e
good morning and welcome to a
subcommittee of executive departments
and administration the subcommittee will
be discussing House Bill 581 and House
Bill
702 um this is a work session it is not
a repeat hearing um however we um we may
solicit some input from those who are
here but that is always at the
discretion of the chair when it's not a
public hearing uh first I would like to
start with House Bill
702 um House Bill 702 is the bill
regarding extra or special duty pay um
looking through this I'm sure that all
of you are aware that we have three
different time groups of employees we
have those who were vested before the
change we have those who were hired but
not vested prior to the change in the
retirement system and we have those who
are hired after the change in the
retirement system those who were hired
prior to July 1st
2011 had extra and special duty pay
included in their compensation for the
retirement system there are Nolo uh
correct me if I'm wrong but I'm pretty
sure that there are no employees that
were hired after July 1st 2011 who were
vested and retired um
so that is important to note because
they are the only state employees who
did not have their extra and special
Duty work go towards the retirement
benefits our bill the bill in front of
us would allow um that extra and special
duty pay to happen in addition to
part-time pay for
retirees um so right now retirees can
work a certain amount of time and if
they work more time than that then they
stop being retirees and go back to being
active active um employees and
contribute to the retirement system as
opposed to draw from the retirement
system looking at looking at the
scenario to me the idea of allowing
somebody to spend more time um working
in a position that in a in a in a
position in a job role that allowed them
to acrw to the retirement
system um and it's basically seems like
double dipping because if you're looking
at people who got that money for extra
and special duty pay going towards their
retirement and now they can do that free
after retirement that seems to be an
inconsistent treatment of a type of work
um so to me it would make sense to do
this for those employees hired after
that change date but this is getting
very very very very ahead of things if
we were to only do that for those people
hired after July 1st of 2011 so with
that if there's anybody who would like
to discuss um representative de yeah
thank you so much Madam chair um I I
want to make sure that I'm fully
understanding this for the people who
were hired afterwards so this this
is allowing them to take the special dut
practice right so if they
were sorry if they were prior to their
retirement pay having special Duty that
never counted towards their retirement
in the first place right um it count for
anybody who was hired prior to J July
1st 2011 it did count towards the
retirement and nobody hired after that
representative sers thank you madam
chair was there a reason why they
switched that up in
2011 um thank you yes that was part of
trying to address the fact that the
retirement system was underfunded and
that was leading to higher property
taxes uh because the employers need to
make more contributions in order to deal
with our um about five billion doll
unfunded liability that's that's
actually contributing significantly to
property taxes today so that that was a
compromise that was
made representative
Dev I just want to make 100% sure that
my understanding on this is correct so
this would apply right now 6
1,664 hours is the max number of hours
that a retired police officer can work
if they were retired before 2019 right
1352 for current retirees are about 26
hours per week and I I understood from
the testimony that the goal of this bill
was to
perhaps um eliminate well someone
suggested to eliminate someone from
retiring then going back to the same
department but these off I think this
applies to the off duty the special duty
pay things like traffic detail
um why we would count that towards the
max number of hours that they're working
because I think that what we're perhaps
on one side it is we're trying to
disincentivize somebody from retiring
and then going back to the same
department but on the other hand we're
short of police officers and so anything
that we can do and it doesn't cost the
state and it doesn't cost the
municipalities anything to do this and
it allows retired police officers to
work more than they currently are
allowed to do Under the current system
so I don't understand what um
public policy we're necessarily
advancing if we say no to this because
if retired police officers want to work
more it's not double dipping um it is
just working more and it the the
municipalities or the state or nobody's
paying in extra to the pension system
for this and it relieves police
departments in the state of having to
take um if retirees do this type of work
having to take active duty police
officers who are paying into the pension
system from doing that type of work so I
guess I'm a little confused about why it
is that we would be against this but but
I'm confident there's a reason I simply
don't understand it thanks well thank
you uh those hours counted towards
retirement those were considered um they
were considered earnable time and they
contributed to the maximum am amount
that contributed to retirement
it does not seem Equitable or fair to
treat the same type of compensation
different for earning retirement and and
for um hours worked during retirement
fairness representative to thank you
madam
chair so I I think that this this bill
however and again correct me if I'm
wrong but this bill speaks to their
ability to work in retirement does it
not
correct so
then again I'm confused why is it that
we would want to limit that what does
that serve us to limit the amount of
time that they can work in their
retirement when that when now they're
retired it does not pay into the pension
system and it doesn't cost us
anything um respectfully paying out of
the retirement system does cost money um
when there are benefits that come from
the retirement system that de that
increases the amount of unfunded
liabilities the more years that an
employee works and the longer it
contributes to the retirement system
that in that decreases the the acred
liabilities because more is being paid
into the system and when somebody is
retired but still working the same hours
same type of hours that contributed to
their retirement then you looking at a
policy issue where um you are treating
the same hours differently for earning
compensation because if we were to move
if currently if somebody works these
extra and special duty hours that and it
plumps them over the level that will
actually contribute to the amount that
is going towards the retirement so you
can't treat it one way in one scenario
in a different way and another that's
not that's not clear and consistent
policy
rep sorry representative
SLA thank you madam chair I just to
clarify this doesn't this would not
serve as a prohibitive measure
preventing employees who are retired
from working special duty this would
simply not count their hours toward
retirement am I understand that
correctly or do I have it way off um
thank you so this bill would include uh
right now the extra special duty pay is
included in their maximum hours worked
so this would mean that these extra
special duty hours are not included in
hours yes representative sellers yeah
thank you m chair so um again this is
for folks that are are already retired
correct correct only people that it
affects correct okay well it's for
people who are retired right now but as
people retire it will also apply to them
okay so quite frankly this would impact
any um police officers in the house or
Senate um
personally representative L I think I
get it thank you uh so that this allows
a retired employee to work more hours
which accumulate their their pension
liability without triggering this return
to work status is it is that what this
is in effect doing it would um thank you
it would allow them to work these hours
that when they were employed counted
towards the amount that they would
receive from retirement and it would
allow them to work those hours without
status representative re thank you so
much mam chair
um for clarity purposes just want to
make sure that what we're talking about
is this this if we were to pass it
communities are in favor of it because
they need more people it doesn't cost
the state anything and these people have
reached the retire these individuals
have reached the retirement age or put
in the number of requisite years in
order to draw their retirement so all
that we're doing if well I perceive what
we're doing if we were to endorse the
vote against this is preventing retirees
from working Revenue generating shifts
that benefit the community and benefit
current status police officers by them
not having to do that so I think that
the communities I think we heard that
the communities are in favor of this um
retired police officers are in favor of
this and that um it there is no fiscal
impact on the state to my to my
understanding and then I know this does
have a fiscal note and it is to I
believe that this is going to go to the
finance committee but the question to us
is the policy question I is to my
understanding um and it's really a
question of whether or not we are going
to force continue to force a limit on
the number of hours a retired police
officer can work special Duty Revenue
generating for
communities thank you thank you so
you're looking at this as a revenue
generator and you're asking retired
police officers ERS to spend more time
um generating revenues for
municipalities is that your
understanding of the
Bill thank you uh Madam chair um that
that's what we were that's what we were
told um in the testimony was that this
is a a revenue generator for
municipalities that when they can use
retirees to do this work instead of
active duty police officers there's a
there's a financial benefit that anur to
communities it's not a revenue generator
for the state I'm not offering that it
is however for the communities at least
that's the testimony that we are I
believe thank you so with that um am I
correct to understand you're saying that
it's basically policing for profit with
the extra special
Duty thank you madam chair um well in
fact it is um this is like traffic duty
to my understanding so these are things
that say for example um the electric
company has to install a new telephone
line and there has to be a police pre
traffic presence there they for example
pay the municipality to do that that's a
system that already exists and isn't
Changed by this bill the question is
whether or not we would allow retirees
to do this work instead of active duty
police officers who are pay who those
people are paying into the retirement
system these individuals are not there
is no cost to the state
from what from all the testimony that we
heard for um if we were to pass this um
thank you do you know if it's only
businesses that are charged this or are
individuals charged this when they need
to do things like f a tree that is close
to the road and somebody says the
traffic needs to be stopped and do you
know how long they may be asked to pay
for a police
detail I don't know the answer to that
question it's interesting question but I
don't think sorry thank you madam chair
uh for the question I don't believe
however it it um whether or not if if
for an example an individual has to f a
tree and if for example that individual
then has to play pay the municipality
for special Duty police
work it to them it's of no consequence I
can't imagine it would be of any
consequence whether or not it's an
active duty police officer or retiree
who's doing that work I can't imagine
that they charge a different different
fee for
that well thank you thank you um the
question is when there's a larger supply
of people to provide that extra and
special Duty does that increase the
incentive to have a 2hour minimum for um
traffic duty at a cost of $850 an hour
as an example so um this is actually an
example from my town somebody was told
that they needed to do that in order to
block traffic and that was 850 an hour
with a 2hour minimum to stand and stop
traffic for five minutes do you think
that there's an incentive to charge
significant fees to individuals to our
constituents um when there is a large
supply of people ready and willing to do
this extra special Duty work thank you
uh Madam chair that's an interesting
question and rather shocking rate
however uh I don't believe that that's
State set rate and I don't think that
the fact that we are M we are allowing
um retirees to do that work is what is
probably driving that
consideration um and and um it I'm still
a little shocked over that rate so um
however the allowing retirees to do this
work is not what's driving that rate uh
respectfully as an economist I think
Supply supply and demand definitely has
an impact and if there's nobody
available to do the duties you won't
check charge it representative
Howard
okay
okay representative salers thank you mam
chair um are we gonna be caucusing for a
couple of minutes so we can if you'd
like to we'll caucus now so we'll take
five minutes to caucus yeah because uh I
going
e
thank you and we are back we are still
discussing House Bill 702
um I will make a motion of inexpedient
to legislate on this bill is there a
second thank you representative sellers
um so the reason behind this is that
state retirees are limited in how many
hours they can work before their status
returns to active employment which
pauses payouts and restarts retirement
contributions this bill seeks to allow
retirees to work more hours and special
and extra Dey without triggering this
return to work status which begs the
question of how the special and extra
duty pay was treated during employment
for all employees hired before July 1st
2011 special and extra duty pay counted
towards earn compensation and average
final compensation only employees after
that date had retirement calculations
unaffected by special and extra duty pay
and the and I believe that it's
inconsistent um to pay out benefits
based on special and duty pay while
exempting the same exact work from the
retirement work
limits um employees hired after July 1st
2011 will not have the same conflict but
there's still many several years until
anybody is retired from that group and
it would be premature to make that
change um did you want to speak to the
second representative sellers thank you
madam chair I was just looking at the
information online that's been submitted
as well and it uh the New
Hampshire the New Hampshire State
permanent firefighters retirement
associate Association is also against
this and then the online um
uh support and opposition is even though
it's not many there was only three in
support and 13 that actually
opposed okay thank
you um so the question is if we want to
continue discussing this or if we just
go ahead with a vote I'm thinking
probably representative de thank you so
much Madam chair um the president of the
New Hampshire Police Association I
believe was Detective Mike guya uh spoke
in favor of this bill um so there's
mixed mixed thoughts on that um and I I
don't I just would like to reiterate
that I don't think that increasing the
supply of people who have the time
without being returned to full duty to
um are is going to increase the cost
because I'm not an economist but I don't
think that's how supply and demand works
if we have more Supply I think that
should actually bring down the cost of
um of uh to individuals and or
municipalities and the municipalities
were in favor of this thank you thank
you uh that actually brings up a very
interesting point that this is treating
police officers different than
firefighters so we're treating two
Public Safety groups very differently um
so with that I um I'll call for the
actually would you like to call for the
vote since you're acting as clerk for
the committee representative
sler sure I can do that um so we'll
start with you I I I'm the chair of this
one so we'll go last for me so who goes
first how about you representative sell
Mo itl yes and then you uh yes and now
the he powered first Power um no no
degrees no no you got it
yes my count is three to two perfect
thank you so this will move to the full
committee with a 3-2 itl vote um next
let's talk about House Bill 581
this is creating a group three
retirement plan for New State Employees
um hired after the effective date of
this bill um so first um with this bill
it would be very important to push this
out another six months because those
will'll be standing this up we'll want
more time in order to do this so um if
if we're assuming we're moving forward
with a positive um recommendation on
this the effective date will not be um
I'll have an amendment that has an
effective date of December 31st 2025 as
opposed to June 30th
2025 um for the employ actually the
employees would be January 1st 2025 we'd
need the group to be stood up prior to
that so we we'll change that date in an
amendment and um if you have still have
your paperwork from the hearing uh
representative McGuire the
representative Dan Maguire um the prime
sponsor of the bill brought an amendment
that
also addresses the Health Insurance
Group Insurance inclusion and the
medical and surgical benefits um and so
these are important changes because the
um group three was left out of those
discussions and by not including this in
an amendment this would put those
medical and surgical benefits um and
health insurance at risk for this group
which was not the intention so this is a
housekeeping Amendment um I would look
to add the date change to January 1st
well so with this bill we had heard some
we had heard quite a bit of testimony
and um we heard some discussions about
Michigan's retirement system after they
moved to a defined contribution plan um
we do have some information from a
retired actuary who cites several
sources um and served on the New
Hampshire Desa Centennial retirement
commission from 19 from 2017 to 2018 who
reviewed the testimony um there are two
studies the Michigan Bas MAA Institute
placed uh um publish a 2011 paper and
they actually estimated that the change
from the defined benefit to the defined
contribution in Michigan saved the state
from recuring between 2.3 billion and
4.3 billion in additional unfunded
liabilities and uh the reason Foundation
looked at this in
2016 and they calculated that the
unfunded liabilities are half a billion
dollars lower during due to the change
so the question is why did the acred
liabilities in the Michigan Define
benefit increase during that period um
Unfortunately they dealt with some of
the same situations that we had here in
New Hampshire that led to the situation
that's increased property taxes to deal
with the acred liabilities they had um
their estimates on the assumed rate of
return were too high so they had
expected it to grow higher and therefore
they did also did not provide enough
money um from in their case from the
state in our case from the employers to
continue with what was necessary in
order to keep the defined benefits plan
functional this is something that New
Hampshire always needs to be vigilant
for because this is how we dug the hole
that's impacting every single Granite
stator when they're paying their
mortgage or cutting a check if they own
their house outright or when they're
paying their landlord because we all
know property taxes flow
through um essentially it's been a
success moving to defined contribution
in Michigan not the failure that some
have made it out to be um there's also I
provided a little spreadsheet that
looked at what would happen if somebody
had joined a deferred a defined
contribution instead of a defined P
Benefit Plan back in um
1985 uh 40 years ago and
this would assume a $25,000 first salary
a 3 and a half% annual raise and the
contribution limits that are in the bill
so that's 7% for the employee and 5% for
the employer
um honestly these this 40 years hasn't
been great for the market you know the
80s 80s were fun I wish I had been
investing at that point but I wasn't uh
my investment Horizon started with the
basically around the 2000 crash with
the.com bubble um so and I know that
it's been a pretty hard slog since then
but even looking at a time frame where
in the last 25 years really weren't the
best of investment times um a person in
this scenario under the defined benefit
would have about a $558,000 a year
benefit but the defined contribution
would be
$99,000 so we have the issue that when
you're involved in the market you're not
capping the gains but the defined
benefit program does cap the gains which
is one of the inherent flaws with the
system um so given that this is just a
very very small move to sort of dip our
toe into defined contribution only for
state employees and which allows some
other only for state employees this is a
way to move forward and also allow
people to have a bit more flexibility in
how much time they spend working at the
State versus working in Private Industry
this bill does immediately vest all
contributions um and I will also be
adding to the amendment um a delayed
vesting for the employer contribution
you know it's not quite fair for
somebody to come and work six months and
then take that 5% of their pay with them
you know that doesn't happen in private
plans so I will be adding um a two-year
weight for 100% vesting which is
consistent with many many private
employer plans that basically means that
you're not taking the state's the
state's contribution until you've spent
enough time working for us
so with that I will be working on an
amendment for that representative sers
yeah thank you mam Cher with that uh
delayed investment will the state still
be putting aside that 5% per paycheck
per pay yes they will they do okay thank
you and um that 5% if somebody leaves
before the two years would sort of be
stranded in the plan but that can go to
some of the overhead costs as well
because it's not free to set somebody up
on the program
um so it makes sense to allow that to
stay within the
system representative SLA something I
just thought of uh thank you madam chair
uh the exit return uh rules around this
a lot of private employers that I've
worked for in the past have similar
investment schedules however if you
return after some period of time you can
pick up sort of where you left off would
this legislation cover that scenario and
is it something we'd like to address um
thank you I'm not sure if it has that
but that would actually I think be a
benefit because if somebody is coming in
and out of Public Service uh when
they're needed in the state and then
earning a free market paycheck when
they're not needed in the state I think
everybody representative
Howard yeah I'm still uh in opposition
to this legislation as I wanted to just
kind of clar ify a few things as the uh
defined contributions plan uh that we're
looking at is going to guarantee a
payout based off of what you paid in
versus the uh defined benefits plan is
the fact that we know what you're going
to get at the end of your service it's
the fact that right now when we're
looking at this plan and we're trying to
recruit public employees we want them to
look at their future and not necessarily
have to worry about whether or not
they're going to be able uh to live on
their pension
so I can't really support that because I
also am under the belief that this is
going to increase our state's unfunded
liability because we're not going to be
paying down the liability that we've
built up uh the unfunded liability that
we've built up so far and that is a very
large concern because when comparing
some of the uh the stat statistics I
mean
I it's just it it doesn't
sound that attractive thank you H thank
you um if you look in the text of the
bill at the bottom of the first page um
the crude liability contribution
percentage will still be charged to the
state as the employer so that this will
not be drawing down on that contribution
to the unfunded liability um um we are
on a plan and a track to have the
unfunded liability paid off by
2039 um you know not quite as far out as
that new Massachusetts train station but
still potentially sooner than exit 4A if
it continues on the same path that's
gone on um but as we look at that we
need to work both make make sure that
everything we're doing is still
addressing that unfunded liability and
this bill does by still requiring that
percentage to be that would be charged
um to go to um into the acred liability
for these group three
employees representative re thank you so
much Madam chair um the I think that we
heard some testimony um on this bill and
including from the sea
seu um
about what impact creating essentially a
defined contribution plan would have on
the ability to recruit and retain
employees and right now that element of
predictability
um for public servants uh once they work
a certain number of hours years Etc in
order to benefit from our retirement
plan and draw their
pensions we heard that the portability
element of this so if you have a defined
contribution as opposed to a defined
pension would not actually help for us
to retain employees in fact it creates
an incentive uh to leave over what
exists currently and
given how hard it is in this environment
to attract and retain Talent by creating
a essentially a third program to find
benefit we are going to have some
unintended con uh consequences in our
communities in our ability to attract
and retain employees so I am against
this I think it encourages people to
leave um in less than 10 years right now
people are working towards that 10year
Horizon um um and so for that reason I
and and many others I'm against this
including that if we do this I believe
and to your point earlier yes our
unfunded liability is set to pay off and
we're continuing to contribute to that
however that unfunded liability my
understanding is and again we're not the
financial piece of this only the policy
piece but those assumptions were built
upon this not exist this uh this defined
contribution plan not
existing thank you um I am also very
interested in attracting and retaining
people um I'm very interested in
attracting and retaining young families
to New Hampshire with affordable a an
affordable lifestyle here um and while
the role of go government is important
it isn't more important than Private
Industry and it isn't more important
than all of those jobs that are created
and bring people here um as we look to
have a Dynamic Workforce and as we look
to make sure that New Hampshire is
actually affordable for people both
starting out and continuing on um I
think that it's very important to
address this representative sellers yeah
thank you madam chair I mean this more
aligns with the corporate world as we
know it today anyhow I mean I don't
think there's hardly any if except maybe
if you're in the unions there are
pensions anymore everybody is 401K
status and you vested after so long a
period of time so to portability yeah
it's important to young people because
there's looking at that that's their
money you know and that's their part of
their benefit package and if they decide
to leave after five years because maybe
they got a bad boss or whatever they
they found something where that's going
to pay $100,000 more you know they
should be able to take their money and
and go at that point sure we want to
keep them we can but at the same time
this aligns with the corporate world and
everybody's used to at
401K representative Howard thank you I I
think that we need to be thinking about
this in terms of professional
experience the reason that we have the
plan that we have right now the Divine
benefits plan is because we're trying to
keep people here we want people to stay
here we want them to uh improve and
educate themselves alongside their
profession so that they are better and
when we're looking at things like
detectives like firefighters people who
are public servants and are not going to
have the opportunity to shift their
career to a private space it's the fact
that you know what are you going to do
if you're if you spent your entire
career in law enforcement and you are a
detective you want to try and you you
want to tr and hold on to that person
because they have a lot of knowledge in
being able to solve cases same thing
with people who have experience in the
firefighter industry they have
experience that again I mean we have a
member on uh our our full Edna committee
uh Mr PE representative Pearson who is
uh has a degree in uh firefighter
engineering and that is something where
we want to make sure that we can keep
him here because we don't want him to
leave to go to another state and I feel
the same thing when we're talking about
teachers and teachers especially because
these are people who are educating our
kids they're trying to improve the next
generation of Granit Staters and educate
them to the highest level possible and
we want to make sure that we are
providing for these people we've been
struggling I mean in my school district
in straford and barington half of our
teachers in straford do not have their
credentials they're currently in the
process of getting them and it's just
like where are the teachers that were
there when I were growing up they're all
retired how do you recruit those people
to come in if we're not necessarily
providing higher pay or better
benefits thank you uh thank you this
bill does not address firefighters it
does not invite address teachers
and it does not address any employees of
political subdivisions this is only for
state employees representative
SLA I'll get it right one of these days
no worries thank you madam chair um so I
I think uh representative Howard
representative re ra very compelling
arguments um and I I think there's
another way to think about
attractiveness I think attractiveness is
important to to any profession I kind of
lived through the shift from pension
into 401K world and was very scary and I
understand it's very reasonable to be
cautious or or sort of skeptical of of
that transition I certainly was when
when I went through it um so I I I want
to just put some food for thought maybe
in terms of you know how how to think
about this in a way that might be less
scary um the idea of uh being forced to
work in a job you might not like for 10
years to get a pension is not very
attractive to me anyway it it doesn't
seem fair to the employee and especially
in terms of improving the conditions of
that that a worker experiences on the
job the most powerful tool they have is
to to leave you know it forces the
employer to make
decisions around improving the
conditions of that that particular job
in order to attract Talent right so
we're very worried about attracting
talent I think it's very important it's
a very correct thing to be worried about
but locking someone in or making them
chase a 10year Time Horizon in order to
get something uh that they should have
anyway like they're working they should
have money going into their account
today um I think that's more attractive
to me personally you know people people
have different opinions on that but it's
it's a way to think about it where maybe
it's not so scary um the the other thing
I think in terms of
attractiveness um it would terrify me
and dishearten me entirely to have to go
before a board like us every year or
every two years to beg for a cost of
living adjustment so it's having a
political process in the way of my
happiness in retirement is something
that would not be attractive to me and I
feel very I I have nothing but empathy
for people who have to come before this
committee and literally beg us to give
them a raise
it's I I don't I would not want to
impose that on someone and so this gives
us an opportunity to to provide a
retirement with dignity for individuals
who otherwise would have to come before
us and and have a political movement in
play it's hard to do it's hard to
achieve and they're they're
Unfortunately they they to the state
they are no longer are are sort of prime
targets right they're they're lower on
the scale of political uh they're not
they're not doing work for us right
they're not our current employees so
they're they're less of a priority and
that's unfortunate but it's the
unfortunate political reality and it's
it's I don't think it's attractive um
what else uh the other the last point
I'll make and I'll wrap it up is
that a
defined what I'm sorry I'm gonna screw
up the words a a defined um the current
pension system is one where the state
can dip in and the state has already
created rules where we've dipped in and
created an unfunded liability and
created incredible uncertainty for
retirees in the future and so what a
defined contribution plan achieves is
shifting the onus to the individual it's
their property now they can do with what
they will where the state can't dip into
it and potentially endanger their
retirement which is to me it's very very
concerning so thank you representative
Howard and then representative Sal thank
you I mean on the flip side though we're
looking at potentially endangering
people who already are retired in the
fact that if we are limiting how much
money we are trying to put into paying
down our unfunded liability we're not
necessarily going to uh be able to cover
people's pensions in the future uh
people who we currently have obligations
to and so that's kind of a big concern
because whenever we have a big shift in
policy like this there's going to be a
change in how much money we actually
have available to pay down that unfunded
liability and I feel like instead of
taking care of the people who already
understood the plan that they were
getting into we are basically ripping
the rug under out from underneath that
thank
you representative sers yeah thank you m
chair so just to be clear if I'm a new
hire as a firefighter in my
town that person is not a state employee
and it's going under the pension plan
that's there but only the state
employees that we hire after July 1st
will go on this new plan only state
employees and then so if I'm a teacher
as well the teacher is going to be on
the old retirement plan or the
retirement plan that's out there now
right that's correct okay thank you um
so I think that um representative de
thank thank you very much I'll be brief
um Madam chair uh this if this were to
pass this is going to cost the state
more money and the reason for that even
with a two-year vesting period Madam
chair um
the while the employees will contribute
to a def if the employees were to
contribute to a defined contribution
plan yes that increases their
portability certainly however under this
uh
provision or rather currently um if you
are an employee and you are paying into
the system you can still take the money
that you invested so this wouldn't
change that what you can't do is take
the money that state taxpayers invested
in order to uh retain you so that's
number one and number two um this bill
or something similar has been before uh
the New Hampshire house repeatedly I
believe in 2000 it was HB 1591 it was
deemed um it wented in our study 458 in
2001 was deemed inexpedient to legislate
in 2005 uh 708 in expedient to legislate
346 you all can read um so I just we've
repeatedly um stopped the state from
creating a new system that would
ultimately cost the state more in the
short term at a time when we have
Revenue considerations um not being as
high as we might like them to be so for
that reason I am uh going to be voting
against this uh thank you I I'm
concerned well I I'll save more of my
discussion for when we move this um
forward but at this point given the time
I'm going to move uh I'm going to make a
motion that we will amend the bill as I
had noted to change the start date for
these employees to January 1st 2026 to
have a two-year wait until the employee
contribution is vested um and to add
that to the amendment that was brought
forth by representative Dan Maguire um
and with that I'll make a motion of
ought to pass as it would be amended by
that Amendment we're playing by Senate
roles here we don't need to have it
written in front of us for a
subcommittee NE second thank you so if
you'd like to call the rooll that's me
again thank you madam
chair all right representative sellers
yes uh I'll
vote Yes now you're on first day on the
mic uh yes from me representative re
no and representative Howard
no and cherle on yes that's three to two
thank you I will get that drafted and
with that I'll close our subcommittee
you
e
uh good morning welcome to Edna I'm
opening the public hearing on house
bills
Aaron thank
good morning Madam chair and members of
uh Edna um for the record my name is
representative Judy Aaron I represent
suin County District 4 the towns of
aworth Goan langon lemster and
Washington
I'm here today to introduce HB 694 FN
requiring leases of land buildings or
space by state agencies to be at fair
market value I filed this bill in
response to a request by my County
manager who deals with these types of
leases and as the latest executive
branch operating lease inventory
published by the department of
administrative services on one July 2024
there are approximately 90 active leases
I have that passed that list on to you
this bill requires that renewal on
property leased by state agencies be
leased at a rate which would be
considered a fair market value or rate
unless a submarket rate is agreed to by
the property owner many times the state
will present a take it or leave it
proposal for a renewed lease the state
has forced terms of Leasing Property on
entities and in many cases that amount
of the renewed lease does not cover the
real cost of the property in question
this downshifts costs and local
taxpayers have to pay the difference so
for example in Salen County the state
forces a lease agreement amount on a
renewal of leasing a courthouse Which is
far less than market value of the space
and the taxpayers have to pay the
difference in what the taxes are that
must be paid and any other incurred
costs associated with the property in
question since the state does rfps for
new leases or whenever they feel it's
appropriate this bill would only apply
to lease renewals which is good because
it allows for a recalibration of the
lease payment in the event inflation
blows up over a three or fiveyear period
as would happen the last uh to us
recently or if there are emerging
factors that drastically impact the cost
of commercial leases in either direction
the language here does not address the
other elements that are included in
leases such as as utilities and
custodial services and things like that
the state calls this a quote
Consolidated lease but those terms are
really add-ons that should be negotiated
in addition to the Baseline cost of the
building since those costs may or may
not be included in other leases done by
the state we didn't really want to
complicate this bill with that in
general though we feel that lease
renewal should be negotiated on fair
market value and not just a continuation
of whatever the lease amount was in
Prior agreements and does not become a
take it or leave it offer Suman County
Manager Derek furland is here today and
he can answer any specific questions
that you may have about the leasing
process um I'm just pretty much here to
introduce the bill to you and um and
give you just sort of a an
overall uh view of of what we're trying
to accomplish and I do have copy of my
testimony that I'm going to pass out
thank you are there any specific
questions for representative Aaron rep
representative
long if the property owner doesn't feel
like the lease offered by the state is
fair why don't they just say no to it
well sometimes you have a property that
has like such a specific use that um you
know it might it might be that they
would by saying no it might cause quite
a disturbance and it might also um cause
them to have to maybe make some men
major renovations to the building
property in order to make it adequate to
be able to offer for some other
purpose I have a general question I
don't know if you have the answer but
why on Earth is the state owning all
these properties I have no idea sing
them I have no idea oh thank you anyone
else all right thank you representative
thank you madam chair and Ladies and
Gentlemen of the committee uh as
representative Aaron stated my name is
Derek furland I'm the county man manager
for Sullivan County I've been in the
position for uh nearly 8 years and so
during this period I've had the
opportunity to participate in several uh
lease negotiations with the state
regarding the Sullivan County Superior
and Probate Court space so it's through
these experiences my just an observation
um as a process oriented person I was I
was a little bit astonished that there
didn't seem to be any overarching
guidance or foundation in state law to
guide the process so as representative
stated a lot of times the state's
position was offered as a take it or
leave it type of uh negotiation or
proposal and so my uh retort to that was
usually well what should we be paying
because it seems to me that a fair
process that we we get approach it from
the perspective of both parties since
we're both political subdivisions needs
to account for the state's interests in
budget certainty and trying to limit
budget growth but also be mindful of
Sullivan County's taxpayers because any
shortfall in our Revenue budget has to
be made up on the uh on the proper taxes
so trying to reach that fair objective
process just seemed to be um there seem
to be a missing linoln state
law uh doing some research I I found
that RSA uh 4 colon 29 talks about when
the state purchases real estate and uh
RSA 4 col 30 talks about when the state
acquires property via eminent domain and
leasing is really only covered in RSA 4
39b but that's only for the approval of
leases that exceed 5 years there's
nothing that really talks about the
process by which the state would acquire
real estate through a lease as
representative Aaron mentioned there are
about 90 leases in about 2 million
square feet I summarized those
statistics in my letter uh so there's
there's quite a bit of physical plant
that the state needs to conduct its
business and in conversations with my
peers both at the New Hampshire
Association of counties as well as the
municipal Managers Association uh there
are a lot of political subdivisions that
are engageed with the state for leased
space of various types whether it's
through DHHS um or the court systems
so it just seems to me that if there was
an objective process to guide these
negotiations it would be a more fair and
perhaps efficient use of everyone's
times that way we're not trying to just
beat each other up and get the best rate
for in the state's case the state or in
our case the for the county and so using
some sort of fair market value data even
if it was a range that was based on just
some simple research or employing the U
some information from commercial reals
to help guide the process I think we
could very quickly reach a reasonable
range that's mutually agreeable to both
parties uh representative eron also
mentioned the three traditional elements
to what we see from the Bureau of Court
Administration for the lease which is
the value of the space and then
utilities and custodial Services which
are all baked in and so what we're
proposing is that the the value of the
space have this uh objective process to
use something that's grounded in fair
market value the other two elements
ought to simply be based on actual costs
and the the catch-up provision could be
that when it's renegotiated for example
we have a five-year contract for um
electricity um and if the lease is
renegotiated in the middle of that
process it should be based on the actual
cost if in a subsequent negotiation the
change of electricity has changed uh we
should be able to make up for that
either up or down so that way it's
always a a fair and accurate reflection
of actual
costs so in summary I think the benefits
of this of this bill would be to provide
an objective standard for both parties
to work towards uh I think it would save
some time I think it would be fair to
the state and its budget concerns and it
would be fair to our taxpayers and and
the County's budget concerns thank you
for your time and pending your questions
thank you I have a
question is Sullivan County responsible
for providing space for the court or is
the is the court system responsible for
getting its own space uh the answer is
both so the right now for all 10
counties the state owns Five of its
Court complexes and it and it and it
rents five in fact in the capital budget
for this budget cycle there is a
proposal to build a Consolidated court
for Sullivan County so if that's funded
and when it's built uh we would actually
no longer have a court lease for the uh
Superior and probate court but the state
also leases Circuit Court space with the
Town of Newport which is in a separate
building it's actually about a couple
hundred feet down the road from ours and
also Court space and Claremont for that
circuit court Okay so so they're leasing
it from you uh in in those two cases
with Newport and Claremont the state
actually has leases directly with the
municipalities so the only lease with
Probate all right because I'm trying to
get it straight in my head whether this
is to address the state owning property
and leasing it to to someone else or
whether it's the state Leasing Property
other people own that exactly that's
it's the ladder so the county owns those
buildings and the state leases those
from US ah and they don't pay enough to
cover the cost of operating the building
correct okay and M was mix I was
confused as to what was going on and if
I may if I could actually respond to a
representative Long's question to
representative Aaron uh about what
happens if we simply don't offer the
space so we've we we tried to do that
not to be um hard negotiators but two
lease negotiations ago we actually
needed some space for the Sheriff's
Office which is part of our complex
because they had they were just they
were out as admin space and so we were
hoping to take what's used as a backup
courtroom but it's also used during
grand jury and so I said during the
lease negotiation that space is no
longer available and it became obvious
to me I was very new in my position so I
just thought well I'll just tell them
it's not available as simple as that uh
it's not as simple as that it would have
been very very difficult for the Court's
Mission um our courthouse is in a it's
in a Newport town hall building that was
built in 1885 so it's not like it's very
flexible space and in terms of being
able to uh reconfigure it and it just
gets to where we shouldn't be having an
adversarial position where it's like
well sorry go find your own Court space
because we can appreciate uh the
position that will put the the state in
in terms of uh executing its its
judicial Mission so it's a there's some
there's some give and take with that but
at the end of the day it's really not in
our best interest to make life difficult
for the state um by not offering spaces
we thought there was maybe an
opportunity by trimming some of the
square footage we're like Hey we're to
save you some money you're going to have
less square footage to lease and so
that'll it'll help the state's budget
but um they had to weigh the impact to
their mission by not having that space
uh compared to the benefit of having
less uh budget to pay for it so it's
just it's it's pretty tricky and then we
didn't want to get it to a point where
we said well we're just not going to
offer it and have the state proceed with
the eminent domain uh to take the
property so just it's not a good look
and not something that we wanted to
spend a lot of time and energy on thank
you repres
this just occurred to me I've never
thought this thought before Public
Schools pay no taxes because they render
a public service the state is rendering
a public service why should it pay any
rent at
all that's a great question I mean the
the statute goes goes back a long time
uh when the state took over
administration of the courts in the mid
80s uh it was all owned by the county
and operated by the county so I'm I can
only assume that back in the ' 80s when
that change was made
administratively uh that for the state
to take over something that it didn't
previously own or run that had to be
part of the arrangement but I I can't
speak to the history other than my
speculation on that all right thank you
representative Leon and then Pearson uh
thank you madam shair and uh thank you
uh when you were answering that question
it sounds like if you tell the state
that they need to pay more they will
just take it by eminent domain was that
a correct understand they may just take
it by an domain was that a correct
understanding I I think if it gets
Beyond I mean there'd be I think a lot
of steps in the process between that
negotiation an eminent domain I mean the
last round was was was a good example so
I did my calculation of what I thought a
fair market value was based on uh
comparable properties in Sullivan County
uh and then I added in the cost of
electricity which during the last lease
negotiation for us it had doubled and so
when the lease was originally negotiated
for a three-year term it was uh at
electricity was about seven and a half
cents a kilowatt on the supply side and
then eventually we ended up paying
nearly 14 and so I said hey look this
this has gone up a lot um as well as our
custodial cost because at the time we
had an um an a a staff member and of
course with Cola going up with the the
postco inflation those costs went up so
I said from where we are now which was
roughly $14 and change per square foot I
said I think it needs to be $17 a square
foot when you look at all the costs and
and um you know they came back and said
well we there's no way we can do that
because the state at least for the
Bureau of Court administrative
Administration they've got an internal
limit where if the if the uh price goes
up more than 5% they have to go back and
and renegotiate or recompete basically
put out a a request for proposals to you
know go go find some space somewhere
else and I said well good luck with that
I mean first of all it's highly
specialized space it's a court you're
never going to find another vacant Court
just waiting to be rented and if you're
asking somebody to go build you one I
can guarantee you it's going to cost you
a lot more than the 14 and change that
you're you know proposing to pay us so
but through that back and forth we
settled on what we thought was a
reasonable number we we got I think a 5%
increase in one year and then this past
negotiation we did a two-year lease with
two and a half% raises each year it was
more than the state wanted to pay it was
less than what I wanted but I felt like
it was a fair negotiation and and to me
we're we're now inching a lot closer to
what I think we should be uh but guess
what if our if our electric rate goes
down at the next bill then I think you
know the state should see a benefit from
that too so it it kind of goes you know
up and down a little bit when when we
bake in all those other um elements that
are part of the Consolidated lease but I
don't think it would just go to answer
your question um more directly we go
right to the eminent domain stage
because that would just be like duking
it out which to me is it would be
counterproductive okay thank you R
Pearson and then
gr thank you madam chair uh I've kind of
got
a it's more than one question because it
has to do with this who created
this that is uh it's online and it's
through the department of administrative
Services well the department of
administrative Services needs to
determine whether Salem is a town or a
city because it's listed as both on this
chart um and I'm trying to understand
leur the city is where the building in
question is
located
well they have it Salem's listed as a
town and a city on here more than one
line so but I'm trying to understand
because I'm looking at this the City of
Salem is leasing something from
itself I'm not quite sure is this
no
no this is all all yeah it looks like
you're right the same with City of
Rochester in the city of
coner it's not a good look for the
state if they're producing this
but these this chart contains properties
that the state is leasing from somebody
is except yeah all righta help me out
thank you I believe the left column is
the agency and that is the agency that
is is leasing a street address that is
located in a certain city and the Lor is
the owner of the property that was my
understanding of this I def didn't
create it but that seems to be the
logical interpretation of this and this
this clearly excludes The Liquor
Commission oh yeah it's got to because I
know the liquor commission's renting
interesting so I'm just looking at this
legislation Madam chair if I can direct
my thought process to
you
uh this this I understand the concept
here right the state is
leasing space that's owned by another
political subdivision that's what we're
seem to be talking about here um but the
the language of this bill doesn't
really separate that out it really just
covers all of it regardless of who if
they were to be leasing a a separate
building not owned by the count and I
think some of these are not owned by the
by the they seem to not be sub yes okay
so
um this is just the the brush on this is
Broad that's that's what I'm trying to
guess convey that I mean I appreciate
you coming here in in the your specific
circumstance but I just want to I just
think we need to be clear that this is
not just a state versus County thing
this is this is bigger than that right
right the the uh the thing is like for
example they're leasing the oplc office
space in Eagle square and knowing the
commercial landlord that's doing it
they're probably paying fair market
value or close to it
the the trouble is that the counties are
and other political subdivisions are
somewhat
disadvantaged
um ially like you say with unique things
like cour houses represent gr you had a
question did thank you so listening
to
um hang on a second Mr F fernal and um
it just does the language in the bill
actually say what you wanted to
say I just want to make sure that the
language in the bill seems rather simple
compared to all these convoluted
examples that we've heard and I don't
know whether or not it's representative
what oops somebody else has their hand
up okay okay representative slots are
you are you familiar with this
not necessarily but I I I think I might
see where you're going and I don't know
how this legislation is enforcable given
if an agreement is reached between two
parties for a dollar or a billion
dollars who is the determiner of fair
market
value okay well my question was a little
is is encompasses that but I just want
to make sure that this indeed it seems
simple compared to all the other the
examples that we've heard because in
some
cases the um count the state is leasing
property from the county another place
it's from a private person or a private
company and maybe in some cases it's to
itself I'm not even sure so that's why I
just want to make you know that's the it
seems like the bill is too simple for
all the examples that you listed right
it I think Simplicity was one of the
objectives just to make sure we could
start the conversation and not get
bogged down in detail because there are
different types of leases
whether it's the Consolidated lease or
if the state other state agencies might
do it differently and I'm not aware of
what all the state agencies do because I
only deal with the state when it comes
to the court lease so I wasn't sure if
the process would be augmented by a
rulemaking uh kind of a companion um
element to provide some of that detail
and address unique or specific cases but
that keeping the the language of the law
uh simple generic would be a better way
to get it started rather than bombard
the committee with a lot of complicated
things you we're all trying to figure
out what what it applies to what it
doesn't for my view I think this should
apply to when the state is leasing to
other political subdivisions because I
don't feel like I think feel like the
private Market is going to take care of
itself when it comes to a private
developer because they can tell the
state sorry go look somewhere else it's
just a little bit more complicated I
think for counties Andor towns and
cities to be in that same position with
a state because like I said before it's
that's where you've got a courthouse
that you uh don't have much use for
representative Howard I was uh thank you
madam chair I was just about to
reference the straford county courthouse
because right now uh one of the things
that we're doing is trying to figure out
our lease with the uh with the state and
it's kind of the question uh of if you
were not able to fill your Courthouse
what are the other possible tenants that
would be able to come in that's a great
question we we would have to look for
well our case is really talk about
oneoff and very unique we have actually
a reverter clause in the deed for the
Superior Court space that as soon as the
court vacates that space will go back to
the Town of Newport as I said before
it's in the town hall building so on the
on the ground floor is the superior
court and above it is the Newport opera
house if anybody's ever been to the Town
of Newport and so the deed language
again going back to the
1800s um and so it it provided that
space to the county so long as it's used
as a superior court so once that stops
it'll go back to the town it'll be the
town's issue I've actually had some
initial brainstorming conversations
especially after we saw the capital
budget come out and I said well what
happens if and when the state builds a
court what do you think you would do and
they think what they'll do is relocate
their uh municipal offices into the
courthouse because the the uh courtroom
makes a great place for uh select board
Chambers so I think that's maybe what
they would do but that's that's a
decision for them for our side the
probate court is in space that's owned
by the county and we would look to
perhaps consolidate some administrative
offices that are in a separate building
that would allow us to then perhaps
dispose of or convert that building to
housing or something like that something
that would be productive uh for the Town
of Newport and the county as a
whole representative scitech uh speaking
of distinctions you mentioned what could
you do with an
courthouse uh isn't there a big
difference between
a courthouse being rented by the state
and office space where that's fungible
you can leave oplc can leave or whatever
uh Department of admin um Employment
Security whatever they're not that's not
real off I could see where this might
apply more to a court building what are
you going to do with it so um should
there not be a distinction between the
two in the
bill uh I guess I'd be open for or I
mean it's really not my decision I guess
I just wanted simplicity so it seems
like yes there it's hard to get a comp I
I'll freely admit when I went to see
what I thought fair market value was I
looked at primarily the age of other
commercial space availability of parking
did it have similar amenities um yes
there there's not like 15 other courts
in Sullivan County to use as my
Benchmark so you have to just do the
best you can that's why I think there
needs to be uh more than a modum of
common sense to say well look we think
it's in the range of $10 to $12 square
foot do we think that's reasonable yes
or no what did you use for comps that's
what I would Envision and hope to see
this process that results from this bill
but right now with nothing in state law
it does come down to here's what we're
going to pay you take it or leave it and
I say no I don't like that and then
where do you go from there uh and it
just it seems like a it's it's it's sets
us up to be adversarial and I don't
think that's the in the best interest of
either the state or uh the political
subdivisions representative long oh and
then and then de
uh is there anything that prevents the
state from taking over the full
operating cost of the property rather
amount I don't think there's anything
that prevents it I guess it'd be maybe a
question for das to see if that's just
that's just not how they typically do
things um I'm not sure what drives the
things that they do or how they do them
uh those things could probably change
but I'm not
sure and I believe that the the
procurement for other agencies is
different from the courts
um well I I have seen like in the
register like when DHHS puts out for
space they say we're seeking 20,000
square feet to be used and they'll kind
of give a brief description of you know
whatever the DHHS function happens to be
um and they'll put it on the street for
as long as it takes to get somebody to
to submit a a proposal U I know in
Claremont they've tried that in the past
and then they you know let those solicit
expired because they didn't have any
offerers but um other than the 5%
triggering threshold that I mentioned
before which drives the state to then
seek other courts which again I don't
think is a very pragmatic uh way to do
it because I just don't think you're
going to get Court space uh that way but
um I think there may be some differences
in how the solicitations are managed but
I'm not I'm not entirely sure okay thank
you representative freeze thank you
madam chairwoman um thank you for coming
in today Mr ferland and I just have a
quick question for you is um when you
were negotiating with the state of New
Hampshire did it change your negotiating
posture um when the entity across the
table had the power of eminent
domain no they don't wield it um so it's
just we we have productive and fruitful
conversations even if there we don't we
don't always agree and it's never gotten
to the point where they're like you know
take this or else they've never done
that so it's been uh like I said the the
the conversations haven't always been
easy but it's never never got into this
the brinksmanship where you know I'm
like no I'm not going to offer it to you
and they say well if you don't do that
I'm going to take it by eminent domain
it never crossed their lip so I don't
feel like it's um I first of all I don't
know how long it would take I don't know
politically how that would look um I and
into their credit they've never even
intimated that that's a path that they
wanted to consider they just want to get
a deal done um but we're just
approaching it from two very different
perspectives and I just feel like this
would help simplify it thank you all
representa I do have one question on the
process other than keeping this
sheet does the department of
administrative Services assist it all or
do are you the ones that you're
negotiating with them or are you in
negotiating with agency themselves the
negotiations are through the Bureau of
Court Administration uh which is under
the
Das okay uh follow up if it wasn't a
court though
is is it the only is this really the
only time that state agencies and the
state state a is it through the court
system is that the trouble spot or is or
is it just other agencies as well I
can't speak to the other agencies yeah I
I can only assume that a similar process
but I don't know okay thank
you yeah it looks like there are we have
someone from the County Association to
talk about other than solivan
County other questions thank you very
much thank you this is not as simple as
I thought it
Horgan thank you Madame chair members of
the committee my name is Kate Horan I'm
from the New Hampshire Association of
counties and I am also pin chitting this
morning for administrator Bower from
stord County who got called back when he
was halfway here so um the association
and straford County do both support um
the uh House Bill
694 um we do view it as another tool in
the toolbox for counties when
negotiating um to reduce some pressure
from County taxpayers who are having to
make up the additional costs I think
administrator Farland did a great job
explaining the issues and the concerns
um and I just want to reiterate that
those are concerns that all five
counties who rent space to the state
share um that um negotiations can be
difficult and so just putting some
parameters around what a lease would
look like or uh in addition to the
eminent domain and buying property would
be a benefit to both sides and I'm happy
so that that there are the five counties
least space to the state yep and that's
for um looks like the Hillsboro County
and
um and plus the court yes Madam chair th
those are all for court or Courthouse
Services um so like Hillsboro County
rents Courthouse services not
necessarily a courthouse to the state
but it's it's property within Hillsboro
County's County
Complex okay yeah I i' see there the
hill the hooksen courthouse for
example and and if if the committee I
don't think the association would have
an opposition changing this to just
apply to political
subdivisions okay represent Lon uh thank
you madam chair and thank you for
bringing this perspective it does seem
pretty clear that with these specialized
locations there's not the same Market
competitiveness and so um I also would
appreciate if you have any ideas on how
to determine those far fair market
values um I would appreciate to hear
that sure thank you representative and
we did meet last fall I want to say
October November with uh commissioner
Arling house to discuss this issue um
and didn't come to a resolution but I
can certainly take this idea the county
administrators are meeting this Friday
at 2 o' and see if they may have some
suggestions that we could give to the
committee around how to determine fair
market value a followup um thank you and
as a followup um they may be a little
bit better about determining these when
they are the less sore are there any
situations where the state leases from
the
counties that you know of I'm sorry that
the counties lease from the state that
you know of not that I can think of off
the top of my head but I'm certainly
happy to ask the group on Friday I can
give you one out of Rockingham yes
please represent Pearson so the
um disgusting building from the state
it's actually in really poor shape it's
got a ton of mold in it and it's part of
it's It's the lease is ending because
we're building the the county the new
County structure but in in the past yeah
the county has leased from the state in
in bruntwood so that might be a rare
example but it it is one okay followup
as another followup I guess my question
is if it may make sense that both when
the state is leasing is the less or and
the less e if it would make sense to
have this designated as Fair M market
value because when you have parties on
both sides of that equation it may be
easier to determine far fair market so I
don't know if that would be something to
bring back to the counties and ask them
what they think I would be happy to
bring that back to them representative
and I I don't think we're trying trying
to be unfair to the state we want to
have a balanced approach for everyone
all right representative
long are you aware of any instances of
the State uh either using imminent
domain to take a property from the
county or uh abusing its power in some
other way like cutting off some kind of
funding if the county doesn't cooperate
in what they're trying to do thank you
representative long I can't speak for
the entire history of County government
because
it's the longest form of government in
the in the state of New Hampshire um I'm
sure the state has taken some eminent
domain at some point in our 200 plus
year history but um nothing that has
come up in our discussions as of late
okay all right thank you I was hoping we
could fin are are there any other
questions first all right see there's
someone else who wishes to testify
M please
it thank you madam chair uh Derek
furland Sullivan County uh uh there's
just a drafting error so in the uh under
the 439g fair market value of state
agency leases it references RSA 21-gon 5
section three that should be section
four state agencies are defined in
section four of that RSA um section
three talks about advisory committees um
that was that's actually in
439b so it's wrong there too so if we're
making this change it' be nice to fix it
in both
places that was all thank you I think we
will
uh this has turned out to be much more
complicated than it looked at first uh
first reading and I think it will go to
the U other subcommittee which is
carefully finished all its other work so
we'll we'll take take a look at this
one all right anyone else all right then
I will close the hearing on House Bill
694 and open the hearing on House Bill
good morning please uh good morning I
presume you're representative Gilmore I
am representative Gilmore excellent
please introduce House Bill 780 and
explain that to us well I don't think
it's going to be too
complicated and that's what we always
hope
well I think we're going to succeed here
um first I should say that uh this was
not not um anything that came from the
Secretary of State's office they were
blindsided just as you are
today and um but Dave or Aaron uh
Secretary of State or deputy secretary
of state would be here except they are
at archives right now at a bout law
commission meeting similarly the archist
Ashley would be here but she has a
meeting at 11:00 and could not make it
so little bad timing in ter terms of
them but um they both did want me to
mention their strong support for this
legislation
um many of you do not know me I've been
out for 22 years and I did surve five
terms back between 88 and 04 and 02 um
but and this is where I meet yesterday
um so it's sort of weird to be back in
the same room again but another
um the origins of this bill came when I
was having a discussion with Ashley um
who was only the third archist in the
history of the state of our 50 60 years
of Heaven archives and when she got the
job she was the first woman appointed to
it and um she wanted to look at all the
laws regarding what the position
entailed and this is basically it and to
her somewhat chrin everything me
mentioned is is a he and him and his and
um did not cheer her up too much but um
I explained to her that uh the gender
neutral language that we adopted um when
legislation came up we adopted that um
stance around 25 years ago when I was in
the legislature and this bill of course
never came up and for likele would not
come up for another 2550 years unless we
change the definition of archist
so I thought well I could do something
about that and that's what you see in
front of
you um thank you the uh archist appeared
before our committee last year to talk
about about her staff I believe and uh
made a very nice case for it if we known
about this issue we might have fixed it
then but representative reeze thank you
madam chair and um thank you
representative Gilmore for coming before
us I have a question about um the the
language of your proposal and um uh HB
780 on line 13 I want to know whether or
not you would be opposed to changing
some of this language uh it currently
reads the head of each agent agency
shall submit list of State records in
his or her custody and I wonder if you
would be open to changing it to the
agency's singular possessive same thing
on the next line instead of he or she
change it to the head of each agency
shall likewise submit list of State
records and then a change on line 15 to
in it currently it reads his or her
custody and I would say the agency's
custody I would actually I'd prefer that
language that you're that you're okay
because I I I think if we're going to go
for gender neutral we should go for
gender neutral I I I agree with you
great thanks thanks so much I'd be
willing to offer that Amendment if need
be thank you yep thank you are there any
other questions
okay thank you very much representative
and may just one other thing I would
really urge uh members of the committee
to if you haven't been to the archives
to visit it and we have a lot of I've
worked there for eight years and we have
a lot of historical um things I think
you'd be interested in and um the senate
election law uh committee met was there
a couple weeks
ago yes thank you it's a very quick
field trip represent of sitech does that
include a history of
counties ah there's all kinds of stuff
on counties there but I don't know about
cour
houses they're probably there they've
got uh house journals from the 1850s
that I looked at one time during a
recount anyways thank you for your for
your testimony is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on House Bill
780 all right seeing none I will close
the hearing
uh representative re you are responsible
for getting an
amendment yes thank you mam can do it at
any time and while we have a few minutes
I would like to go into executive
session
on House Bill
156 and I offer Amendment 0421 H is
all right this is the advisory committee
that representative Bixby wanted on food
which struck me as a rather nice thing
to have but it also allows us to
replace the current advisory committee
on state procurement which has been Mor
abund for at least two terms
and then repeal it
so this
is a a an advisory committee on
procurement
that we can argue about how important it
is and then it repeals it and that's my
reason for doing it representative
lamb uh thank you madam chair um I
believe that it is important for us to
find those commissions uh and those
committees that are no longer serving
their original purpose and I think this
is a great great way to meet the need
from representative Bixby and to also uh
reduce the burden on the legislature and
the confusion for the public that may be
looking for a committee that does not
actually meet yes yeah I was impressed
that this committee would would would be
able to finish in one year
representative
groa so what we're saying is we're going
to ask to delete the statutary the
statutory Commission on procurement and
replace it with a commission like this
the first thing is to change the scope
of that statutory committee to be the
food oriented one that representative
Bixby wanted yes and then repeal the
whole thing so this would eventually get
repealed on November
1st um 20
2025 representative Bixby said that the
uh
the commission could finish in one
year yes yes yes okay I understand what
you're saying that's fine I that's a
good move thank you okay anybody else
representative Pearson thank you madam
chair as uh someone who served on the
state procurement
commission I
am in support of this
Venture
um
questionable so I think in this case the
this this will uh solve two problems at
once thank you any other comments
questions
concerns okay then the motion is to
adopt Amendment 0421 H for House Bill
microphone thank you uh the clerk votes
yes representative Pearson yes
representative
sellers
yes repres representative groda yes rep
representative
Davis yes representative darge
yes
representative Howard
yes representative re yes representative
long yes and the chair
yes uh
130 okay for adopt the amendment to all
right right in that case I move ought to
pass with Amendment on House Bill
156 is there a second I'll second
it
okay I don't have anything more to say
representative
not okay does anyone else have anything
to
say comments
questions okay in that case the motion
is ought to pass with Amendment on House
Vice chairman Leon yes Clark quotes yes
representative Pearson yes
representative Bailey I representative
sers yes representative yes
representative tibo excuse me
representative Gro yes representative
Davis yes representative Dary yes
representative Howard yes represent D
yes representative long yes chair yes
130 as before I'll move consent all
right anyone object to
consent no okay I already have the
committee report issued so this will be
on
consent
and 21st Bill thank you almost halfway
there all
right in that case we have a short break
hearing
e
just uh let me know once you're situated
um so we can start I do want to make
sure that everybody knows what doing so
but I don't think this going to get
retained retain
um thank you I would like to open the
hearing on House Bill 525 and introduce
representative Dan Maguire thank you
madam chair members of the committee for
the record my name is Dan Maguire I'm um
from
Epsom I for the past couple of years
have been the chair of a committee
called The Joint Committee on dedicated
funds and what we do is we review
dedicated funds on a fiveyear cycle so
every um every year we do 20% of the
funds and this year we came across this
particular fund which is shown by the
the paper in front of you called the uh
interpreters certification fund it's
part of RSA 200 C col 20a and basically
what this fund does is it takes in the
licensing fees of the uh interpreters
for the daff and heart of hearing and um
though those people are being licensed
by the board by the Department of
Education and when we look at a a page
like what you have in front of you we
see a problem because as you can see the
revenue every year is in the $30,000
range but the expenses are only around
67,000 right so they're collecting way
more money than necessary for this job
and um when we talked to the Department
of Education they said that this board
is is a bit of a
um uh it it's not their their Focus
right I mean it's it's a little bit of a
of
[Music]
an they don't get they don't get the
services they don't get much attention I
guess from the Department of Education
and so we thought that um by moving this
board and this um uh accounting unit to
the
oplc they would get professional
attention um
they would oplc would be better able to
connect the revenues and the expenses
and and they would be more professional
just like uh other licensed entities so
that was a very simple um reasoning
behind this um I think moving the um the
board from Department of Ed to oplc they
would continue to have this particular
fund and the fund could be spent for
their their own
purposes thank you are there questions
from the
committee a representative
groda yes um their funds could be spent
for their own purposes now so why is
this a requirement to move them to op
they can use the funds whether or not
they are in oplc or whether or not
they're on the board of education
they're on the Department of Education
excuse
me right thank you for the question
representative but what I think would
happen is they would lower the fees
below the expenses right they would they
would give them lower fees until such
time as this money is used up right and
if they also want to use it for training
or other purposes they can but again
right now Department of Ed doesn't seem
to
be engaged I guess you know I I don't
want to criticize them exactly but it's
it's not their
focus thank you um seeing no other
questions from the committee thank you
very much representative thank you madam
chair I have to go back and Grill The
Liquor Commission so thank you um next
Maguire uh thank you madam chair members
of the committee I'm Carol Maguire mayck
District 27 and I put this bill in at
constituent so what once representative
the other represent Maguire had
identified the need or the desire to
relocate this board I worked to
implement it the intent is to keep the
same functionality of the board keep
their
responsibilities and duties because they
are a
it's a professional licensing board it
has this it would have the same as any
other and it would be more appropriate
in the oplc where it it would get the
attention the funds in
the uh in their dedicated fund would
continue to be used solely for the
benefit of the uh the de de blind and
heart of hearing and for investigation
and discipline of those who are
board and my recommendation is that the
committee retain this bill to make sure
that all the cross references are
um and the the duties and
responsibilities have been transferred
appropriately
I would like to mention that the
um the the fiscal note implies that the
oplc would need some extra help to run
this board compared to a normal one and
that to some extent the
uh the bo Department of Education may
have been subsidizing this from its
other issues uh but we don't know we'll
find out and I would like to to look
I'll try to answer any questions thank
you uh representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair so uh I
just have a kind of a technical question
because I I I thought this was just
defin heart of hearing are we have are
they blind folks as
well um de blind are included in the
board definition okay it's the same
statutory definition that exists now
okay very good so uh if if your intent
is to have the bill retained I think we
have to make that clear to what the
implications of that are to the folks
who are here today and the other people
who can't be here today but who are very
much involved that's why I mentioned it
right up front because this is a fairly
Hefty bill I consulted a bit with the
oplc to make sure it would be be correct
but I I do not guarantee that all the
cross references and
details have been completed properly so
that's why I want to keep it and send it
to
subcommittee very good I think that's
very important for them to understand
right off the bat what what it means for
for them at this point to be the bill is
going to be retained okay thank you uh
representative gr and then
representative Pearson thank you so I
have a concern with this bill and the
transfer of this board to
oplc because oplc has a
distinct um administrative duty of
boards and right now this board operates
on its own and is self-contained in
itself so I would be very concerned
about taking a board with such specialty
with such a
specialty
and putting them under another agency
that would have to hire people or get
some sort of assistance which is doesn't
exist now as we know it and I don't
um so I would be concerned about
retaining that bill to make sure that
ultimately that wasn't the the purpose
of retaining was to amend the bill to
get it to to stuff it in oplc if the
people who are administrating and taking
care of this board now
don't don't think it would be a good fit
for them well that's another thing the
subcommittee should consider is whether
this move is necessary it was generated
purely from the financial point of view
that the fund appears to be growing the
board doesn't appear to
be setting its fees
and it end his expenses to balance out
in a more appropriate way and I mean
it's it's growing significantly and
therefore that's you know is that a
matter of the an issue of what the board
is required to do or is it a problem
with the supervision of the board and
again that's the kind of thing we would
beat out in
subcommittee thank you representative
Pearson thank you madam
chair just just so there's some clarity
the the purpose of this is not I'm
asking you is not to take away any
Authority or power from that board it is
simply to move the administrative
operations of that board over to the
oplc is that true that is correct and
the have the oplc
provide some things that it appears to
be uh be able to do for example updating
the rules of the board um the open PLC
has been
producing new rules and updated rules at
a really impressive rate the Board of
so but no the duties and responsibility
of the
boards if I wrote the Bill correctly are
exactly what they are
now thank you um other questions from
the
committee um sorry representative
Schmidt
thank you madam chairman so um the
representative Maguire so the that
there's no implication that uh that the
funds are being in any way the current
funds are being in any way know
improperly administered it's just it
seems that they're getting more money
than they need what is what is happening
to this extra money just sitting but
it's their money right and it and it
shall be used only for their benefit
but I think that it would at the rate
the money is accumulating I think would
would make sense to cut their license
fees for
example um but that's up to the up to
the board and to the oplc as the
administrator to figure out how to
better balance income and outgo perhaps
they're not doing the
investigations quickly or thoroughly
enough perhaps they need to provide more
guidance and training it's it's their
money they need need to use it and if
they think that the amount they're
bringing
in can be properly used for their
purposes
great but follow up follow up thank you
so but at but at this point uh since you
you want to retain the bill and we can
get into all the details and so forth in
a in a in the appropriate form which
this is not uh that uh that we should
take advantage of the fact that we have
a number of the participants and the
beneficiaries here today is there a
question representative what is there a
question yes they will be welcome in the
subcommittee she understands where I'm
going thank you yes we will we will need
their help to figure out why there is
such an imbalance and has been for five
years or so so my question if I may
follow up uh is uh is there some use ful
purpose that can be achieved today since
we have them here and it would be a
shame to waste their presence and and
and and the opportunity to I would be
delighted and I'm sure it would be
useful for the
subcommittee if they would say we think
our licensing fees are too high we'd
really rather like would like to cut
them or comparity they said we really
need to get more information out there
about this board's function or we need
to do the investigations more thoroughly
those are logical places to reset the
cost to
income thank you and and I have actually
I have one question if I may ask of
course um so my question is I know that
we try to that the goal is to set the
licensing fees um to only cover the cost
of Licensing if we look only at that
does that suggest that um this board may
be better suited to be an oplc where
there could be a closer attention to the
demands of the board responsibilities
that was the Genesis for this bill was
that the Department of Education did not
seem to be looking closely at the cost
versus expenditures thank
you representative salers yeah thank you
madam chair um so one question I have is
will the
administration cost change at
all it shouldn't
there will probably be some startup type
costs um relocating new business cards
that sort of thing and also updating the
administrative rules but um the general
cost should not change unless the board
decides for example that they need to
have a dedicated investigator if there's
a lot of complaints that haven't been
settled that would increase the cost but
that would be their decision
representative gr I noticed though that
there's a fiscal note
$227,000 and I I think that has to do
with
the cost that the department that oplc I
I'd have to read this but this I think
yes the over the oplc states the overall
impact of this bill is indeterminable
because it's difficult to know what
would be involved so there would be a a
cost according to this for LPL for oplc
to take this on yes and there there is a
cost reading the details of the fiscal
note it appears that some of the
administrative costs for the board such
as
um an interpreter or whatever is covered
by the the Department of Education
Without necessarily breaking it out and
charging it to the
board um I don't know that exactly
that's something we'd want to look
at but defin but definitely the board
wants needs someone to translate to the
clients and that that is a a necessary
and legitimate
expense um representative de thank you
madam chair and thank you madam chair us
um I have a question about this bill as
as I read it and um excuse my this part
of this is because I'm new to this
committee um but on the second page of
the bill for example it talks about on
line three there shall be CH the change
would be to an Advisory Board of licens
Licensing for interpreters um and then
under lines 35 and 36 it eliminates the
the board's ability because it becomes
an Advisory Board to suspend or revoke
licenses and conducting investigations
and hearings to to be clear is those
changes would not reduce the
independence of this board but it would
create
um would
it create administrative support for
that functionality and it would still be
this board even though advisory who
would be who would be um reviewing
complaints about um possibly interpret
interpretation Services I just want to
make sure because it would be the same
as the electricians or the psychologists
or whatever the oplc will conduct the
the investigation with appropriate
experts and then the board will decide
what the results are I mean what
the the the the the lack as as the
jury follow up thank you very
much so that the board would continue if
moved to the office of professional of
oplc to be populated by members of the
deaf deaf blind and heart of hearing
Community is that correct absolutely
you'll notice the um the composition of
the board is four
interpreters five consumers including
three uh three deaf or deaf blind
persons one consumer of oral
interpreting services and a non-deaf
member of the public so yes the the
community that's the same composition it
has right now thank you that language is
directly copied thank you um I have a we
can we'll take one okay yes my question
for you is can we have the oplc go next
so that they can establish a foundation
as to what the expectations
and and the scope to which they think
this is going to apply to them before we
ask questions that ultimately are going
to have to be answered by oplc anyway
yes we can do that um I will I I need to
figure out where I put that card um I
think it's I would also recommend though
that we don't do that because I think
that this board the people here who are
of this community can explain why they
have this situation I think there is an
explanation for this and I think we
should hear that um I appreciate that I
think that the largest part is to make
sure that everybody understands what
this transfer would entail so hearing
from oplc if they have any comment at
this point would make sense then we will
hear from the community we just want to
make sure that we're setting the table
of what this bill does and doesn't do so
that it can help guide the um guide the
the testimony that we're receiving
although I will mention the oplc will
support the subcommittee in excruciating
detail okay as they always do thank you
actually then with that um perhaps we
should go with the New Hampshire
licensing board and P pull up lplc at
the end because they're neutral um with
that also I'm going to I need to go
introduce my own bill in another
committee so I'm going to hand the chair
over to representative Bailey until I
return thank you very much
representative Maguire and I will call
Grace Warwick as we do this transition
proceed hello everybody um I have some
written testimony that I'll hand out
after this so you can have written
notice of what I say here um but my name
is Grace Warick and I am uh authorized
to represent the New Hampshire interpret
relationship board today um and we
oppose this bill um there are many
reasons why this bill shouldn't pass um
there are a bunch of people here today
who are going to talk about um some
different features of this bill um in
particular the program for the de of
heart heart of hearing that's included
um to be put under our board as part of
this um I'm not going to talk about that
I'm just going to talk about the board
for right now
um yes U I'm the clerking this I don't
what is the New Hampshire lure board
sorry the the New Hampshire interpreters
licenser Board of the interpreters Li
yes sorry when you're in the middle of
things sometimes I sure and stuff um so
bill
um so I just want to start by saying
that um interpreting is not like any
other profession um we're not like
cosmetology or accounting or psychology
or um things like that there's there's
no prescribed way to interpret something
there's no formula uh to correct the
correct in interpreting process um by
Nature the interpreting process is not
prescriptive and it's not standardized
um my understanding is that putting us
under oplc is to striving for some
standardization I think this goes
against what our community is about um
to improve our qualities of interpreters
it's important to have rigorous
standards and a governing body that can
regulate these standards uh in order to
regulate and monitor inter work we rely
on feedback from the public this
feedback can come in the way of a filed
grievance and reviewing these grievance
with care is the top priority of our
board our board is made up of passionate
volunteers and most importantly
volunteers who can speak directly to the
communities that we're serving our board
has interpreters who know the work uh
deaf Representatives who know their
Community um and oplc will lack this
ability to truly understand the many
cultural linguistic Nuance nuances that
our board does
the board's enhanced grievance process
um that we've just uh moved past it it
creates a space to ensure that
complaints filed are met with the desire
to understand and find a resolution not
just provide Judicial Discipline The
Lure board is in the best position to
evaluate concerns regarding quality of
work provide oversight and insight in
how to move forward with the goal of
correcting offending behaviors so that
interpreters can improve the quality of
their work and continue providing much
needed service to a historically
underserved
population to specifically address the
uh the funds that are currently
available for the board's use because we
recognize it's a large sum of money
that's been there um it should be noted
that this amount is relatively new um
and we've been working over the last
several years to confirm that the influx
of funds that we're seeing will continue
and how to best utilize these funds so
what happened is when covid uh hit um in
2020 we started seeing an flux of
virtual interpreters from other states
who are applying for lure in the state
of New Hampshire so we started taking in
more lure fees um so historically if you
look at the funds prior to 2019 we were
hovering at closer like $50,000 a year
this new $200,000 number is legitimately
new and it's taken our board some time
to figure out the best way to use those
funds to make sure that they're going to
serve the board um and the interpreting
community so during our recent December
meeting uh we voted and approved a
motion to enhance our griev grievance
process to include compensated
Consultants that will hold well-defined
roles so that our grievance process is
accessible and transparent to the
community um this pool of money that we
have will be allocated and will be used
in accordance with our statutes and
administrative Rules by moving under
oplc and their standardized judicial
grievance process we're really concerned
that we're going to lose this
opportunity that we're just getting
started using um the significance in
this in the importance of our board's
expertise and handling concerns within
our interpreting profession really can't
be understated um we really hope that
you're going to allow us to keep our
current system that does work um and
allow us to continue doing important
got representative s how many complaints
do you get a year board here um so it it
it does vary um I am relatively recent
the board I've been part of the board
for the last two years um but
historically we receive one to as many
as five a year this year we've received
far representative
Schmidt thank you Mr chairman so there
there seemed to be some
implication uh in the uh in
representative Dan Maguire's uh
testimony that the board has been taking
in more money than it needs
uh and uh that it and that money the
excess money is kind of sitting there
not serving any purpose and it would be
more appropriate to have the fees
lowered so that they get as much money
as they need and they're not taking in
excess money is that a correct uh State
of
Affairs um I think there's some
assumptions happening with that again
the the funds that we have right now are
relatively new this is the infl flux of
funds that we have really started in
2020 um when Co hit and again it took us
a couple years to realize that this
trend was going to continue um we didn't
know that covid was going to last for
several years and sort of change the
landscape of interpreting at this point
we've determined that the funding that
we're receiving annually which has grown
since since 2019 um is likely to
continue and with that we have these
funds to make a more robust complaint
process that's handled um I'm going to
say by our board but by by Consultants
that will know what they're doing and
know the community and know the work
that's happening so we very recently
passed this new grievance process that
we're hoping to enact um that again will
increase transparency and bring in
qualified Consultants to work and
process these uh
grievances um so that and that will take
money um so that will take money to to
pay these consultants and make sure that
we have correct interpreters uh for
Access so we're anticipating the funds
to be allocated in the same way that
oplc will need these funds I believe in
the fiscal note it mentions that oplc
will need to hire interpreters to manage
this work um so the board already has
sort of initial expertise and ability to
have conversations with folks and then
pull in and pay for Consultants using
funds proceed thank you Mr chairman so
uh is it the case that some of the funds
the ex SoCal excess funds um that are
currently being held uh are are would be
used if if the in if the structure and
the the instrumentality were uh were in
place they would be getting used right
now yes absolutely we actually have one
complaint right now that we're working
on hiring an investigator for um to
again sort of start this new grievance
process that will pull in Consultants to
support it um so so yes the funds will
be used um again it took us a minute to
I mean legislative Works takes time we
we needed to make sure that if we were
enacting this process that we were
following our rules um and and going
through the correct process so it took
us a little while to establish it we
recently passed that motion and are
starting to to dive in to do this work
that will utilize our board's
funds
followup go thank you so uh is we we
know that there are uh labor shortages
all over the country for all kinds of
professions uh and and so is it that is
that kind of what you're facing as well
that that there just are not enough
people to do this kind of work that are
available to you at this time it is I
mean that that's a huge part of our
board and the way the reason why we take
the grievance process so seriously and
want to work so hard towards resolution
um and and not sort of a formulized
standardized process of of punishment
that we understand sort of the oplc
would use a standardized complaint
process and realizing that we would get
to sort of be the jury I understand that
we would have some say but but holding
it with us allows us to really sort of
work internally and understand what's
happening every step of the way working
with our Consultants again who
understand what's happening in the
nuances in the field um and make sure
that instead of jumping right to lure
revocation lure suspension we can talk
towards resolutions and make sure that
we're um working on specific trainings
and things to really enhance the
interpreation that we have in this
community so we don't lose them so we
maintain the interpreters that we have
to continue serving this community
because yes to your point we need more
interpreters we need to lift them up um
to serve our community in the fullest
way possible thank
you pres gr thank you how many licensed
interpreters are there now in New
Hampshire oh it is a great question and
I apolog ol I don't have off the top of
my head it's certainly information that
we have um and part of it is again we
have a significant number of outof State
licensed interpreters but they only
provide remote Services um having live
interpreters is so critical you can see
it here today we have a team that's
supporting folks in this room um remote
interpreters are wonderful they provide
additional access um but our our group
of internal New Hampshire interpreters I
believe our number hovers at about a 100
serving
Statewide um it's a small pool of again
our local New Hampshire interpreters
living here in the state thank you
representative Howard thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question uh
do you have any examples of some
complaints that people may
arise um I think I have to stay fairly
vague in order just to protect folks um
but really so the New Hampshire follow a
strict code of professional conduct it's
part of our statutes it's part of our
administrative rules we hold
interpreters to these standards and they
relate to confidentiality respective
consumers professionalism again
following that state rate fee making
sure folks aren't charging abnormally
High rates um but again it also comes
down to professionalism making sure that
folks are showing up in representing the
deaf clients and hearing clients frankly
I mean you all use interpreters too our
interpreters here representing you as
well um this matters it matters to have
quality interpreters um so complaints
can come against sort of anything that
somebody feels an interpreter is
violating um so if you feel that the
interpreters here were not doing their
job today you would have the right to
file a complaint and say I don't think
The Interpreter who showed up shared my
message correctly or was professional um
the same as de consum consumers they
should have that right to say hey I
don't think I got the right Services I
was at a doctor's appointment and it
caused me harm um this is critical and
again it's really important that some of
the things that happens and the
complaints that come in which I think is
another part that's important is often
the complaints that we receive are
written and for most heart of hearing uh
deaf uh deaf blind folks English is not
their first language some of the
complaints that we receive would be hard
for you to understand not because it's
not written coherently again is sort of
understanding of the ASL grammar
structure we can read through and
understand better what somebody's
getting at if oplc sort of step one of
reviewing these complaints they might
not understand they might not um get the
gist of what's being said the same thing
that we can so frankly I think on some
level reviewing complaints our board
would be able to do it faster come
directly to us have direct Expert Eyes
on this and start the process to come to
resolution thank you and I appreciate
your generality thank
you representative de thank you very
much Mr chairman um maybe I shouldn't
actually be directing this question to
you so if um the people who come up
later want to speak to it as well I'd
certainly be appreciative um English not
being the first language of uh many
within this community I'm just curious
culturally um what the potential harms
are by making this move um for the deaf
de lined and heart of hearing Community
from where it sits now within the
Department of Education which is one
place that probably also isn't well has
not been specifically built to serve
this community but moving it over to op
oplc um just speaking to the cultural
differences and the potential harms to
the community would be um particularly
interesting for all the speakers thank
you yes excellent question and I
appreciate the way you prefaced it I am
going to let some of the other folks who
are here they're going to talk directly
about that um and share their their
experiences um and I do also want to
remind that I'm talking about one part
of this bill um it's important to
recognize that the bill mentions moving
the program for the DEA of Heart of
hearing which is under V rehab and the
department Ed right now moving it under
our board's purview um and again I I
haven't touched on that in my testimony
other folks will talk about that it's
important to recognize that's a piece of
this bill and adds some complexities to
the whole
thing thank you thank you representative
zitech did I hear you say an out of an
outof State interpreter can provide
services to New Hampshire residents in
state here yes it's why our um lure fees
have increased over the past few years
because we do require so if somebody's
providing remote services so you know in
hospitals or something you'll see
somebody on a screen who's interpreting
so not directly in the room we do have
folks who have applied from out of state
but they apply for State L lure so
somebody who's living in Montana can't
just interpret virtually in New
Hampshire they have to first apply for
lure and then they're able to and the
way this functions is there's a number
of um referral interpreter referral
agencies so language bank is something
you might have heard of um there are a
few other agencies that manage a whole
Fleet of interpreters throughout the
country um so they'll contract with
different um folks so that they can do
that virtual work so again they never
actually come and set foot in New
Hampshire but they're able to provide
some services
follow up uh different question what's
today it caught up um I apologize I
don't know the answer to that one either
but I believe we're actually right in
the process of updating that fee
schedule it is posted on the website um
and it's I mean the fee schedule varies
depending on how many years you've been
interpreting the type of certifications
you hold um so it's not like there's 100
dollar lure fee excuse me let me step
back I answered your question wrong
there is a set lure fee um there's a
lure fee for firsttime applicants and
then there is one for renewals and I
believe it's in the $1200 range but
again don't quote me on it we have it
listed on our
website representative Schmidt thank you
Mr chairman so what what what is the
population of people in the deaf de
blind and heart of hearing
uh sphere if you will uh in New
Hampshire at this time if you have an
accurate count oh I also don't have an
you guys are quizzing me on the stats
here um I don't have that number again
it's something that we can certainly
find in one of the other folks who might
speak today may have that number for you
okay maybe somebody in the audience
could could answer that question right
now so that we don't lose it I think
it's very important to know how many
people we're dealing with here
are there any other
questions oh I have Lori schaer here who
might be able to answer that question
directly I'm not sure if you'd like her
to come sit or just shout it out uh we
just I just don't want the question to
receed into the carpet yeah yeah have
her come up and join you is she filed a
card or I have a
card you want me to go next as well as
answer the question yes that would thank
you although I don't know a specific
count for New Hampshire I do know that
it's 1.5% of the United States
population so I think proportionally New
Hampshire would fall under that same
number could you perhaps introduce
yourself I'm sorry I'll start from the
beginning well they said Lori but I
don't think they all caught it hi I am
Dr Lorie Schaffer and I am speaking in
opposition to HB 525
um and to answer the question as I said
the national population is
1.5% of the overall American population
and I would say New Hampshire's probably
in that same
proportion if that would be helpful
thank you um and if I may continue with
the testimony I have I appreciate that
thank you um I am a director of an
assistant professor at the University of
New Hampshire's American sign language
English interpreting program
many of the people in the audience and
providing the interpreting service today
are graduates of that program I hold a
doctorate in Translation and
interpreting studies and have been a
practicing interpreter for over 30 years
my area of research specifically looks
at the impact of institutional systems
on the work of interpreters and the
impact it has on their work and on the
lives of the communities we
serve I'd like to First clarify a
distinction that has I've not yet her
discussed this morning between the New
Hampshire licens boards for interpreters
its duties functions and
responsibilities as compared to the
office of De and heart of hearing
service referred to in the bill as the
program of deaf and heart of hearing
services on the on and their duties
functions and responsibilities and
they're very distinct and they're both
encompassed in this
bill the New Hampshire lenser board for
interpreters as we've already noted
reviews applications for lure grants The
Lure oversees our conduct as American
sign language English interpreters who
provide services in the state the office
of deaf and heart of hearing services
starting I believe on page three or four
of the bill it provides training and
assistance to deaf heart of hearing and
deaf blind citizens of this state and
equally important to the employers of
New
Hampshire the distinction is critical to
the discussion of HB
525 so I'm going to ask us to First
continue our examination of The
Interpreter licenser board although
under the bill the board will remain as
a functioning Advisory Board to the
office of Professional Licensing and
certification the board's responsibility
of suspending revoking licenses
conducting investigations and hearings
regarding the denial suspension
revocation and R renewal of licenses
and quote accepting written complaints
from the public against lenses
conducting necessary investigations of
such complaints and publicizing the
complaint procedure all have been
struck such duties would then fall to
the
oplc these responsibilities require
extensive knowledge of the expected
conduct of our working interpreters as
my colleague Grace Warwick already
mentioned also as she mentioned our
conduct is guided by the code of
professional conduct which is provided
to us by our National Organization of
the registry of interpreters for the
deaf in collaboration with the National
Association for the deaf the code States
the American deaf Community represents a
cultural and linguistic group having an
inalienable right to full and equal
communication and to participation in
all aspects of Society members of the
American deaf Community have the right
to informed choice and to the highest
quality interpreting
Services the CPC goes on to say the
driving force behind the guiding
principles is the notion that The
Interpreter Will Do no
harm the phrase Do no harm is very
intentional it is the same principle
that is the basis of the hypocritic oath
as we all know it is the oath that our
Health Care Professionals swear about
hold if we want to file a grievance
against a medical professional here in
New Hampshire one would file with the
New Hampshire Department of Health and
Human Services or the Board of Medicine
both bodies have the expertise and
institutional knowledge to carry out the
responsibility of suspending and
revoking licenses conducting
investigations Etc all those duties and
struck I do not think anyone would argue
that Northeast Deen heart of hearing I'm
sorry soone would argue that the new New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services and the Board of Medicine are
the correct bodies to manage these
grievances now it might be said that
interpreting is not medicine There are
rules and rules are either complied with
or
violated however our code of conduct is
not made of rules but of guidelines
guidelines that ask for example quote
interpreters conduct themselves in a
manner appropriate to the specific
specific interpreting situation
unquote I would like to know how the
oplc would determine compliance or
violation to this tenant they could turn
to The Advisory Board then this becomes
a duplication of work the oplc cannot do
with the nhb the interpreting board can
and does do HB 525 would make the oplc a
puppet overseer leave nhb to do do their
job time is money and this restructuring
will cause inefficiency and cost the
state financially in addition there is a
risk to violating our deaf heart of
hearing and bl blind citizens in aable
right to high quality communication
access if a wrong decision is made on
the part of the P oplc there could be
legal as well as Financial
consequences now let's look at the
office of of deaf and heart of hearing
services has not yet been discussed one
thing that needs to be understood is
that neither the the NH like
interpreting board is actually not under
directly under the Department of
Education it is under vocational rehab
which is under the Department of
Education so you're asking for a
department that is two degrees away to
be supervising the interpreting board
and it doesn't for the most part it
overse to a degree but who really works
closely with them isocal Rehab Services
that are housed within the Department of
Education so what does this program or
office for Deen heart of hearing
services
do the office of Deen heart of hearing
services does offer some administrative
support to the interpreting board
however it's not a licensing operation
which makes it curious as it's included
in this
bill what it does as I mentioned
previously is offering training and
assist
the training and assistance are designed
to prepare both the potential deaf heart
of hearing or deaf blind employee and
the employer for work you see most
people associate the word deaf with
hearing loss with
impairment the frame is rooted in
deficit
thinking the professionals at the office
or program of Deen heart of hearing
services model the opposite they model
professional success they bring their
expertise resources and the lived
experience of being deaf to share with
these
employers they assist Employers in
Shifting the Paradigm away from deficit
thinking to one of
contribution these same experts then
work with potential deaf heart of
hearing and deaf blind employees
including those transitioning from
public schools into our Workforce so the
employees can bring their best sales to
the job or
classroom without the services of the
office or program for defant Heart of
hearing services many of these people
deaf heart of hearing and deaf blind
would go unemployed and many an employer
would not have access to the
contribution they could make instead
we'd have more people on state
assistance unemployed and unable to meet
their basic
needs odhs
the office for de heart of hearing
services does not belong under the opes
of oplc it is appropriately positioned
on the offices of vocational rehab in
closing I say to you it would be
525 are there any
questions representative gr thank you
your testimony was very helpful because
from what I
understand we telling us is that really
the program itself is the large
component of this whole discussion yes
it's half the bill right but it's also a
significant portion of what you all need
yes right it's the thing that drives the
whole program I mean this this office is
the thing that drives it and it's the
reason why you need to keep the
licensing in that under your realm
exactly so are there other communities
that are also under the vocational rehab
office Yes actually the vocational rehab
office I'm not from there so um my
colleagues are but in brief I can say
that their job is to work with people
who are labels as those having
disabilities to join the workforce thank
you so much very
helpful is that a sitech uh may we have
a copy of your testimony I have provided
it to the gentleman who was collecting
them and I've also posted it on the
website I didn't make copies for ich Vu
I apologize I have one more copy we'll
get them don't worry you'll
okay are there any other questions oh
representative Howard thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question so
uh as as a professor I'm I'm sure that
you'd probably be uh best to answer this
question is American Sign Language a one
to one translation of English well
there's no such thing as in any language
yeah if we could pause just a moment
until the technology comes up
question there some of usion on because
speakers
are example the variety of members of
is there something we should be doing I
don't know how to fix the technology but
go so to the question of whether
American sign language is a quote Ono
one uh translation into English no
languages there's no such thing and I
teach to this as you said I am a
professor that there's no such thing is
verbatim um American sign language is no
different its roots are actually in
French sign language which is what uh
the initial teachers for the deaf our
first school for the deaf in the country
were brought over from France so
therefore the language much more
actually resembles syntactically in
linguistically French so you can imagine
we can go from
there well thank you for the explanation
it thank you um are there other
questions from the committee represent
of sellers thank you madam chair you
mentioned uh liability that oplc might
undertake because of they're not being
knowledgeable
enough what isn't that the same thing
for this board as well even Al though
they're knowledgeable they could still
have liability true except there's a
whole lot more expertise there and less
likelihood of it
happening specifically given the
discussion of hiring new Consultants
with the expertise additional to the
boards with the funds that are
there follow up yeah thank you one other
question um my question is is if um what
about appeal for those that you're
certifying if they don't agree of the
grievance or something like that where
do they go from your your there's an
appeal process within the grievance
process and overall yes absolutely so a
good
question thank you representative Dev
closer oh there I'm usually not accused
of being particularly quiet um thank you
so much Dr schaer um so the the question
that I guess that I have for you is um
moving the New Hampshire
nhb um is to the
OPC U I know Ops sorry I just so many
acronym making myself a little crazy um
there are two different things things
underneath this bill that would be
moving underneath the office of the
oplc what I heard you saying and perhaps
you can correct me if I am wrong is that
the office or the program for the deaf
and heart of hearing is
especially um challenged to be moved
under the the oplc because they do not
have any
particular um expertise in um training
employees or rather training employers
about how to how to work with the
community I'm just if you could be a
little sure let me review that a little
bit okay so looking at The Interpreter
licensure board I think it's equally
problematic to put them under the um
oplc because now we're duplicating
effort why not let them do what they're
already doing why pay Why move them
under the P oplc that has no expertise
as I read how vague our guidelines are
as professional interpreters you really
have to be an interpreter or a consumer
of our services to understand how they
would be violated um and so I think
there'd be a lot of back and forth of
not knowing that it seems um a waste of
time energy and money um as far as the
office for the deaf and heart of hearing
under vocational rehab their expertise
is training employees and employers and
I'm not sure what that has to do with
the
oplc to be honest thank you
thank you there are other questions from
the committee seeing none thank you and
I hear your testimony was fantastic that
will be revie yes thank
you iove yes yes thank you uh next I'll
sorry MERS TOS when they if we could so
we can follow along we Community we can
follow along you know
names um thank you as we're recognizing
people for questions I've said
representative dev has that been
satisfactory I'll be a little bit more
clear just as an example representative
de I'm sorry was was that question
directed to me it was it was to the
interpreters and to the audience to see
that if recognizing somebody as
representative Pearson or representative
you actually um and I will call Christy
stellato from the New Hampshire
deaf I'm sorry sorry yes Christie D oh
sorry D sorry here we go actually I my
just uh just trying to figure out
logistics here
okay so I think I think we'll we'll stay
like this uh so everybody can see
me got to talk into the
microphone
okay I have I have to speak with the
microphone and um I I also would like to
add that we would greatly appreciate
this also as written testimony uh
because we all benefit from multi
multiple
modalities thank you madam chair would
it be helpful to have a seat at this
table I'd be happy to if somebody would
like to have this seat so that the
there uh we're we're just discussing if
uh you know if D was to stand there he'd
be signing to the audience and uh but
wants to sign directly to um the members
as
well
[Music]
okay uh just fingering All The
still to he's saying uh please sit there
and I will go from here
okay good morning
everybody my name is D Clanton
and I am
deaf I do not support this bill HP
mentioned so I I was the former
Statewide coordinator for Deen har of
1994 and when that new license uh
approach was was built I was very
involved with that and So what had
happened prior to
that we would frequently have
interpreters who would struggle all over
the state of New
Hampshire and Nationwide as
well and so we had we you had asked
about uh the The Lure which protects the
community and protects the interpreters
as
well but in order to get a license you
have to go through it's called the
registry of interpreters for the deaf R
it's a a nationwide Nation wide um
entity that's based in DC so
interpreters um go through that process
go through our ID in order to um get
their certification and then their
certification is brought here to New
Hampshire and then they are given a
license to allow them to work in the
historically folks might say oh I have a
family member who knows a little bit of
sign but that's not enough that's not a
experience so some interpreters might
and okay so everyone you're following my
convers my testimony so
far all right so as I was mentioning um
The Lure board was set
up through legislative process our
committee we did have a subcommittee
that was working on the dire set of
rules um which we have still in place
today um I think it was back 2003 early
2000 something or other um we had
learned a lot from that point in time
forward and looking at the lure board we
had four interpreters four deaf members
one hearing member so we had a total of
t nine members we were figuring out what
was working what was not
working and we did see that it has been
employed for that time period and has
been working well when things don't work
well then we had reassessed the the the
rules and we really thought we were
doing pretty well with the interpreting
community and with the de
constituents again um you know looking
at the office of Deen heart of hearing
and looking at this bill
525 seems that it would really be a
major setback it seems that the idea
behind this bill is finances is munding
look and and again this this funding
source is relatively new in the idea of
it being sent back to the deaf and heart
of hearing community and thinking about
how do we do that this is all kind of
new conversation we hadn't had that
experience over the last 20 plus years
the oversight of the funding there and
thinking that it would be just taken
away from us or thinking about what to
do with it and thinking about VR and
heart office of Heart of hearing and
deaf and heart of hearing services and
leaving that as
is from what people are saying how many
members do you have within the community
and in as far as the interpreting Comm
goes as mentioned it's at least 100
looking at New Hampshire thinking about
Maine thinking about Vermont
Massachusetts some of these interpreters
are crossing state lines because the
needs are there whether we have send our
interpreters over to other states or
vice versa the need is there so one
example might be um looking for a
certified deaf interpreter like we have
today standing in the corner that
individual is from Vermont he drove over
today to provide service
which is is great to see that they're
there providing the services but knowing
that there is just not enough and
thinking about if an individual does not
have National certification or lure they
cannot provide services in this
state um there was also The Mention Of
Video Remote interpreting it's called
VRI there are so many locations that are
utilizing this Services whether it's
courts or hospitals or what have you
that number has skyrocketed in the past
few years
therefore should we charge lure fee for
that if they're providing services in
this
state and again the unprecedented amount
of video relay interpreters that have
gone through the roof and the past few
years New Hampshire was able to
capitalize on that and gaining fees and
gaining fees from those members that are
outside of the state working lure
following the rules and the regs for the
state to provide services for our
community so video remote interpreting
we did not anticipate that it was a
shock for everybody Co was a shock but
we do appreciate that service was
available and we were able to provide
Gap in services with video remote as
interpreting missed that so with talking
now about the office of Deen har of
hearing and where it's living and the
interpreting uh ice lure board I think
that that's a natural um function that
has
coexisted I wouldn't say that there's
any Mass criticisms at this
point um in thinking about the term of
lure which is two years and in having
the state of New Hampshire overseeing
that looking
at the the board members and the
turnover that happens It ultimately this
community is is not easy to um oversee
and this is within members of our own
Community providing these functions I
think we're very fortunate to have what
we have to have that historical
knowledge to have that lived experience
to have that opportunity to screen these
new interpreters coming in whether they
have the rid credential or the NAD
credential or not it's important that we
have entity setup to oversee what is
community thinking if we were to move
over to the office of license
professional lure if this is a
discussion about
funding I think well hold on I think we
have to think about whether this bill is
going to happen or not and I would
really appreciate if you just hear our
testimony and just squash it before it
goes any further
are there any questions for me I'm ready
for them okay I'm a representative
Jackie groa and um I have a
question um regarding your relationship
with the
vocational um rehabilitation office of
the Department of Education of the
Department of Education so can you share
with
me what that relationship is and also
the relationship that because you spoke
a lot about interpreting but really the
program for the deaf and heart of
hearing is also part of this bill which
is significantly different than
licensing it's more of of a relationship
with your community and the promotion of
your the individuals who are part of
your community community I'd like to if
you could expound on those two things I
would appreciate it is that one or two
okay I here what you're
saying first of all uh vocation
Rehabilitation was an office set up some
years ago the department of uh the
office of Deen heart of hearing I mean
that's Statewide providing
Services New Hampshire Statewide that
was set up gez sometime in the 80s early
' 80s ' 81 maybe that was the intent of
that was for the deaa and heart of
hearing community and such members
anybody with hearing loss um to look
into employment services so that's VR
talking about lure when the vote was
there was a vote that was passed to
support um lure they were looking at our
office at that
time so we were there to support and
that
solid um work history there and to see
the members here today it's obviously
evident that the monitoring that has
been happening and have been working for
the licensure
board and this is not a joke here I'm
telling you this is not a joke when we
think about our community things it is a
small state things can get sticky we
have to be careful and if there's a
grievance out there to a community
member we have to think of logistics we
have to think of confidentiality we have
to think of the individual as a person
the deaf person the hearing person what
happened here and look at this tactfully
to resolve what happened what is the
issue from the deaf person's perspective
what is the issue from the interpreter's
perspective and not only does that
opportunity exist for the deaf Community
but as does a um the hearing members of
this incident so whether it's a business
that
was impacted by an interpreter's
decision as
well so one example I can remember there
was some issue with um you know I don't
want to go into great detail here but I
remember something relatively serious
remember calling another state and
saying we have a problem H how do we
remedy this um the other state did
validate that it was an infraction
within the lure board and that the
leaving so we investigated this
individual also me looking at this
individual did they have certification
from the National Organization rid
registers interpreter for the DEA and
see if they were in good
standing and so what happened was
um looking at the the protections that
were in place for the community
members so I'm not sure if my situation
is explaining clearly did or if I even
answered your question for that
matter follow up yes thank you I I
believe you did and the previous
speaker the woman who's the professor I
don't remember her
name there you are okay I'm so sorry um
she um talked about the community being
similar to um a community that is a
medical community or a where the whole
being the whole person is being
addressed so I I would think that your
the the the board of Deen Harden hearing
is looking at individuals in the same
way because you're looking at the
ability to communicate with them um find
them employment and guide them in and
work with their employers which I also
think is very is very interesting as
well because the entire system has to be
um has to
recognize the need the needs for that
communication to
sign Lang the sign language interpreting
program here at University of New
Hampshire in Manchester is
excellent those hearing students are
eager to learn the language the culture
to become quality interpreters is it a
guarantee that they're going to get
certification National certification it
is not it is that depends on the
individual some some students come out
there with great
success but some of them don't make it
to certif ific right right away and
that's where the lure board comes into
play in providing those screening
opportunities to say yes these students
are now graduates can become
interpreters but for with limited
settings or with limited um capacity
some of the individuals go on right away
to become nationally certified and
accredited certainly Lori's been her
program has been a great asset to the
state of New Hampshire and for the deaf
Community here um so we applaud new Hamp
UNH Manchester for their efforts in
creating those individuals to support
our community without Lori I think that
we would be at a real deficit in the
state and okay I have a question um er
representative Erica Leon uh all the
money that is in this account was
collected by the community um in the
licensing fees are you concerned that
High higher than needed licensing fees
have been drawing resources from the
community and have potentially reduce
interpreters funny you should say that
uh prior to my retirements uh boy here I
am talking about my retirement it's been
while but
um we had looked at the fees and at that
time prior to instigating the fees
we that was also prev VRI video remote
interpreting and again emphasizing that
during covid we just saw the numbers
Skyrocket and that really surprised
everybody the number of interpreters
hasn't necessarily gone down um the
number has increased certainly with the
VRI
implementation um but I think the number
kind of holds strong there are members
of the interpreting community that have
retired or moved I mean I retired a few
years ago we had a pretty stable
population of interpreters maybe a
slight bump a slight um decline but V
video relay interpreting has really
impacted the numbers um and the surplus
of funding but we're also utilizing the
services I don't know what's happening
within the hospitals that are strong
proponents of VRI but we know that there
changes um will the number of
interpreters go down will it change will
be impacted by
VR um we're we can't
predict um we have new individuals and
New Opportunities all the time I think
we just have to remain open and see what
will happen thank you representative de
thank you madam chairwoman uh thank you
Mr Clinton a question for you so the it
was the spike in after covid that caused
a greater number of uh people seeking
licensing and that in turn drove up the
number of dollars that were in the the
account from approximately 50,000 to
approximately
$200,000 fair enough and then so now we
have this new technology the the VRI and
we don't know what some of the outcomes
of that technology which may be
fantastic because it allows uh service
and more or rural areas perhaps but the
possibility exists
that is it correct that the possibility
exists that what may look like an excess
Sur uh Surplus from licensing fees of
now we're at 200,000 instead of
$50,000 that there may in fact because
of the new V technology be more demands
on the
nhb would you agree that because this is
new technology there may be increased
pressures on that
board and
therefore the the
$200,000 isn't in fact a problem but it
is um resources to address changing
Technologies sorry if I didn't I was not
clear
well if we're looking at pre and postco
and this this this funding time again
mentioning that the funds were very
stable for quite a period of time and
then covid hit and I can remember
seeing the difference the influx I can't
say it was right or wrong it was just
changes uh there were some interpreters
that were many interpreters were not
going into the hospitals anymore many
interpreters preferred to stay home or
individuals within the hospital they
wanted the in-person interpreters um I
mean I'm not going to bore you with all
the details of Co we know what that
looked like but in any
event um we do know that the funds were
increasing at that time and individuals
do have the right to prefer an in-person
interpreter if that works best for them
up and the hospital or whomever can ask
for the referral agency to get that live
impers interpreter but sometimes the
situations are not offered and it's just
video remote interpreting like this
morning I went to a physical appointment
for myself and I do prefer The in-person
Interpreter in the room in the same
location so that the nuances can be um
can be expressed within the the language
however if V was the only thing that was
available we're just going to get the 2D
screen um and those subtleties within
the room are not going to be conveyed um
I think for some people that can work
fine some people not so much but if we
imagine being deaf and blind like some
of our community members are the remote
interpreting is not going to work for
them if we're thinking also about remote
situations heading up North into the
North
Country there it's important to have
those community relations for those
individuals that know the area and know
the arena that is so helpful that is
lost within the VRI complex so I'm not
sure if I answered your question
completely all right thank you um next
thank you very much for your testimony I
appreciate it next I call chrisy
stellato from the New Hampshire
again just uh figuring out where the
best place to
stand so I know the the live streaming
is going to uh miss this because I'm not
but hello everybody thank you for
my name is christe
stellato I am a deaf person I am using
interpreter services and I am the
President of the New Hampshire
Association of the deaf I am also a deaf
interpreter
Hampshire and I here to oppose HB
525 related to moving both the program
for the or the office for the deaf and
heart of here
hearing and the New Hampshire
board you know the alphabet soup we have
IB so I'm here to provide a little bit
of history behind um these two
departments the IB and the
OPD um so the program was uh for the
Deen heart of hearing was set up in um
1981 and um which includes uh a number
well and it was set up to provide
services for deaf and heart of hearing
individuals with the focus on providing
standard and quality of services for
agencies which is administered by you
coordinator who is an expert on the
subject
population so the Cornerstone of this
program program is to promote quality of
interpreters excuse me if I could
interrupt for just a moment um one of
the things we do in the committee is if
you have written testimony for everybody
um it's always easier for us to read
your written testimony but listen to you
summarize give the high points um so
that it we can hear what out of your
testimony is most important to you while
we read the whole doc we ask this for
everybody in our hearings it's it's not
unique to your community it's something
we ask from everybody everybody who
testify okay sure thing uh I do have
several copies um I also gave three
copies uh over to the um the gentleman
that was over there as well with cards
thank you we'll make sure to get copies
of anything that people submit so that
we all have the opportunity to read them
subcommittee sure
thing so basically I am uh here to
525 because move the program for de and
heart of hearing was founded um by
federal law uh by by several federal
because they are focused on providing
and improving Services um for folks to
have access um through interpreting
standards and through the interpreting
program through interpreting laws and
the the licensers
certifications interpreter training P
forth so the New Hampshire lure board
established because consumer deaf
frustrations and trying to determine how
one can approach um and this type of
situation and how um you know that that
heard maybe that interpreter needs to
make some improvements or um maybe it
wasn't the right person not the right
fit for that situation so that board was
established to meet those needs and
example so so suppose um if a if a
complaint process goes through then we
have those procedures to set up that are
set up uh to address those
needs sorry I I don't want to read this
whole thing like you said I I'll give
this so I would prefer to see The Lure
board stay where it is which is in the
so because of other reasons particularly
cultural competency board members
themselves have experience they have the
training and the
knowledge and if it is moved under the
oplc where the folks there have no
similar experience or training as as the
board members do from the
IB which we do have that experience and
like you had said we become kind of the
jurry
members and so we have that ability and
we have that
knowledge but oplc is the one who does
the
investigation they may not have the
right process they may be asking
questions um you know and that the
consumer might realize that hey this
isn't the appropriate the appropriate
process this is not the appropriate
investigation while we sit back and
watch why this oplc does this
investigation which may become derailed
for whatever reason so the deaf consumer
historically has experience all of these
frustrations and barriers and maybe just
shut down because they don't want to go
through this complaint process with an
entity that doesn't have the knowledge
and um experience to do
Thank You by I I'm not trying to
interrupt you that was very very helpful
to hear that I appreciate that Insight
committee seeing none I thank you very
much uh next I'll call
Michelle from I can't read your last
name from Northeast de and of hearing M
you and I just do I want to say that it
is lunchtime we have some members who
need to eat it's not a matter of them
not wanting to listen to this in person
but they they need that for their health
um and so we may have people coming and
going but um rest assured that we will
be paying attention to all test Tony on
this
Bel good morning share well good
afternoon hello good afternoon good
afternoon share and member of the
committee my name is Michelle MCC I'm
the executive director for Northeast de
heart of
her I'm here with the F support of the
Northeast de heart of her board and what
I'm reading here is just summary of what
testimony we are a nonprofit
organization have been serving the death
in heart of heing and death blind
community in New Hampshire for 24 years
today I come before you to express a
strong OPP oppos opposition to HB by2 by
and to shed light on the profound impact
that this would have on our community in
the in of time I will cover some of the
crucial point and hope you will take the
time to read the more detailed
explanation that I have provided like a
death individual I ask that you refrain
from not comparing me to another death
person and wonder why we knew different
communication methods that could
discussion for another time our
community comp and divert and it's often
challenging for many people to fully
understand let me address I'm of a
common
misconception lip reading an effective
communication is a mess asking a that
person or a heart of hearing person to
lip fre place the entire burden of the
communication on us and not all of us
can lip fre study shows that only 30 to
40% of the foken language can be
accurately interpreted
Freedom a more effective approach is to
act that person or heart ofing person
that blind person what is the best way
to communicate with you communication
should be a share
responsibility that people have equal
access to learn
him again that is not true over 90% of
us are born to her and parent who first
experence with the death person is their
own child the result is the delay access
to language
which can lead to L
deprivation I've outline a more detail
of that regarding to land deprivation
but it is one of the main reason why odh
should remain with the B of Vocational
Rehabilitation where they understand our
experience and how to effectively serve
our
community and that the do that any can
our KN the very complexity of death and
heart of hearing and death blind
individual require specialized knowledge
fishing odh to OPC which did not have
this expertise would mean losing decade
of institutional knowledge crucial for
serving our
community I share this misconception to
reflect how we are frequently
misunderstood and the additional barrier
we
Face we we recognize that well intended
people may not gra the far reing
consequences of the decision that deemed
minor however disconnecting to from one
of the few ageny that understand our
experence could have a devastating
effect on
us the New Hampshire interpreting lening
board had a vital role in our community
moving the responsibility to the
oplc undermine the service the oversight
and diminishing Serv
quality this is not just a butic sh
these affect real life trust is the key
that heart of hand and that blind
individual are more likely to Avid a
stability concern when they know their
exp can be understood and respect thaty
is a Conant struggle for us and it is a
doting and
frating as we navigate the ch challenges
we recognize that many of the well me
well meaning individual may make
interpret our need issu of
trust understanding of our culture and
language and the community aom can be
difficult to convey especially to those
who lack our live experience live
experience I elaborate further on the
point in my testim in my written
testimony which I really encourage you
to review it is crucial for you to
understand the significant of this issue
within our community in closing I
effectively ask you to take our word for
it your support of opposing
h525 means a great deal to us thank you
for your time and
consideration thank you are there
questions from the
committee seeing none I greatly
appreciate your testimony thank you uh
next I will call djar from oplc um she
will need to be in another committee
later so I wanted to get the Insight
from the from the executive director
thank
you right good afternoon I do appreciate
your Indulgence i u just want to make
sure that I get down to house finance in
time and I wanted to be before you for
any questions um I guess I will just say
we had a few remarks um prepared but I'm
happy to just bring those to a sub
committee or a retain Bill committee at
any time happy to assist um I see
attorney fry joining me at the table in
case there's any questions that um I
cannot answer um but I the office is
prepared to implement whatever um this
legislature Wills in terms of the
movement here um I I would just like
just to allay any concerns the office is
is very understanding of each individual
community's needs and we have 57
different boards that do lots of you
know a variety of things and so happy to
to meet the needs and I think the fiscal
note accurately um demonstrates just we
we've already taken a look at our
existing process and how we would need
to change and adjust to serve this
community so I do want them to hear that
uh should this become law um we would do
our very best to implement and work with
the stakeholders and and the community
and to ensure that it's served I do
understand there's some conversation
about bifurcating kind of the program
and the the licensing aspect we do have
some precedent for that I would say um
property assessors with there's still an
assessing Standards Board at the
Department of Revenue Administration but
the licensing function lies with the
oplc so there's some precedent for that
Division if the committee would like to
look at that um not making any policy
recommendations but just to say that
that is a potential option but ha happy
to work with you all on any Logistics to
make it fit within our existing process
um and address any concerns we're happy
to take questions uh but we don't need
to take more of your time and and can
just do that in subcommittee as well
representative de thank you very much
Madam chair and thank you for being here
today I'm curious today um we're talking
sometimes about cultural competencies um
and I understand that you're you've
taken a look at this and would be
prepared to move forward but I'm curious
how many people within your office now
are members of the deaf blind or heart
you I don't want to say none because I I
am it's very possible that I have
members of my staff that may be part of
that Community or may have family
members uh I don't have that knowledge
at my disposal I guess the question is
do I have interpreters on staff or do I
have people who are designated to do
that work the the answer is no um and
the fiscal note contemplates that we
would we would look at probably hiring a
dedicated staff member for support to be
able to offer those services in addition
to contractors like we would with any
other board like I think the department
vok rehab are doing now follow up follow
up yeah to to be clear sorry that was
not my question it was entirely about
how many people you have on staff
currently and not future oriented
because I think one of the prior
speakers um was talking to us about um
the the institutional knowledge that has
been built up over the years working
within the Department of Education so I
it's not about a lack of um and I don't
certainly do not mean to convey that but
I just wanted to know what the existing
cultural competencies were um uh to to
understand what the impact would be
thank
you sorry um and I I think I'll sort of
refine that question generally oplc does
the administrative backbone for a lot of
different regulated groups where the
expertise for the group and the cultural
knowledge for the group is within the
board that advises the PLC and my
understanding is that the people who are
involved in the current program would
would come over um unless they chose not
to follow the group The Advisory board
that they would come over from their
existing home to now have the oplc be
the administrative backbone instead of
the Department of Education be the
administrative backbone is that a a fair
understanding yes I I think it it
certainly remains to be seen and there
would be details to work out about
exactly what those functions are I think
there's some pieces that are driven by
the board presently at the department um
that are more policy decisions or more
um maybe Community Services is the right
word I I think the bill contemplates and
maybe presently there's a maintaining a
a registry of what is available um
looking at uh grant writing and other
kind of services to the
community that's outside of the the
scope and function of oplc which is you
know we do licensing credentialing and
then when you break the law we
investigate right or when you're alleged
to have broken the law a complaint comes
in so I I I think some of the concerns
that you've heard is to say that that's
not really a function of this it's not a
license your function it's separate from
that um and so I think that's kind of
the discussion that you're hearing
today I'll make a broad statement we
could credential anyone uh but the the
other community services and those
aspects I I think is the concern that
you're hearing and uh
we we defer to your judgment um if you
don't pass this bill we we won't look
any further into it thank you that was
very helpful there other questions from
committee members seeing none thank you
very
much um next I'll call Valerie Ortiz
can you push the button so it's red
thank you how's that perfect okay good
morning or good afternoon thank you for
hearing my testimony I am here on
reading a statement by Lori Meyer she
may actually be here in person later um
but uh since she is not here yet I will
read the her testimony could you
summarize it if you're familiar enough
with it I will do my best thank
you could you also put your mouth closer
to the microphone because thank you is
that better yes okay great um this is
from Lori Meyer I've been an ASL
interpreter for 49 years most of that in
New Hampshire several decades ago I was
one of a handful of interpreters and
deaf community members who recognized
how little agency people who used our
services had in the choice of
interpreters they were receiving and the
significant impact that had on their
life experiences New Hampshire became
one of the early states to propose and
pass lure legislation that included a
defined complete process with the hope
that consumers of our services would be
able to give voice to their concerns and
that interpreters would benefit from
hearing those concerns one of our major
interests was to create a process for
interpreters to hear What mattered to
deaf heart of hearing and de blind
consumers and those Contracting our
services our Hope was more to uplift
than to sanction even with deaf people
and interpreters at the table it has
been difficult for the consumers to
effectively file a grievance as you can
imagine imine regulatory processes have
thwarted some of our intentions over the
years and The Lure board has been on a
multi-year quest to make it easier for
complaints to make it through the
process as other testimony will explain
the lure board has approved new Pathways
that will support complaintants in
reaching constructive resolutions for
those Pathways to be effective lure
board members must bring cultural and
linguistic competence to the task we are
fortunate to have a re have the recent
leadership of of Richard Salah director
of the New Hampshire Department of
Vocational Rehabilitation and Beth
Keller program coordinator for the
office of the Deen heart of hearing the
recent lure board progress is a tribute
to them and one of the many reasons why
it's so important that the lure board
and the office of the deaf and heart of
hearing remain with the New Hampshire
Bureau of Vocational Rehabilitation the
institutional knowledge and sensitivity
to the issues that New Hampshire VR
brings to these conversations would
require decades to replic at the
oplc I believe there are significant
ways that cons that concerns coming from
The Lure board differ from other
licensed professions navigating the
ethics of interpreting and the impact on
the community we serve is not simple
national conferences debated and deaf
leaders and interpreters at the local
and National level continually examine
the nuances of our code of professional
conduct an oplc oplc board without this
background would be unable to fairly and
effectively support the Integrity of a
grievance process and the safety and
well-being of the New Hampshire's deaf
heart of hearing and deaf blind
citizens an example of how this lack of
understanding could impact the lure
board is demonstrated in the methodology
section of House Bill
525 the oplc recognizes that it does not
have the expertise to manage The Lure
board and proposed administrator to
quote ensure that the office has an
interpreter unquote as as if the
existence of an interpreter on staff
creates an accessible lure board any
trained interpreter will tell you that
creating an environment that welcomes
deaf Community concerns requires the
experience oh I will leave it at that
because you asked me to summarize I did
the best I could with the summary thank
you I appreciate that and you did a
great
job um and since it's her testimony we
won't take any questions for you thank
you um
I believe this is Paul derome I
hi I am here to oppose Bill HB
525 I am a former Vocational
Rehabilitation client I've always had an
appointments and I do trust the office
hearing to address and handle all the
[Music]
so it gives me peace of
mind that the Hampshire lure board is
me thank
you thank you very much I we appreciate
your
Novo and I apologize if I'm getting any
names
wrong thank you it's n no one gets it
right um I have limited copies of my
written testimony so if you are
especially somebody that wants to follow
along and make notes you can um I only
I'll wait for those to go around I will
keep this brief
um my name is Katie Nev I am also known
in the community by my name sign Katie
um I'm here today to represent the New
Hampshire chapter of the registry of
interpreters for the deaf and HD um we
are kind of the counterpart to the
National Association of the deaf um
which Christy was representing earlier
um our I am the current board president
so I'm here speaking on behalf of our
members today our guiding mission
statement leads us to work together with
the de Community to meet the
interpreting needs of New Hampshire
residents for over 20 years the approval
of lure and the processing of complaints
and grievances has been handled by The
Lure board um which consists of members
of both communities moving that board to
be an advisory under the oplc would
remove the important cultural and
linguistic awareness and knowledgeable
experts that are working right here in
New Hampshire and would sanitize the
process that we've been building for the
last couple
decades um and it removes nearly all of
the opportunities for Community feedback
and for the growth of a dynamic process
that grows with the community that it
serves um just to highlight some uh
things of note that we saw I am not a
legislator or a lawyer but I have spent
the last week reading every single
chapter rsaw law associated with all of
these boards um current a law current
law allows for members of the community
to submit a petition for rule making um
to The Lure board to amend repeal or um
otherwise enact new changes to the board
its lures its process its rules um which
from all my understanding is not
possible under the
oplc um the uh proposal just passed by
The Lure board for interpreters a few
months ago to upgrade and enhance and
make more efficient their grievance
process would not have been possible had
it been moved under
oplc um current law specifically details
acceptable criteria for alternative
filing of Grievances and complaints um
for any other profession under oplc uh
this doesn't seem to be possible all
grievances are filed using a
standardized online form completely in
written English there is nowhere to
state that um the form has been filled
out on your behalf or with assistance
and there is nowhere to upload a video
testimony or to um file your grievance
officially in
person
um there is also no promise that a
grievance filed using non-standard
English would be accepted or even
understood by anybody who is on the
receiving end of such a
complaint um current law also has
licensed interpreters and members of the
deaf and heart of hearing and de Bland
communities fully integrated throughout
the entire process of Grievances and
lure people who know exactly what it is
to use an interpreter or to work as an
interpreter here in New Hampshire um are
front to back start to end in the
process um people who work under the
code of conduct every single day are the
ones who are doing the investigation
collecting evidence witnessing
testimonies and making decisions how to
proceed um in ending the community we
serve is a cultural and linguistic
minority with a long history of
Oppression both on a systemic and on
individual levels as you've been hearing
little bits of today um I cannot
personally speak to the experience the
lived experience of being deaf but I can
tell you that interpreting is an
intimate profession um unlike a land
surveyor or an accountant or an
optometrist which are all under the oplc
currently along with um 57 other boards
of various lers um interpreters are
there for everything if you could just
take a moment to imagine that every
single time you go to the dentist the
doctor's office the bank managing a loan
going to your parent teacher conferences
for your kids all of that information
that you want to share with them and
that they are sharing with you has to go
through another person the amount of um
trust that's required to live your
everyday life in that manner is
extremely important and so it's critical
to understand that for a community that
up until the Advent of FaceTime and
Skype could not use their native
language with friends and family unless
they were in person um that that
communication and understanding of who
someone is and what their background is
is
vital um so it is I think my point is
that it's critical that um the deaf
Community is involved in the oversight
and regulation of the professionals that
permeate every corner of their lives um
and then very often The Interpreter is
the only person in the room that knows
knows what all parties are saying at all
times otherwise we wouldn't need to be
there if you understood all of the sign
language that was being used here today
and they understood all of your speech
we wouldn't need to be here but
unfortunately that's the case if The
Interpreter makes an error often times
they are the only one that knows and so
it is extremely important that
interpreters are also part of this
process in lure and in filing and
processing grievances because this is an
extremely Niche profession and we are
the ones that are living it and working
it every day and um as a as part of the
profession it requires a specific level
of insight and um accountability both in
keeping ourselves accountable and
keeping our own Community accountable um
so to the Casual Observer it does seem
that these changes are pretty minor
moving a lure board to an office of
lure um but the implications are long
reaching and um thank you thank you for
your testimony there are questions from
the
committee seeing none thank you very
Marco hello I'm Joe maku I live in
Manchester and I'm Hardy herin and I'm
here to vote ask you vote for against
this bill um I had um been H to here all
my life and I uh actually as a high
school student was able to get both
Rehab Services and then later on got to
um be employed through vocational
reputation and work with many
individuals who were def in how to hear
in and uh deine and I have to advocate
for the keeping this agency within the
department of aded sending it to another
agency that may have no knowledge or
cultural uh information about the de and
hard hearin and de blind population will
be doing a disservice to your New
Hampshire
constituents I as a h hearing person did
not know many hard hearing people as a
youngster but once I got into
um uh high school and working with the
weh have counselor for the Deen hearty
hearing I was like oh I finally got to
know and meet someone someone who
understand my challenges and provided me
with the accommodations that I needed in
college someone who was hearing who
doesn't understand that I need CAU like
you can't see over there but we didn't
have that back then I had a notebook
that someone took notes for me so but as
a professional vog rehab counselor I had
a graduate degree and those of us who
were rehab counselors for the de and
Hearty hering we had educational
um education that we pursue got graduate
degrees we had um gone to a lot of
conferences and trainings about all
kinds of um technology and try to kept
up to date with the technology that
would make people employable employable
so we work with clients to evaluate
their skills assess their interests find
what would be a suitable goal rot up
plans for them and said they need uh
like this educational training or this
job placement training but they needed
these kind of accommodations might be a
vibrating pager if they were working in
a w site or if they needed ASL
interpreters or job placement uh
services to initially learn the job and
then be able to be Su uh independent and
be able to maintain employment so V we
have when I worked as a VR counselor I
worked with a lot of individuals that
were on the verge of becoming unemployed
because they had a hearing loss it takes
about 7 years for someone to do
something about their hearing loss once
they start losing their hearing so they
were on the verge of becoming unemployed
they would come to vog rehab we would
provide them with the uh heing AES they
were a able to learn about technology
that would be uh you could be used in a
job Capel phones and uh cchen in and all
the um devices that can enhance their
employe ability they would be able to
maintain employment and then we would be
able to close them out and they would be
successfully employed and uh meeting the
criteria for The Vocational
Rehabilitation agency uh Nationwide
every state has a a v agency in I don't
know if you know but B weab was
initially started as an agency to work
with veterans who incur injuries dur
after the war and then in this we have
Vocational Rehabilitation that provides
General Rehab Services we have a
specialty unit for death and bl I mean
um sbbi which is services for the blind
Invision impaired and we have the
services for the uh D and Hardy hearing
IC you to please keep OD DHHS under
education educa under the Department of
Education because education knows about
disability you know they have special ed
and they have a lot of
um specialist in under doe but
OPC I'm so concerned if any moves are
made to oplc that all the gains we have
made over the years will just backfire
and we're going to be regressing many
years and with lack of suitable services
and then what happens is that we're
going to end up having people go on uh
benefits because they can't keep their
job they don't have the right Services
because they didn't have appropriate
Services provided to them so providing
Services is an investment by the
government that leads to individuals
being successfully employed in taxpaying
citizens and that's why it was always
been felt that V rehab was a good
program to provide investment and
services for their constituents so thank
you for hearing me thank you uh we have
a question from representative gr if
you'll take it gr hi thank you I'm
Jackie groa um so you mentioned the
vocational rehab that you're involved
with and you're actually in the
vocational rehab Office of the
Department of Education is that correct
I was I we I was there for 16 years from
1984 and then to 2001 and then I went to
DH Department of Health and Human
Services but I would refer people to
voke rehab at the department of AD V
rehab for as long as I've been uh in New
Hampshire V rehab has always been under
Department of or maybe under I think V
rehab under Department of thank you I
have another question which the chair
has told me I can ask you um so under
this V vocational rehab not only do you
have the board for the deaf and heart of
hearing which takes care of that
population but did I understand you
correctly that there's also a group for
vision and vision impaired individuals
as well yeah it's not a board so there's
General VR Services you have the
department of AD Adult Services adult
learning re I forg theong um ad services
for adult learning and
it's it's okay okay um but without
learning and then they have Vocational
Rehabilitation and Site Services for
independent live in and also the office
of DEA and hard Haven services so
there's actually three under that
umbrella perfect thank you so much okay
thank you thank you thank you very much
next I'll call Cara
cine I want to mention this is Lori
Myers That Couldn't present that U just
came in I wanted to know she someone um
read her paper thank you thank you for
good afternoon and thank you to the
members of this committee for hearing
the testimony is given today from New
Hampshire
citizens and uh entities of whom HB 525
will greatly
effect my name is Cara crumrine I am a
2019 graduate of the UN Manchester ASL
English interpreting program currently a
coordinator for the education and
Resource Center at Northeast Deen heart
of hearing services and a practicing ASL
English interpreter holding the state's
ler since 2021 and I reside in
der I joined my many of my colleagues
and community members in opposition of
HB
525 in the interest of brevity I am
going to leave much of my written
testimony out you all have copies I've
passed it uh to the gentleman uh next to
Madam chairwoman and um I implore you to
read it please as many have we will
speak about today though I do want to
stress the importance of recognizing the
distinct differences between the two
entities named and considered for
administrative transfer in this bill as
Dr Schaffer has gone into the functions
and duties that's the part I'm going to
skip over but I I do detail those in the
my written testimony I will say though
that aside from the proximal relation of
their housing and the administrative
support from
odhs to nhb they are very distinct
entities and distinct with distinct
responsibilities and outcomes and to
conflate their existence for the purpose
of this bill is a rather gross oversight
that risks inferior successes and
productivity within the communities that
they
serve there are deaf persons here today
that will provide testimony representing
the deser AUM of odhs remaining under
the opes
of doe and I implore to this committee
to consider those lived experiences
their nuanced understanding and
integrity of those testimonies that
certainly do mirror the skilled expert
and industrious laboring under the
current odhh
office as a trained in working an
interpreter I would instead like to use
uh a few minutes of your time to
highlight large concern for the nhb
being moved to the office of to op l c
New Hampshire is one of 22 US states
that require interpreters hold an
occupational license receiving this
license is certainly not a nominal feat
we must obtain at minimum years of
interpreter training often including
somewhere around or over 300 hours of
practicum experience we matriculate a
degree pass either the New Hampshire
interpreter State screening or our
national governing body certification
pay testing application and Licensing
fees and maintain continuing educ
education credits thereafter New
Hampshire interpreters that are
committing to this process of obtaining
this lure really do command the presence
and execution of a proficient Li
proficient informed and well-versed
Licensing licensing board so that it may
Safeguard our Professional Standards of
utmost importance is the understanding
that de charge and guidance must be at
the helm of this
oversight this is a significant factor
when considering the need for managing
investigating and mediating grievance
grievances in this occupation a current
current nhb Duty proposed to be struck
from this bill in the writing but it
seems that there's been some clarity um
and sharing of information on that since
this hearing has started the medium of
our professional work the foundation and
root
of our practice is the linguistic
fluency of American Sign Language and
Allied cultural competency of a
marginalized
people the US does in fact have a
systemic history of Oppression of deaf
people and suppression of
people deaf individuals were uniquely
equipped to mitigate investigate and
mediate those potential injustices
intended or not that risk harm to this
community lest of course we repeat the
past if moving this board to under the
offices of oplc renders this Duty absent
then practicality and morality must kill
this
bill this committee might hear argue
support for this bill as it relates to
the fallacious claim that oplc will
bring greater legitimacy to this
profession I argue this claim is
ego-driven and at the expense of the
deaf community that our allyship must
remain a principle that is rightfully
instilled in any interpreter from the
beginning of our training our profession
is valid and profound by its nature
communication access is the right of
deaf people under the Ada and federal
law and a prominent necessity used in
New Hampshire every day if governing of
our ler and practice under oplc cannot
be guaranteed by a uniquely competent
highly qualified various and De le board
the risk of Damages lawsuits and harms
is perhaps imminent so in closing um I'd
like to offer that nhb was designed to
prove the equality of the profession of
interpreting in New Hampshire it
currently operates under a department
with a vast depth of established
institutional knowledge it continues to
demonstrate a very refined understanding
of our code of professional conduct
American Sign Language the many
interpreter credentials the that exist
and Deaf culture there is explicable
doubt that the Integrity of these
functions can persist and under the oplc
and uh if you hear or share this
reasonable concern I ask that you votee
expedient to legislate thank
you thank you there any questions from
the committee being none thank you very
hello um I'm Tom DS and um I've been
hard of hearing all my long
life and um I've been a social worker
for 40 years and I didn't know I was
going to speak while I was parking the
car my wife put my name on the list so
I'm going to clearly state from what the
people said before me that at some
points they made I oppose this
Bill H
hb25 thank you thank you very
hello everyone good afternoon
committee thank you my name is Valerie
Hughes and I am I am a resident of
Vermont uh but I was actually born in
New Hampshire so I just want to talk a
little bit about
that I'm also a deaf independent program
coordinator for Vermont and I have
several clients that work with both U VR
in New Hampshire and Vermont as well
just so you have a little understanding
of my background
so I was born in new uh New Hampshire my
parents realized that I was deaf and
they were looking for a school at that
time which we did not have a school
established at that time that really
impressed my parents anyway so we uh we
actually moved to Vermont and that was
the reason my family moved to Vermont I
had better
Vermont and so now I just wanted to
mention a little bit about um so the
Vermont school for the de I also worked
there for 14 years and that was under
the Vermont Center of deaf and heart of
HH it's actually uh the Austin School
unfortunately has closed at this point
um so the Vermont DS uh closed that so
unfortunately the services for Deen
heart of hearing people were closed as
well which created a big change um folks
were trying to figure out what that
access and everything looked like so
some of the services were um removed
they they still tried to keep a couple
of things open and tried to figure out
where things would be um so I don't want
to see this replicated here in New
Hampshire so I do oppose HB 525 because
I don't want to see what happened in
Vermont happen here in New Hampshire as
well I've testified in Vermont on this
as well uh working with some deaf deaf
blind
folks uh to propose a bill right now for
the deaf and deaf blind folks to get
supported services that is in the work
right now um I'm I'm very hopeful that
that will pass um but I I understand
that the the Cornerstone is kind of
money here and I understand that the New
Hampshire deaf Community um you're full
of beautiful people here are deaf in
heart of hearing deaf blind um oral deaf
late dein
um and so I just I wanted to mention one
other thing as well about
interpreting we know that uh like we had
talked about uh remote interpreting has
really taken off since
Co however
with
technology things are not always smooth
things are not always accessible with
technology sometimes things freeze or um
maybe that uh interpreter is not from
the area it's not from New England maybe
they're from sou or maybe they're
sitting in California and their sign
choices and their sign language is
actually a little bit different same as
with hearing folks who have accents from
all over the country I mean folks in
Boston speak different than California
so it's the same thing with sign
language it's the same same
thing and so that's where we come up
with this issue I have several clients
that have come up to me and said the VRI
isn't working the technology is freezing
or I'm deaf blind so here here's a story
for
you so I I um was working with a deaf
blind
person and so I asked the office I said
do you have an interpreter ready for
this de blind person they said oh yeah
great and they pull in this screen the
VR I
screen the deaf blind person is not able
to see the screen I am not an
interpreter I I am I am an advocate um
and so it they asked if I would
interpret for this individual and I said
absolutely not we need to reschedule
this
appointment and get an in-person real
live interpreter that can serve this so
so that's when I might con my concerns
really come up when we think about um
moving um this under the OPC
how are those folks going to know the
deaf Community language deprivation um
and how that will impact their needs
every
day and I do remember one of you had
asked a question um about um ASL in
English um and not all deaf people
understand English written English some
do have a lower reading level for
English maybe a fourth grade reading
level that is not all of us certainly um
some of us of you know graduated from
college and and clearly can understand
and uh written English but that is not
standardized within the community so we
need to understand that oplc um might
not be ready and uh able to understand
that these concerns um so in closing I I
oppose HB 525 and um any questions thank
you there questions from the committee
sing none thank you very much um and uh
the last pink card that I have is for
turn good afternoon everybody
legislators I really appreciate your
work here today
and all of your work on other house
proposed my name is Susan Wolf hyphen
DS that one he was my husband that one
The Heart of hearing individual I am
deaf so sometimes I'll say yeah I need
an
interpreter so I wanted to um kind of
keep this personal I am I am against
525 when I first started my job first
day of my job and that was as the
executive director of northeast stenard
services so fast forward to almost 20
years later and we have Michelle
successor and so at this comes after
night 18 months of of searching to find
the right person the right fit for this
role which we did
find and so to try and envision oplc
having that knowledge um Ian it took me
19 months to recommend her to the board
and get her approved to find the right
person and now here she is right now and
wonderful so going back to my first day
on the job so DHHS asked me um to go
speak against a
bill and they said you need to say all
of these things in opposition to the
bill I said this is my first day so I
had to be there at 6 o'clock said
okay and so I reached out to some
interpreters my at that time at there
was no lure at that time um a no lure
at that
time and so when I arrived at that
audience to speak I had no interpreter I
put down my name to
speak trying to think about how I could
work and so there was a gentleman that
you know let me know hey they they
called your name and I
said okay how how am I supposed to do
language so there were four uh members
of um on that that legislator I don't
know if any of you were there at that
time but there were four folks there and
I used sign language and they did not
understand me and I said hey I did my
duty but they asked the the four the
community members who had some side
dialogue and we're trying to figure out
on and I said will you read this for me
message so I asked that person to read
me and I said Thank you and I walked out
and the audience actually applauded me
they stood up and applauded
me I said Woo
that's my first day on the job I had no
interpreter I think I've got a long ways
to go
here and that was my first impression of
Northeast up and heart appear Hearing
Services um so we started to build that
referral
department so maybe about the my fifth
um to get your master's degree please go
back to
school so I did I went and took night
years and I I said I I I will have to
advice and so every seven weeks we had a
different course set up
class and that was so for seven
weeks and I had two wonderful
interpreters probably some of the top
there one of them was a teacher of the
deaf a
well I still still could not figure out
what the professor was trying to say to
me everything was going over my head I
frustrated and so
then that interpreter as we talked about
that phrase Do no
harm so The Interpreter stood up and
interrupted the class and told the
professor I'm going to write on the
board give me five minutes to explain
this
interpreters don't typically do that
following our code of professional
conduct um and guidelines not rules
guidelines that is that was not a a
typical behavior for an interpreter but
they stood
up and they wrote this on on the board
and the professor was watching
board and then I started to get it I
finally started to realize and
understand what the professors were
saying it was finally making sense to
me and I was in my my
40s
wellow so I had talked to the board
now and so from then on to make some
changes so The Interpreter would say
hold on one would be sitting next to me
kind of pointing as to where we're go
we're going as the inter the professors
are going quickly they're flipping
through these pages and there would be
another interpreter across from me so we
tried we made a couple changes in the
approach the interpreters themselves
have the knowledge of how of what to do
situations we're making sure that the
message from a hearing provider is
consumer I was born
deaf I live and breathe
deaf I see deaf members of the community
all the
time and I depend on the use of sign
Lang
interpreters I can write back and forth
in English of course but I do depend on
interpreters so when we talk about the
money and the fund U from The Lure board
that is a result from the increase of
VRI and I I I'm just sick of VRI um
because like I said they're not a real
person in the room maybe I'm just
oldfashioned but
there then the doctor was kind of
wrapping up and made a couple of these
laugh
points and I said wait a second I didn't
say that the doctor said oh yes you had
mentioned all of these things and I said
no I did not say that and so I looked at
the The Interpreter on the VR I screen
and I said what did you what did you say
out loud no that's not what I had said
The Interpreter the VRI on onscreen
interpreter was wrong and they were
interpreting mistakes and that is a a
frequent experience from from deaf folks
for The Interpreter to kind of get off
point and to not interpret
correctly so when I'm having a
conversation and the doctor responds in
a manner that's not appropriate I
realized that there may have been uh a
miscommunication or misinterpret
and it's so with VRI it is incredibly
difficult to kind of make those um those
moment
what so uh I have a
brother who's a a quadriplegic and he's
wheelchair and his cognitive process is
slow and so VRI does not work for him
and the the hospital is trying to use
this as an
accommodation and so one
time uh they saw that the the VRI screen
was being pulled in and my brother
wheeled himself out and refused to work
with an onscreen VRI interpreter and
from then on they pulled in somebody in
person
so when we were talking about uh the
complaint process and what the licensure
board
does so I had a professional meeting one
time that I had to attend and I had two
there and I was wearing a
suit I made it was it was a very high
level professional meeting um that I I
had to address appropriately to match
the
situation and so one interpreter came in
wearing blue
jeans I was absolutely Furious that is a
reflection of me that person isn't a
reflection of me and so after the
meeting I brought that interpreter aside
I said this is between us I said you
never use blue jeans for any job you are
a professional you have a Prof
professional job to do you are a
professional
interpreter and I did not go to The Lure
board to file a complaint a grievance it
wasn't necessary um they actually
weren't even a member but so I took this
on myself and I had this um this
conversation and DEA folks need to
well so one one time uh interpreter had
earrings and I said that's fine that
doesn't distract me but that maybe that
not be the case for all de for all deaf
consumers there might be some folks who
that would be very distracting for not
all interpreters can interpret medical
situations too I just want to clarify
that when we talk about medical
situations some folks May some
interpreters may love engineering
meetings or highle professional things
um maybe they'll do a dentist one-on-one
every now and again but each interpreter
kind of has their own specific skill set
interpreting so especially children
whose parents are deaf uh we call that
and so I I just want to say thank you to
here and so I'm sorry to say that I I
reject this bill and for those those
reasons that I just stated um I would be
thrilled to answer any questions that
you anyone might have I know we're in
the interest of time here but thank you
very much I appreciate that um and I'm
sorry I hadm missed the card for the
person who gets the honors of what I had
in the 4:00 hearing yesterday um Andrea
KB um I apologize for misplacing the
up good afternoon and thank you for the
opportunity I'll try to be brief our
interpreters the cart report a close
friend of mine has been working 2 and a
half hours now it's way over her time
and the sign language people I
appreciate them sticking in there for us
um I did submit my testimony so I won't
go through all that I just want to
summarize
um I am Andrea from exitor and I oppose
this bill
525 I have um lifelong hearing loss I
have hearing aids for decades I just
recently got a colear implant I work
work very much helping people use
hearing assistive technology so I come
from the perspective of people who are a
heart of hearing I am considered oral
deaf I am a member of the New Hampshire
interpreter licensure board I am the
chair of an advisory committee to the
program for the deaf and heart of
hearing and I'm also on the state rehab
Council so I have a lot of insights into
these
programs um the program is a service
delivery program so no none of us can
figure out why that would be under the
oplc um and I have a lot of reasons in
my testimony about that it's also you
know federal law you cannot discriminate
against one disability moving just our
community under op PLC and leaving all
the other disability communities within
V rehab could be viewed as a
um the advisory committee that I chair
we made up of we have um the Portsmouth
Naval Shipyard as an employer we have an
audiologist we have mental health
experts the Helen Keller Foundation we
have a lot of experts who come together
to advise V Rehab on this program and I
wonder what would happen to all these
experts and in our lived experiences and
insights if this went under oplc so I
have serious concerns about moving that
program um a lot of what we're hearing
today is about the fee I want you to
know the licensure fee is
$150 that we're talking about here and
if you want to be concerned about is
that possibly keeping interpreters away
I would ask you to consider what are we
paying as a state for our interpreters
and I just quickly Googling this based
on our discussion today I believe the
average pay is
$57,000 and New Hampshire 17th in this
in the country where pay 48,000 for our
interpreters Massachusetts is paying
62,000 so I wouldn't blame it so much on
how much the $150 is keeping people away
I want our state to consider how much
are we paying these interpreters there
is a shortage I can tell
you within the program a few years ago
we used to have four um career
counselors who knew sign language they
were um rehab counselors for the deaf
and we we also had one who was
specifically for people with hearing
loss that was years ago in recent years
there have been zero people in those
positions people in our community had
nobody they could go to who spoke their
language who understood their needs in
this state that is
atrocious you need to understand what
our communities have faced in the state
we have a shortage of interpreters as I
said there is no de School there is no
registry you ask how many people are
there we don't know cuz we can't have a
registry right now our commission has
not met in over three years even though
they're supposed to meet yearly and
apparently nobody's coming forward from
the house I would ask all of you to
please consider stepping forward to help
us get that commission going once again
for the deaf and heart of hearing um
when I first get involved I went to a
commission hearing and I heard you know
people on that commission could park in
the parking
garage but guess what that uses some
kind of an intercom system and people
who have hearing loss or are DEA can't
use that intercom system so sorry you
can't use that parking garage that was
the
solution um there's just a lot of lack
of access in our state so when you talk
about that we're collecting too much
money and maybe we should be giving it
to somebody else I I would like you to
do some more research and understand how
put upon the de and heart of hearing
Community is in our state and
underserved and if there's any extra
money please consider putting it toward
other needs you know there's a lot of
assistive technology needs in our state
remote microphones trying to hear on the
phone at work trying to hear a doorbell
if you are a school
secretary um do you know hearing aids of
course people need to hear the forklift
if they're working in a store room there
are all kinds of needs in our state for
funds so so um I just hope you'll
appreciate that and thank you for your
time thank you any questions from the
committee none thank you very much um I
appreciate all of you taking your time
to be here um and we appreciate the
comments that you had with this um we
will close this hearing um we have an
executive session scheduled at 2 o'clock
I don't know um and the Republicans will
be meeting ahead of that and we'll be
meeting in here okay can I just say you
Democrats are going to meet in the
office
um hello Democrats we're meet hello
committee Democrats we're meeting in the
office in 10
minutes
e
representative Shen is in her other
committee which is why she's been
replaced for the
afternoon I'd like to introduce
representative peoples who is filling in
for representative TBO who has class and
representative
gon who is replacing representative
shean for the afternoon everybody else
is
here rep representative scitec is
assuming that we are going to deal with
House Bill 536 first so we might as well
he is reusing himself from that because
he would be a direct beneficiary of a
cost of living increase if it were to
pass
all right
so representative Lon you have a motion
on House Bill
536 yes I move in expedient to legislate
second second thank you you you can't
I'm afraid I'll second
it okay do you wish to speak to your
motion um yes thank you very much uh so
so right now all Granite Staters are
dealing with increased costs without
increased income this bill uh proposes
to create a Perpetual cost Del living
adjustment which would benefit each and
every person with the state pension who
retired prior to July 2nd 2020 um the
committee had a recusal um as we see and
I think that that's important for
everybody to note moving forward um this
bill would add a permanent 1.5% increase
to the first $50,000 of retirement which
uh would be $750 a year right now at an
annual cost to the state of 1.57 million
a cost of political subdivisions of 6.62
million and a $100 million increase in
acred liability which uh the next time
we calculate rates will be another
assessment on property
taxpayers while this bill was offered as
a way to help State retirees deal with
increased property taxes this would
ultimately increase property taxes and
create a vicious cycle where State
retirees need yet another cost of living
increase to off set increased property
tax values uh property taxes which then
increases property taxes um we I do want
to note that there was a special fund
that was created in the past which was
one of the reasons that actually led to
drawing down the amount of money in the
retirement system as well and while I
would love to give everybody more money
uh we simply need to be prudent with
what we
have and as a second I I'll just say
that yes we give cost of living
increases to retirees but that's when we
have the
money and I think it is
highly I I'm really bothered by this
bill doesn't tell the state to come up
with the money and pay for the cost of
living increase they want to give they
just say it'll be paid for by the rate
payers by the property taxpayers because
the bulk of of our our
um um employment system people are a
retirement system are employed by the
political subdivisions it's the teachers
it's the police and fire and a few other
people around um in in town offices
and we're mandating that they get a
raise at the co and we are charging all
the property taxpayers in the state for
that and I think that's
inappropriate so I'm going to be voting
for The
comments representative gr thank you
thank you madam chair although I
understand the um the issue about money
in the state is this is a policy uh
committee so I hope that we're voting on
the policy and I will be voting against
basis thank you fair enough anyone
else Mr
G representative excuse me thank you
madam chair would it be fair in your
opinion to classify this as an unfunded
mandate because the state is pushing it
down no okay thank
you no they it would merely be a cost
increase in something they're already
paying for as a as a matter of Education
all references and actions that have to
do with the current retirement system
anyone
else ah I will mention that someone else
brought up the issue representative Shen
is being replaced because she is a
person on two she is assigned to two
committees her other committee is
meeting today and therefore it is
possible to have her replaced in this
committee that is an explicit exemption
in the replacement policy thank
you I should have mentioned it because
earlier
standard well yes so we have more people
on two committees than usual this
explicit so all right any other
comments in that case the motion is inex
Meed to legisl late on House Bill
536 and representative L will be calling
the role um I vote yay representative
zitech has recused himself
representative Pearson solely on the
policy
no representative Bailey
I representative
gason yes representative sers yes
representative
Sai yes representative
peoples yes
representative gr gr no I need more
coffee I apologize for names
representative Schmidt no representative
Davis no Representative dargy no
representative Howard no representative
de no representative long
no repres and representative Maguire
fails does some does someone have an
alternate motion I do Madame chair I
536 SEC is there a second all
second who was
me any comments
else other
folder in the notebook okay thank you
there we go I apologize I've never been
clerk we do need more people to be
trained as a clerk so if anyone's
interested there will be holding more
training
sessions all right um seeing no other
comments the motion is ought to pass by
representative groa cler you can call
the role um I vote no representative
scitec is not voting representative
Pearson yes representative Bailey nay
representative gayon nope Representative
cers no repres representative SL yep or
uh representative um
peoples
no representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative Davis yes representative
dargy yes representative Howard yes
representative Dev yes representative
long yes and the
chair no and that motion passes 8 to 7
there'll be a um Minority Report which
I'll write okay representative grota
your report is Du um as soon as possible
okay representative land is doing The
Minority
Report sorry who seconded that
one um Howard representative Howard
representative
sociable note representative de re has a
motion and an amendment on House
780 Madam chair we're taking that now
thank you very much um I I distributed a
copy to everybody um the changes were
what was discussed earlier in the day uh
to make the language completely gender
neutral
no reference to he she his her um
and pretty standard so move a to pass
okay give us the amendment number please
discussion okay in that case the motion
is to
wait hi I'm looking at the original Bill
and in in section seven on line three
oh I'm so sorry but it's fine it's fine
I
sorry anyone
else I'd have to say this is probably uh
somewhat unnecessary but
nice all right uh the motion is to
accept Amendment 0496 H and the clerk
representative re is ah no wonder I
couldn't find it you you still have
it no I have it you have it I don't seem
to have it but my problem is it
no that's okay i' i' I saw it yep that's
it I may be pulling things into my Orbit
I apologize no
and go ahead okay Vice chair L
yes
yes representative Pearson
yes representative Bailey I
uh representative SL
yes representative
peoples yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt all
right vast representative Davis
yes Dary yes
yes representative Howard yes
representative
yes representative law yes and the chair
yes okay
passes representative de re you have a
motion like to motion on to pass
amended
okay this is there a
second grow to seconds okay any further
discussion what's the bill number
[Music]
780 yes this is that's not one okay it's
not one of the mandatory ones no was
okay
yeah ready okay representative Leon yes
yes Vice chairman Le clerk votes yes
representative Pearson yes
representative gas gas yes gas I'm
sorry um Representative sers
no represent
SL yes represent
yes representative
groda yes representative Schmidt yes
representative Davis yes representative
Dar yes representative Howard yes
representative Tes yes representative
long yes and the chair yes the same
151 okay motion passes 15 to one do you
object to
consent are anyone else no okay in that
case we'll put this on consent
representative re you DOA committee
convenience okay all right house bill
438 relative to immigration detention
facilities uh we
held off on this because of
Representative long wasn't with us that
day but I'm going to move in expedient
to
legislate is there a
second
okay and I'll just say that this is an
attempt to
regulate an immigration Detention
Facility that we don't have and we don't
expect to have and I would certainly
hope that new New Hampshire doesn't set
up any random immigration detention
facilities as as far as I know the
immigrants who are held here are people
who are charged with
crimes which is the same way
as regular people anybody else yes we we
don't have any specific facilities for
detaining immigrants and I personally
and representative sers do you wish to
speak thank you madam chair I totally
agree and let's leave this up to the
feds at this point this is a nationwide
issue not a state
issue okay anyone else have a comment
representative long uh I do want to note
that the uh straford County Jail is used
for immigration detention that's not
necessarily people who have uh been
charged with a crime uh could be anyone
who is removable uh from this country
either based on their immigration status
or based on their criminal record
subsequent to immigration
else
okay so the motion is inent to legislate
on House Bill
438 and the clerk can call the role Vice
chairman Leon yes the clerk votes yes
representative Pearson yes
representative Bailey I repes
representative gas yes representative
sers yes representative slaty yes
representative peoples yes
representative groa so in the spirit
that we never have one of these in New
Hampshire yes representative Schmidt yes
representative Davis yes representative
Dar
yes representative Howard yes
representative Tes yes representative La
yes and the chair yes that makes it 16
Z
okay motion passes 16 to zero any
objection to
consent okay we'll put that one on
uh representative L you have a motion on
House Bill
570 yes um I have an amendment um that I
will pass out sorry that I didn't drop
it sooner that was actually why I was
delayed
oops and here this is the other side of
this yes and it is Amendment 1
okay so I wouldve I would move Amendment
1 190h on House Bill 570 all right is
there a
second I guess and I'll let you know
what it is representative Bailey
seconds thank you okay representative L
uh thank you madam chair um looking at
this this is actually a pretty signif
ific expense I know it and this
amendment would repeal the board um I do
recognize that there's the potential for
cost savings however this information is
largely collected at the department of
insurance and uh there are many other
Market solutions to do this I'm also
concerned that um this may end
up mutating into basically a statun
pharmacy benefits manager with some of
the inherent risks that come with those
and therefore um well I feel that it's
unfortunate I feel that these resources
can better be allocated elsewhere so I
think the policy decision of ending the
prescription drug affordability board is
prudent given the current
situation okay represent ba you wish to
speak to your
second does anyone else have a comment
represent groda yes so this um bill has
been before us in many forms for the
number of time years that I've been on
Edna
and I don't believe that um this board
is re you know people say that it's dup
the efforts are duplicated well then
show them to me we've been waiting to
see those are asked for them and we
haven't seen them so I don't know if
that's the case and again this is a
financial decision to buy a policy
committee which I don't agree with so
I'll be voting against the um itl motion
or against the amendment the amendment
else okay in that case the motion is to
adopt Amendment 0190 on House Bill 570
and the thir call the
r Vice chairman Leon yes clerk put yes
representative Pearson yes
representative Bailey I rep
representative gas yes representative
sers yes representative SL yes
representative peoples yes
Representative groden no representative
Schmidt no representative Davis no
represent representative Dary no
representative Howard no representative
t no representative long no and the
chair yes 97 in favor of adopting the
amend
Amendment the amendment passes represent
Lan you have a motion um yes I move to
um move a to pass as amended on um House
okay all right any further discussion
since this is a complete
replacement the amendment replace the
bill anyone
else all right those in favor the the
clerk will call the RO the motion is
ought to pass with Amendment uh Vice
chair Lan yes clerk VES yes
representative
Pearson yep
representative bayy hi representative
Shan darn it darn it representative G
D um representative sellers yes
representative
yes representative peoples
yes representative Gro no representative
Schmid no representative Davis no
Representative dargy no representative
Howard no Representative dver no
representative long no and the chair yes
97 okay motion passes 9 to7 I don't
think consent would be appropriate is
there someone going to write a Minority
Report I will thank you madam chairo
702 representative Lon uh yes I move in
expedient to legislate on House Bill
702 is there a
second say Okay broken seller seconds
all
right you speak speak to your motion uh
yes thank you madam chair um so State
retirees uh that retired that that were
hired uh before July 1st 2011 had their
extra and special duty hours acrew
towards their retirement um those that
were hired after that did not have their
uh those hours ACR to retirement if we
are looking to allow more hours worked
and we do this with a type of hours that
added to the retirement um I think that
that is a poor policy decision because
we are treating the same time
differently and we're treating it
differently with different employees if
we were talking only about um tierc I
forget exact the C group I forget
exactly the terminology the tierc group
where this extra and special duty pay
did not acue to their retirement I I
don't think that I wouldn't really see a
problem per se based on um the type of
hours that are worked uh but we're not
going to see those people retiring for
several more years so it would be
preemptive to do that the other issue
too um is is that if somebody works too
many hours it's not just a little whoops
when you go back on active status it's a
pretty significant impact um don't know
if another Committee Member will be able
to speak to that um more thoroughly than
I but I I'm very very concerned that
this could be a situation where not only
are we treating different people people
differently with the and the same hours
differently it may actually get some
people into some real trouble
financially representative do you wish
to speak to your motion representa shean
you're are you through with your other
committee
almost all
right so um Madam chair while they're
tagging up um I can answer that question
for representative Lon oh please so in
reference to the penalty for
hours if you exceed the maximum amount
of hours as a retiree you come out of
retirement which means your pension St
Pops that is something
that you would think would be tracked by
the retirement system it is not so if
you as an example work per DMS let's say
for multiple agencies you are on the
hook to track it
yourself and if you go over there's no
going back there's an there is a real
danger in that now um wasn't not so much
years ago um but with the with the huge
recruitment problem that we're having
having um we're relying
on retirees to do per DMS more and more
so um that has occurred it's very rare
but um it is it's not something that can
be just undone here so um that that is a
real
concern unfortunately within this piece
of
legislation
um and is is something that I think we
need to look
at
holistically additional elements in the
way retirees are allowed to work in New
Hampshire uh Beyond just 702 we need a
holistic look at this so unfortunately
that's kind of where we are gon sers do
you wish to speak to your second okay
I'd like to agree with representative
Pearson that we need to look at why
we're limiting the hours retire can work
and not just saying well you can exempt
this one here and this one here and and
doing a patchwork because the point of
limiting the hours is
to ensure that you don't end up firing a
full-time person and hiring a part-time
person to replace them because that
part-time person will not contribute to
the to the retirement system and the
employer will not contribute to the
retirement system
so if you do need a full-time person um
you need to have somebody who is in the
system contributing to it and
not sucking assets away from our system
representative Schmidt so I I have
chair magically
disappeared represent Shan is has not
finished with her work in her other
committee and there she is still being
spying I'm delighted to have her back we
always miss her representative scitec
you had a comment uh yes this is a a
moderately outrageous suggestion which I
rep recommend to representative Pearson
I think that retirement should be a
benefit like vacation you get your
retirement and if you want to go back
you start as a greeny you start start
again that would require a great deal of
discussion to make implement it in a
fair when the desial commission meets
next year we can take that
up as part of a holistic look at working
yeah the desal commission's convening
next year so or in uh in 27 in 27 so yep
yeah representative
deers thank you madam chair but I I
agree taking a holistic look at that at
this makes a lot of sense but in the
interim our municipalities are saying um
that they're having a hard time finding
police officers to do this work and if
we make if we remove the cap on retirees
this is a benefit to our municipalities
so I heard talk earlier about I hear it
actually every day about the cost of our
property taxes and property taxes going
up if we can and the municipalities have
said that this is something that is
ultimately a money maker for our
communities to have a retiree in that uh
role as opposed to an active duty police
officer I think that until it gets fixed
holistically as as my colleague
suggested or CL suggested um that that
that this in in the short term until
that is corrected this helps our
communities so that's why I'll be the uh
one comment on that is that almost no
retirees work anywhere close to the
limit of ours special Duty or not
and it's
unnecessary so um I would I would say
that
it that's a nice thought but I don't
think it it's
a um a major issue if the the problem of
getting retirees to to work any hours
is you
know you have to convince them they want
to yes represent uh thank you madam
chair um I actually do want to um
correct something that I said earlier in
the subcommittee meeting when I was
discussing some of the rates that were
told um for some details um at the time
when we had settled it out we didn't
realize that the amount that was given
by the patrol officer was wildly out of
line with the actual department policies
and uh there'll be further conversations
about that I'm not trying to I I was
Raising just the question about the idea
of raising funds from our our our
citizens as opposed to getting into a
bigger issue so I just wanted to correct
that yes followup I I was going to
suggest that that the leadership of
Hampton talk to the people in uh uh down
in Dairy so thanks so much for that okay
all right anyone else have a comment
question concern all right the motion is
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
702 and the clerk can call the
role Vice chair Leon yes the clerk votes
yes representative Pearson yes represent
Bailey I repres representative gon yes
representative sers yes representative
yes representative
peoples yes representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative Davis yes representative
dargy yes representative Howard yes
Representative
no there's one in every crowd
representative Pat Uh representative
long uh no uh the chair yes looks like
14-2 all right the motion passes
14-2
is do either of you plan to write a
Minority Report no no and no objection
to consent have any objection to
consent no all right then we will put
consent
okay House Bill 581 representative L um
yes thank you madam chair I've
distributed an amendment and um I would
representative seller seconds
okay um thank you madam chair I will um
discuss what is in this amendment so
that you understand what what changes
there are relative to the bill um the
bill was is initially written with a
July 1st 2025 date for this new group
three employee group um however there
could be some implementation issues from
having it having that group go live
immediately at the same time that the
bill becomes effective so um the
implement the the higher date that's the
go live date has been moved to January
1st 20126 and that follows throughout
the bill wherever that date um comes up
this also um this also adds I need to
find the exact line in here but it says
that when somebody is vesting their
vested payments that they paid in are
immediately vested but for the state um
they need to be in for two years before
the state contribution is vested um
that's very consistent with Private
Industry and there's absolutely zero
reason to give something that's um more
goldplated than what the citizens who
pay for these salaries receive um this
also included some up some changes in an
amendment brought by the prime sponsor
of the bill representative Dan McGuire
just to make sure that the group three
employees uh are included in medical
Surgical benefits and um the Health
Insurance Group Insurance inclusion um
so that simply adds the group three to
the list of group one or group two um in
a couple important
sections so that is the bulk of the
Amendments that we discussed in
subcommittee this
morning sers do you wish to speak to
your
second
okay anyone
else representative Smith have this
amendment
uh yes I handed it out to everybody okay
well
you I I did it's somewhere in that stack
I can see if I have another one but I
think I put them on the
end and I do recognize that some people
will be voting against the ultimate bill
but I think that this amendment um just
has some important clarifications that
would be good to uh make sure that we
move through and then however you vote
on the next motion obviously isn't Tied
else okay the motion is to adopt
amendment 0502 to House Bill 581 and the
clerk can call the rule Vice chairman
Leon yes cler votes yes representative
Pearson I will vote Yes on the amendment
representative Bailey I representative
gas yes representative
yes representative SL yes representative
peoples yes representative Groo to my
colleague to my right who I have a lot
of respect for I vote no I'm sorry okay
representative Schmidt no representative
Davis no represent Argie
no representative Howard no represent
dver no representative law no the chair
yes I
s
okay the amendment passes 9 to7
representative Lon uh yes I move ought
to pass on House Bill 581 as amended by
that this to me and I think going
forward this actually helps the state
employees that would then be hired at
the certain
time to be more in line with corporate
America as well even though we're a
government everybody's used to Corporate
America and they use like a 401 case so
this is a very good idea and plus it
puts the state as far as putting the
money into the bank or our side
immediately and not just guessing at
much should be put
aside thank you representative Howard
thank you madam chair this bill is
attempting to shift risk responsibility
from the employer to the employee but
due to the way that we currently uh have
our defined benefits package set up new
employees help cover uh the unfunded
liability paying it down over time with
the defined uh contribution plan that
we're proposing here our unfunded
liability will go up excuse me repr
the the the unfunded liability for those
positions is explicitly paid for in this
bill I I understand that the employer
aspect is paid for but the uh employees
themselves are not vested so they're not
necessarily being required to pay in the
same as current group one and group two
employees this leaves us holding the bag
and retirees without a guarantee uh of
their their benefit
this also makes employees more portable
which some people do like but in my
opinion this is not good for New
Hampshire because our state is already
struggling to be competitive when it
comes to wages and benefits making it
easier for our neighbors to poach Talent
while making our state worse off thank
else thank you madam chair
uh we throw around a lot is the private
sector and getting things in line with
the private sector uh I I don't know
that we're going to start uh offering
stock option plans to our state
employees I don't know if we're going to
offer B performance
bonuses to our state employees those are
things that occur in the private sector
all the
time uh the
there are elements of this bill that I
like especially when it comes to what we
referred to two years ago as the
desertification of positions in
reference to the unfunded
liability I like that concept the
problem was that in a bill that was
filed two years ago in this the
retirement system made it very clear
that because they don't
track data that way that it's not
possible to pull that out it was also
reiterated here in the public hearing
that the UA assignment to positions is
not something that they can do they
they're going to have to rework a ton of
stuff to to even begin to gather the
data to figure that out that
is problematic I I wish they could
figure that out because then uh you know
we would we would be using that in in an
in another area in in other legislation
but they can't
so what ends up happening is if you
can't figure that out then the UA is
spread out over the entire Corpus of
group one
which then will have an effect of
causing a rate increase that rate
increase will be borne not only by the
state but it will be borne by the local
well that is why that's part of the
reason why why this has such a big
fiscal note on it because there is
a
now that that is going to be a big
problem one because it it's it's a down
shift and two because it's an increase
the second concern I have has to do with
what looks like something that's rather
minor this it's a 5% contribution
rate that sounds very relatively small
but the the reality is the normal
operation cost for group one is 2.42%
it's doubling that it's a tax
increase the conditions around it don't
work and I will not support
it person slash you had a
oh repr Schmid sorry this is just a
technical note but for the new members
we want to get into the habit
of using correct terminology so the
amendment Mo the motion on the bill is
ought to pass with Amendment not as
amended only the house can amend the
bill so for the moment it's only a
recommendation so the correct motion is
what to pass with Amendment thank you
thank you representative lamb uh thank
you madam chair 16 years and two days
ago I lost my livelihood because the
company I was working for was bringing
on more and more business units in order
to cover its losses in other areas I
lost my job because my employer had
created its own Division and had created
something in order to try and keep
something going um I'm really really
concerned when we talk about the idea
that we can't have any Innovation or
change in how retirement works for our
state employees just because we need to
make sure that those next people hired
are paying for the people who are
already in that didn't work out for me
when I was hired into that company and I
was hired on and I was bringing in money
that was covering for um some some
Financial choices in the past of my
employer and while there may be some
challenges as we move to a defined
contribution system as somebody who
personally lost their job in one of
these companies that um that ended up
getting prosecuted um I'm really really
sensitive to that small but real risk
that we could end up in a situation
where everybody's trapped and we just
need to keep increasing the amount of
people hired by the state
and increasing the amount that's going
to property taxpayers and increasing all
of this because of the retirement system
now I do have to say I have far greater
confidence in the New Hampshire
retirement system than in my former boss
um I I have to say that even if you
throw parties at the New Hampshire
retirement system they're probably not
the same as what that boss had but um I
I'm highly sensitive to the fact that
when you concentrate risk in one entity
there's that is something where you
can't make manage that risk well that's
why our property taxes are so high
because we were not appropriately
funding the retirement system way back
when we are still paying for that
mistake and my great concern is that
until we can offer a retirement system
that's on par with all those young
families were trying to attack to New
Hampshire it's going to be very very
very hard to bring people in have them
work for a few years in the state
government and then go off to create
something else because where citizen
legislature at a certain point having a
citizen government as well where
somebody steps in takes a job wait works
for a little while and then goes back to
Private Industry I think would be a
beautiful thing and I think that this is
an important enabling option in order to
do that and the fact that it's only
dealing with state employees and it's
very narrow and very limited I think is
critical and the other point too is that
when you're doing this and you're
allowing all of those contributions to
grow um when you're looking at this in
your 45 years old if your retirement
balance is higher than you expected
you're not going to stop contributing as
much to it for one thing the law is
going to say you keep contributing 7%
and the state contributes five that
means that all of those gains keep going
into your earnings um if you were to
model out over the last 40 years when we
had quite a few years that were not
impressive um and and had some problems
in the stock market it actually would
lead to a 4% withdrawal rate from that
to
contribution that is um 999,000 versus
58,000 in a scenario where you start at
$25,000 in scenario and that is some
pretty powerful leverage from a market
that honestly hasn't been the best
Market in history but still in those
stagnant years after the do com bust
that time when nobody was hiring anybody
we still have had good returns and and
lastly when your money is growing in the
market um occasionally you have
stagflation occasionally you have times
when there's inflation when you're
buying things but the Market's not going
up but as a normal rule those investment
levels will be going up so you'll
actually have more money to pay for
those eggs and pay for that meat and pay
for your property taxes as well so it's
a drisking even though it seems scary
right now this is drisking the
retirement system which is why I I feel
so strongly about it s representative
bayor
I thank you Shar lady here um this the
second or third term I've time I've
heard recently about this notion that
you have to constantly have new people
to be paying the pensions of the old
people and I would refer you to a
dictionary or to economics textbook of
that's the classic definition of a Ponzi
scheme and you know I this is our chance
to get out of that and we're evidently
going to forgo it but I regret reg that
and I will be voting in favor thank you
else all right uh the motion is ought to
pass with Amendment on House Bill 581
and the clerk can call the
role Vice chair Leon yes clerk V yes
I representative guy
yes representative sers yes
representative
sloty yes representative of peoples yes
representative Broda no representative
Schmid no representative Davis no
Representative dargy no representative
Howard no Representative dver no
representative long no and the chair yes
why 88 what a surprise
yes the motion has is
tied we will go with no
recommendation and it will not be on the
consent
calendar I consent to that thank you I
thought you might all right uh let's get
a couple of the of other things taken
care of and one of the things is I got
to go down the hole and get some more
papers all right stretch your legs we'
are on House Bill 210 represent a you
have a motion I'd like to move that we
itl House Bill
210 do we have a title Please for what
house bill 210 is that would be
establishing a commission to study the
state flag and its
history is there a
second representative seller seconds
thank you representative Bailey you wish
to speak to your motion well as Charming
as I found that recent attempt to change
the state flag
I feel like there's not that much to
study uh we heard the deficiencies of
our current flag being a blue bed a blue
state seal on a blue bed sheet
and yeah but uh we don't seem inclined
to change it thank
you okay represent sellers okay does
anyone else have a comment
representative Schmidt I think I had to
be out of the room when we were hearing
this bill
uh and uh seems to me
that that when they discussed the flag
it turned out that there were
several items on the seal which is on
the flag that are inaccurate or
inappropriate uh but we're not going to
change the state seal like at at this
point however when I discovered that
there are about what 10 or 12 other
state flags that look ex almost exactly
the same except they have seal or
something you can hardly see from the
ground which is where most flags are VI
viewed from not up next to the flag um
since none of us are Superman to fly
around uh that it would be a good idea
to consider changing the flag I didn't
like the idea of accepting the one flag
that was proposed if we're going to have
a a new flag it ought to be something
that has wide approval and is a definite
Improvement so I I'm not going to vote
no on
this anyone else BS and BR so this is
the second year that we've heard flag
bills and I'm afraid that this is going
to
continue so I would rather have a
commission to study the flag and just
get it done with and then that way if we
don't like the flag that they come up
with we don't have to vote for it but at
least we address the the thoughts of the
flag and all the concerns to this
commission so I'll be voting in support
of this I really find it hard to believe
but I will be thank you okay well that's
one one reason can make a commission so
year all right anyone else have a
sellers
um I'll have to agree I appreciate
representative gr's effort to save us
will
but I
will anyone else we don't no all right
the motion is inexpedient to legislate
by represent ba Clerk and call the r
representative Lon yes rep the clerk
votes yes representative Pearson no
represent Bailey I representative uh
gison yes representative sers yes
representative
slaty yes representative peoples
yes Representative grod no
representative Schmidt no representative
Davis no repres Representative dargy no
representative Howard no representative
D no representative long no and the
88 it would be prudent to have our
entire legislative body render their
magnitude
what uh yes at this point we
have uh we can can report it with no
recommendation that's a 88 tie and let
the house fight it out
um or we can try a different motion and
hope to uh to convince people to to
pass any uh preference
folks obem uh thank you madam chair I I
I really don't think that fighting this
on the floor is a prudent use of
anybody's time I'm concerned about the
time with the commission but um I think
people will be volunteering for that um
so I I could be convinced to change my
mind on this so that we're not having an
88 battle on the floor all right in that
case your moving ought to
pass and
um a
second
okay any anyone wish further disc
Schmid representative sitech oh we can
make it this could be studied without uh
a state agency it can be or state
involvement Betsy Ross didn't need a
commission so I'm just I don't care
where we fight it I'm voting no against
against
this
okay I'm representative Pearson only
thing is the only thing is now with an
with an OTP motion it can be subject to
being
amended whereas it is an itl it cannot
so that leads do you have an amendment I
do not have an amendment I I want to
apologize because I was tasked with
getting an amendment and I was planning
on doing it after
this what your amendment to do what uh
eliminate the uh commission's ability to
create a flag on their own I believe
it's uh section
if I recall correctly that was a
permissive and not a uh directive they
may come up with the design yeah yes
correct still the goal was to delete
that and that has not been done
yet I would like to confirm because I
have my little note here so
representative Heath I mean
representative Howard is correct so we
can all Point our finger at him but
um yes but I will
I will vote in support of the autop pass
motion as as I don't feel strongly I I
can withdraw my motion and see if
somebody wants to present an amendment
later this is not an early
bill that that would uh be
appreciated all right we have we uh with
motion is ought to pass motion is
withdrawn we will take this up at some
amendment so from from from a procedure
standpoint do we need to recess the vote
we need we need to recess the executive
session on House Bill 210 okay we if we
need a specific date it's one o'clock on
March
okay yes I think I agree with
representative Layon that I don't want
to waste too much time on this one all
right
House Bill
227 represent lamb uh thank you madam
chair I would like to move ought to pass
on House Bill
227 I'll
second um House Bill 227 is a pretty
simple Bill where um it removes the
ability for somebody to practice
Psychotherapy without a license um this
stat this part of the law goes back to
2012 when the board of Psych of
psychotherapy was created there was
never any record of any discussion about
why you would exempt somebody working in
the schools from this ler though at the
time um I'm not sure if they had already
stood up a school
psychologist um designation currently
today school psychologists are licensed
at the Department of Education and most
likely on Friday we will be approving
the rules for a board of psychother uh
psychology um license because that is on
the docket for Jael car so the idea of
removing the ability from the Department
of Education before we actually have
approved any licenses under the board of
psychology I think would be far too
quick of a move and I think that even if
that is a direction that we would like
to take um as as uh my neighbor here had
suggested in their initial hearing I
think we should give it some time just
make sure that nobody nobody is trying
to give these services to vulnerable
kids without appropriate training and
without their appropriate um
consequences so this repeals an
exemption to the licensing um and there
there was no opposition to that the only
real discussion was about whether we
should take this bill and expand it just
to consolidate the process of the lure
but I think it's too soon to make that
move yeah I
would like I'd like to say that it isn't
just schools this exempts government
employees from perform
who from performing the
Psychotherapy and they don't need a
license and I think that a blanket
exemption of that sort just eliminates
the whole point of having us licensed to
do
Psychotherapy um if we're doing it for
Public Safety it's no less unsafe if
you're
uh somebody in the prison system is is
counseling somebody then if a fly by
person has a side office we we should
have the same
protections for unlicensed
practitioners whe no matter who they'
worked
for just as a matter of public safety
and
fairness represent Lam and if I may add
to that the the whole purpose of the
board of psychotherapy is to assure that
the services provided are of equ
equality consistent with the standard of
care of the profession and to safeguard
the public against harm which may be
caused by untraded unskilled or
unlicensed practitioners so thank you
for highlighting that it's not just the
schools it's also our prisons it's other
places as well yeah I mean it as written
the exemption would say that if your
town your town clerk wants to give you
psychological
advice she doesn't need a
license representative Dev thank you
madam chair um uh when we were
discussing
227 there was a question that was raised
about whether whether or not um
this this um would need to go to another
committee perhaps if I'm remembering
this correctly
um as to whether or not the Department
of Education was in the Edna's purview
that's one question that I have and
maybe that was answered in
subcommittee and I have a followup
question too thanks represent L um I
spoke with the Department of Education
um and they would be willing to make
that change but given that the the other
license hasn't moved this is within the
scope of Edna because this is a board
that is that is under Edna's Authority
it's not the Board of Education we don't
get the school nurses ones but because
this is an exemption from Statewide
licensing it is
ours okay and you had your other
question I have another question thank
you very much for that um because I I'm
not sure that we answered that question
definitively within this larger
committee and the other question that I
recall being asked was um when we talk
about duly chartered educational
institution there was a question raised
about whether or not this included
public schools and whether or not they
they qualified as duly educated or
rather duly chartered uh educational
institutions and I just Clarity on that
would be helpful to me to thank you um
thank you that language won't exist when
we pass this so the fact that they pass
language where we're not sure why
anybody would be exempt and what a duly
licensed public school is is not clear
and consistent with other language is
just sort of removing um removing the
appendix from this law it's not
particularly useful and it might get us
in
trouble okay thank you anyone else
concerns all right the motion is ought
to pass on House Bill 227 and the clerk
can call the role Vice chairman Leon yes
clerk votes yes representative Pearson
yes representative Bailey I
representative gas yes representative
sers yes representative slaty yes
representative peoples yes
representative groa yes representative
Schmidt yes representative Davis yes
representative Dary yes representative
Howard yes representative D yes
representative long yes and the chair
yes
160 okay motion passes 16 to zero any
objections to
consent right seeing none we'll put that
one on excuse me ex Howard I there is a
fiscal note on this bill I don't know if
that uh it is not a second committee
Bill the fiscal note is pretty tiny okay
if and so
it's I don't I don't think it would be
necessary but it's oh I'm I'm fine with
it being put on consent just uh wanted
to to make sure that we weren't doing
anything out of procedure uh no uh tiny
fiscal notes are okay also itls of big F
notes I have a question the chair yes
sir um on the 88s there's usually a
statement of pro statement con do we
specify that
now on the have uh well one of them we
are recessed on house build 10 okay but
there is one that did get exess yes
representative Lon will be writing a
a note in favor of ought to pass and
representative
um represent gr did you volunteer to
581 581 yes 581 representative L is
okay I think it must be me yes it is me
yes how
marvelous wait a minute I'm writing I'm
writing one I'm so sorry no I'm writing
The Minority Report on the um on 570 the
drug affordability board that's
something else that's separate something
else so I'll write the 581 well okay
thank you writing Mo what is the
ah without
word I'm so sorry I don't have my
microphone on let me have a think about
that and um because the amendment passed
right
yes so the minor it would be o itl it
would be itl for
right think we can get one more good one
Sashi yes mam chair I I'm uh
itl okay is there a second second
okay do you wish to speak to your motion
thank you madam chair yes I would um
this is relative to proxy carbon pricing
in state procurement um having listened
to the testimony um and considered uh
its effect um if I've determined that
it's un unwise to follow a uh rubric
that the state isn't actually um subject
to this is some speculative uh pricing
that might be imposed at some future
date that there's no certainty on
there's no mandate that the state
followed these these carbon pricing
guidelines um so uh that is why I move
uh itl
sorry representam uh thank you madam
chair um I'm opposed to this bill
because I had always thought that carbon
proxy proxy carbon pricing was actually
a market based price um I had never
looked into it all that much previously
because I assumed as somebody who was a
former Market maker that there was
things that were being balanced and that
would bounce around but when we learned
in committee exactly what it was it's
not a market pricing it is a it's
basically a
one-way um increasing drag on um anybody
who's spending on on something that has
to do with carbon this is a one-way
Direction where it continues to increase
the bill as written doesn't even have
the actual start values because it
started calculating prior to this so um
we had calculated already that with the
already of the increased growth we were
looking at a significantly larger number
already that we continue to ratchet up
and up and up we also heard that because
this is set as a global standard what
we're not going to have any control over
it and I also heard commentary that
suggests to me that once everybody's on
board this is going to this is going to
get larger and larger and larger um
while I personally try to be as green as
I possibly can be there's already enough
costs in making those choices I think
that adding in additional costs when we
frankly have people worried about
getting three meals on the table a day
and now we're going to be pricing in a
global standard for a punitive pricing
for for carbon I I think it's just the
wrong path forward for New Hampshire and
so I'm against this
bill representa freeze thank you madam
chair um my understanding of this bill
was that this it doesn't actually cost
us anything to take on board the the
cost to the state of the carbon so my
understanding was and I again could be
mistaken that what this does is cause
the state when it is purchasing to have
to take on uh and into consideration how
much carbon actually costs us so for
example if they're comparing one version
of a boiler and HVAC system to another
version of a boiler and HVAC system if
one is
significantly um less possibly maybe
nominally less
expensive but uses Burns a lot and
produces a lot more carbon and one is
nominally more expensive but
significantly more efficient that the
idea behind this is not to drive the
cost of our purchasing up but take that
into consideration in our procurement
and for that reason just
understanding that and letting it be a
consideration and asking the state
agencies when they're doing their
purchasing I am in support of this bill
representative
SL yeah I think uh representative re uh
raises a very good point and um but I
would just like to speak to the to the
idea that would it would not cost more
um what this bill would do in effect is
to force the state to take into account
uh additional cost evaluation for
effectively lower cost options and it
would
result in the state making purchase
decisions into more expensive equipment
that might not otherwise make sense so
it's factoring in these sort of
imaginary costs that are imposed by
Foreign States or foreign governments
that we don't necessarily have control
so in that sense it it delegates the
legislative authority to uh you know
either European nations or Global bodies
or some other entity that is not New
Hampshire so uh I don't know if that
helps but that's my understanding
represent BRK you so the bill doesn't
mandate anybody do anything they can buy
whatever boiler they want they can do
whatever they want it's a way of keeping
track of what the state is purchasing in
the in in the area of equipment
or um things that use fossil fuels
to keep a separate column
for carbon pricing that's all it does
and it seems to be something that the
department of administrative Services is
already doing in some way so I'm I'm I
will support the
itl um I don't
necessarily I I mean I can tell by
listening to everybody that everybody
has their own idea as to what this is
and it doesn't involve foreign States or
foreign countries it's just um a way of
keeping track of what the true cost of
carbon pricing is eventually and I'm
fine with I will support the itl
motion yeah I I'd like to say that one
of the reasons I'm opposed to this is
that it picks a
specific proxy price and inflates it and
tells uh administrative services to use
that rather than for them to use their
best judgment as to where Energy prices
and carbon prices are going to go I
spoke to some of the people in their
procurement department and they do this
all the time they are forecasting where
fossil fuels are going what the
likelihood
of a carbon tax is they are considering
it and they're already doing it
and I don't want to give them one
person's
formula and say use this instead of the
other all the other methods they're
using to look at forecasting energy and
carbon
prices representative Lon uh thank you
madam chair I think you did a great job
highlighting that right now the they are
already doing something that comes
closer to what the actual current price
and projected price basically the market
prices um and I appreciate
representative jere's um seeing like I
used to think it was that this carbon
proxy pricing was based on market
conditions um it's not we can talk about
whether or not it's a good idea to do
this in the first place but it's
definitely not Market based um so I
appreciate that they're already doing
this and taking a look at energy costs
because we all need to take a look at
energy costs representative ree thank
you very much Madam chair I'm not quite
sure that that's what I said um but I
may have uh I would just like to say
that um before we take a vote on this um
itl motion that it was offered that if
there is a federal policy put into place
um and and we frequently point on this
committee to what it is that that
private business is doing as though
that's something that we should take on
board when it comes to state government
in order to save people money there is a
risk of not taking this information onto
board in our procurement decisions
across state agencies because we may end
up picking a more expensive ensive
version of an hvx HVAC system a boiler
whatever it is that burns more carbon
we've made that purchasing decision and
then if there ends up being um a federal
policy put into place we will have made
a bad decision because we didn't even
consider this all that this bill is
doing is asking for the state agencies
those in procurement to take this into
consideration it does not need to be the
dispositive factor in any state
purchasing uh decision so for that
reason I'm going to vote against itl
okay anyone
else all right in that case the motion
is inexpedient to legislate on House
Bill 278 and the clerk can call the
role Vice chair Leon yes clerk votes yes
representative Pearson yes
representative Bailey I rep
representative gas yes
representative sers yes representative
yes representative peoples yes
representative groa yes representative
Schmidt
no represent Davis
yes represent darge
no representative Howard no
representative Diva re no representative
115 okay the motion passes 11 to5 I
don't think consent is appropriate is
someone going to be writing a Minority
Report representative Schmidt will be
writing a minority may I just I I was
the first one on this last vote to vote
no and I and I'm not trying to change
anybody's mind but this this is a
controversial issue uh I don't think we
uh are oblivious to the fact that the
weather is changing uh and and sometimes
I'm going looking out there and I'm
going like what's all this about global
warming when I'm freezing my butt off
out there uh so the bottom line is I
don't think we should have a unanimous
vote on this and if if I was the only
one so I'm glad to see that we had some
opposition because I don't think it's a
clear situation at all um and we know
that private business is factoring in
carbon costs and so forth so anyway
that's the reason I voted no okay very
good we will We await your uh
right Madam chair just to remind you I
have a subcommittee meeting that case I
think we've uh We've accomplished all
the necessary and a few of the nice
to-do ones so uh we will
get out of executive session we have
House Bill 210 still hanging over our
heads but that's an easy one all
right you've got the you've got the
James
e
all right I'm going to officially open
the
subcommittee on two House Bill
271 and that
is looking of course at the
examination question that we've had in
reference
okay okay and we'll be looking at
representative grod's Amendment which is
uh number nine excuse me 495
H and uh representative Grotto why don't
you uh walk us through it okay so in the
original um
RSA the
licensed social worker assistants were
asked to pass a national proctored exam
approved by the board and that turned
out to be more onerous
than um the social broker
Association
light and between them and the board I'm
suggesting that there is a
an amendment that says that they need to
pass a uniform competence assessment
examination of Social Work knowledge
skills and abilities approved by the New
Hampshire Board of mental health
practice that way it it is there is an
exam but it's the one approved by the
board and it's up to them how they want
it to be which what they want in their
exam
examination so I'm I'm uh thinking that
this represents everybody's interest and
I move this
amendment towards House Bill 271 so it
would
one
five
the director of oplc was here she was
here oh well okay are you aware of of um
this okay all right hi so yeah um you're
as they say my colleagues in Oklahoma
say you're fixing to be up pretty soon
so
um do you have a copy have you seen
representative Billy is there a is there
a u there were there was there was a
spare
copy right did he give you two well
there should be some should have two
okay all right okay we have you can have
one D I'm gonna put you in the hot seat
you good afternoon just for the record
the jurus executive director
oplc happy to opine on this thing I'm
seeing for the first
time
yes so representative grota did explain
um the yeah why don't you do that one
more time I apologize that's that's okay
so rather than having
the licensed social worker Associates
having to pass a national proctored exam
that has to do with license social
workers um the language in the bill
would change to they would have to pass
a uniform competence assessment
examination of Social Work knowledge
skills and abilities adop approved by
the New Hampshire board a mental health
practice so it gives the board the
authority to design a test or use a test
but it gives them the authority to
it does it would seem to broaden the the
choices
yes certainly we would be able to
implement that if that's the question
yep
perfect that's great yeah all right is
there anyone here that wants to speak to
this change anyone has concerns on this
amendment to
marvelous I think thank you sh okay so I
would like the subc commmittee
to support recommending to the committee
Amendment House Bill
FN 0495 H Excuse me yes 0495 H
marvelous all right I I will second that
uh that request is there any discussion
in reference to this by either any
committee seeing none I think this uh
solves the overlying problem that we
were talking about in reference to an
exam that didn't match a job and a
desire to not repeal an exam process
that was ju that was just created and
really implemented less than a year ago
so I think we've kind of uh We've
compromised here in in working that
forward
and uh we'll we'll see how this goes and
and as long as the Director can
Implement as she stated then I think
it's uh I think this might just work so
I'll uh I'll I'll call a vote on
adopting the recommendation in the
subcommittee representative
[Music]
groda yes yes I vote Yes I'm sorry yes
the chair votes yes representative
Bailey I and representative long yes
perfect all right so that will go
forward as the recommendation to the
full committee as to how to solve the
issues that we had with House Bill 271
if there's nothing else on the docket on
271 I will close the subcommittee
hearing on 271 and we will open the
subcommittee hearing on um
145 okay so I um sent the amendment to
um
OS and this had to do with
the background check the criminal
history record check portion of the bill
which was portion one and I'm sorry to
say that I don't know where the
amendment is it's I think I I don't know
what happened but I don't have it in
front of
me and um so I do have the language
which
um I would recommend to the
um that the committee the subcommittee
brings forth towards the committee the
large at large committee but I don't
have an amendment number let me just see
if I can figure this out from my I am so
sorry when did they get it like how long
ago they got it I mean I have it I I
just don't
know what the heck happened to it if
they sent it back to you it should have
a number I know I'm looking through my
emails now I'm just a little bit behind
stuff you know what I mean so uh d
d actually Mr fr attorney fry sent me
the amendment marvelous and I would love
well do you want us to address the
concept while you're looking for the
specifics representative I realized that
I'm looking for something that OS has
not sent back to me so I don't have I
sent the one for House Bill 82 yesterday
which I didn't think I would get back
but attorney fry did send me both okay
documents marvelous are the are they
since we're covering the same FBI
background check do they read the same
then we can talk about
it right now so go for it yep happy to
let attorney fry take that and we'll
also defer to our our friends at the
department of safety who are really the
ones with the expertise we're just
trying to implement what if I might ask
do you want me to run upstairs and see
if I can get a copy of what they let me
do that while you're talking I'm going
to run upstairs sounds
great make sure we have both 82 and this
one as well just so so perfect sure so
um sort of what we were talking about at
the committee meeting which is just
changing the criminal background statute
to just get more specific right instead
of using just the office or the office
of professional liur and
certification so some suggested language
that um we run by do was to um use the
executive director of The Office of
professional
license uh license insurance
certification or it's design or it's
design um and then also just defining
what that design is so it we use some
language that was in the education bill
that um the captain had sent over to to
us and just inserted our own titles in
there so offices agency counsil
administrative law judge uh director of
Licensing and a board administrations
licensing service representative or
board administrator so we just put in
titles that we thought someone's hands
might actually touch a criminal
background check throw it in there okay
so that would be section three of the of
145 which
covers um that criminal history portion
and use the term office which seemed to
be what was
problematic yeah so yeah lines 3 through
145 okay and then in addition to that I
will say the one thing I inadvertently
forgot when I sent over the amendment to
representative Grotto was to get the
effective date in there because that was
another key component and I believe was
that July 1 of
2026 yeah
okay effective date of the bill itself
or effective date of the section
I'm sorry I missed that effective date
because the the effective date of the
entire bill is 60 days after passage you
want a different effective date for the
background
check well I think to add some Vic Muzzy
um charge of the Justice information
Bureau for the State Police which is
overseas the criminal records unit
obviously this bill is two part right
we're talking about criminal background
checks for dieticians and then adopting
the the compact so my fear is that I
don't want to um hold up the potential
adoption of the compact if that's
obviously pressing in something that's
very near and dear to folks my only
concern is that if I guess I'll say this
if the effective dat is remains at 60
days after its passage the only trouble
with that is we won't be able to
disseminate any criminal records or
fingerprint folks um until such time
that we get the approval from the FBI
criminal justice okay you know the law
unit so that's the only hang-up um is is
would be our ability to actually do that
um until such time that we hear back
from them which could be upwards of a
year so I don't know if it makes sense
to dissect the effective date and say
the effective date of of section two
will be 60 days after its passions and
section one will be upon effective upon
the approval of the FBI criminal law
unit that might be sufficient and
appropriate language to satisfy
both areas I know it's going to come as
a shock to some people but government
sometimes moves at the speed of smell
and in this particular case keeping a
60-day inaction date just give it's it
enables it to happen any sort of delays
that occur in
processing we would not legislate in a
time frame for that because all we would
be doing is pun intended handcuffing
ourselves right in that regard so if we
let's say we push that out six months
and this gets figured out in five we sit
there n so so it's it's okay to have
that 60 days there it's just the you
know the board of the LC Bo um
Administration is going to obviously
have to convey to those that put in for
this please understand that we're
working through a process of approval
and as soon as that happens we're golden
y but I don't I don't want to put a
secondary date on that I it it'll just
enable it to occur and then as we're
able certainly to process it we can so I
that that's not going to be necessary to
to make this work oh very good I just
wanted for awareness purposes wanted to
make sure everyone knows that you know
we will be hindered I guess until that
that time but and and my hope is is that
once once we get language that the FBI
is happy with we can then mirror that
across certainly other boards and as
well so no that's the intent and I think
I think what we have here in my
professional opinion or our professional
opinion Christine Shay is actually the
the administrator over the criminal
records unit is also the compact officer
so she has a a is on a national board
basically relative to the dissemination
of the FBI's record for employment
purposes um so we feel that basically
the language that's been been amended or
added will suffice and we'll pass that
test based upon our experience a lot of
things lately have been um denied based
upon being too broad sure they don't the
FBI is really unwilling to sort of
redefine that for us in the context of
whatever Bill we've put before them they
just kind of give us a boil plate
language that says oh this is too broad
that's really helpful appreciate that so
that's why we've modeled this after
18913a because that recently has changed
and been passed um and so it seems to
make sense to us that trying to model
language after that would be the obvious
course of action given no other guidance
from the FBI um legal unit so and on top
of that if we've been successful we can
go hey you just you know we you were
good here how come we not good here read
the same so that I think that's that's
fantastic that
vets I think what we need to do uh in
that regard so that is the overwhel hang
up that we had on
145 it appears as though it is we hope
so um Mr Greenland is getting a copy of
what I sent to OS and if we all have it
in our hands and read it that's not it
that's for House Bill 82 so if we could
maybe we might until Mr Green comes back
hop over to House Bill 82 because it's
the same issue if it is literally really
the same language since this is a
subcommittee and it's a recommendation
to the full committee if it is the exact
same language we can process
it so this is um the proposed language
to House Bill 82 which I sent to OS over
the weekend and they should be sending
it to me as an amendment with a real
number but in the meantime if the
committee will accept this language as
the language that will be
um used to amend House Bill 82 and 145
and 14 well 145 I believe is a little
shorter because this Bas yeah it's the
same language this basically addresses
these a different board like the first
one board if you see at the bottom is
the psychologist criminal history check
and then there's also the installation
board so this is all the languages this
this has to do with all the background
checks that are in House Bill 82
and then here is the language which is
the same one
for House Bill 145 marvelous since we're
still we're still technically in 145
yeah you pass thank you so this is the
language that I would
recommend and I will have the amendment
number for the committee when we have
the executive session on this which I
think will be March
5th right corre yes that's correct okay
yeah so they do read
fantastic representative Pearson May
interject for absolutely so there are um
two sections for criminal background
checks in there one's for Board of
mental health practice the other ones
for psychologists the intent was to make
sure that it mirrored what is in the
dietitians and then there are also some
minor changes that OS had brought to our
attention um with conflicts between RSA
310 yes and uh board specific statutes
that are also in there and then if you
remember correctly there was also a
discussion uh Mr Steve Rancor came up
and he had some concerns about
electricians language so I've been going
back and forth with him on language and
that is also incorporated into that
Amendment beautiful okay but not it's
incorporated into the 82 Amendment 82
yes right so as far as getting 145
processed and and finished before we get
into
82 do I do I have any concern concerns
by other members of the sub wonderful so
let's uh let's go ahead and we'll do
this without a without a number since
it's just an OS delay and that really is
irrelevant we can that can be dealt with
afterwards so um for the adoption of the
proposed amendment for 145 to fix
the background check
language you're going to you're going to
tell me something right yes I move
in the um in the document that we have
that says proposed amendments to House
Bill
145 amending lines 3 to 21 relating to
criminal history record checks I move
this as the
amendment that we would am amend House
Bill 145 with to make the background
check information compliant with the
requirements of of enforcement and and
um I will have the amendment number for
the executive session on the 5th of
March and I will second that any further
discussion or
concerns all right the uh what you what
do you say representative
Bailey I'm fine you're and I yes
wonderful represent long Perfect all
right so are there any other questions
or concerns in reference to house Bill
145 that would like to be brought
forward seeing none I will close the
subcommittee hearing on House Bill 145
82 so Mr chair in front of you you see
language that starts with proposed
amendments to House Bill 82 this is the
document that I sent to OLS to represent
the amendment to House Bill 82 which
addresses different board Boards of
oplc and um there are different
requirements under each board the first
one is to amend Section 8 which has to
do with mental health practice and
processing of license license
applications and so um Section 8 lines
20 to 30 um go they they start at
section one with every applicant for
initial licensure
this is the
um criminal background check information
as well as section two as well as
section three um the next um section has
to do with psychologist which is at the
bottom of the page and it reads to
amend um lines 27 to
37 again section one is the licensing SE
I mean sorry section one two and three
have to do with criminal background
checks as well as section
four and then um the next section would
be to would be section 31 which has to
do with Podiatry again um there was a A
Change by the by OS in section B subject
to the discipline in accordance with
this chapter in RSA 10 as opposed to RSA
359 in the original bill
um in section this is still and then
then the next section has to do with the
electricians which is the concerns that
Steve Rancourt had in section 39 which
mentions RSA
319 C
col8 and
then on the next page
um we have uh the installation standard
board
which was again a reference to which
needed to change the reference to RSA
310 per the office section 44 is the
installation board again of manufactured
housing again has to do with fees and
it's in accordance with RSA 310 which is
the home RSA for oplc so I think that
this has addresses all and since section
45 it repeals the um that particular
section on fees because it's the wrong
it it doesn't refer to that any longer
so I think that this addresses all the
cleanup issues that had to do with House
Bill 82 to make it in compliant with
current oplc regulations and background
checks regulations that were refer is
that they may have to have three or four
licenses under the MRT so in
conversations with representative
Maguire she was uh would prefer to see
one license type for the Mr
professionals and so um what she had
done with the amendment was at least put
a placeholder of uh with that indication
of having one license but we took it a
step further uh with the handout that I
just shared with the committee um
because there are certain pieces within
each of the modalities that are um
overly prescriptive with respect to
being being at least the age of 18 and
having obtained a high school diploma or
passed an approved equivalency test
almost all of these modalities require a
higher level of education so those are
assumed that they would be over 18 and
would have a high school diploma but
because current statute has that in
there oplc has to ask for their High
School um diplomas and it's really
difficult especially for individuals who
are coming from other states to produce
that if they've been in the profession
for many many years so this is a cleanup
opportunity for the MRT so what I handed
out is the suggested statutory changes
to rep reflect one license type for all
of these modalities and also to clean up
the um the credential requirements happy
to answer any questions oh I would also
add that um I have worked with oplc on
this language so they're aware of it
I've also met with the MRT Advisory
Board they're also aware and approve of
these changes as well wonderful
representative gr so I have
representative Maguire's original
Amendment yes which amended um which
added section
11 to
this to your amendments what it it's it
added so 328
dj1 starts with one limited x-ray
machine operator license and it went and
then it went through it just left
everything the same except it added
section 11 yeah I think she added at the
end versus my language I think is in the
introductory paragraph which is how the
crafted if that makes sense it does but
it specifically says here any licenses
issued for Medical Imaging Professionals
and radiation therapists is valid for
every
modality so you're where are you seeing
that where am I seeing that in your
Amendment so I did not include her
language 11 I had written this before
she had submitted her Amendment so I
think conceptually it's the same thing
it's just a matter of construction as to
where you would want to put this one
license type um again we're where I had
put it in um my uh handout that I gave
you it is the way that it's currently
crafted in the statute starts off the
executive director no my my language is
hers she added an 11 she sort of added
at the
end yeah go for it so but in your
Amendment you
remove a from all the
modalities except for um limited x-ray
machine correct whereas she hasn't
changed anything about that she
recognized that um further revisions
were necessary and she asked me to bring
this to
subcommittee I see yeah I do recall um I
do recall some discussion in reference
to having to pluck this out of multiple
sections to make it work so it appears
that's what you've done
here which yeah I I do agree it does
seem peculiar to ask for something um
I've I've presented a master's my
master's degree to someone and then said
oh no no we need your high school
diploma and I oh okay that's cute but
sure right we can do that I I I get
where you're coming here and uh it is
it's just you know one of the things
that one of the things that happens is
that we get agencies or groups or dep
departments in the state that look at
something and go oh that's dumb we're
not going to do it but here's the thing
when we pass law you got to do it it's
not optional it's law so if it's bad
let's get rid of it but the idea of well
we're just going to ignore a law that we
don't we think is dumb is not how this
whole universe is supposed to work so I
appreciate you uh bringing this forward
with the
necessary uh cleanup to to handle this
properly so that the agency is not
required to do something under law that
really they don't need to do anymore so
correct um as far as the as far as the
insertion where that gets inserted
whether it's a paragraph 11 or how they
do that is Believe It or Not really
actually up to OSS right so what I'm
going to do now is I'm going to
pull my recommendation for this
amendment House Bill 82 because we have
to include this as
well it could yeah I mean it could be
done as as two amendments it could be it
would be better if it was one it's going
to be one and if the the committee
trusts me I will be glad to attach this
and representative Maguire's attach
Amendment and my proposed language
together and bring to the executive
session on March 5th an amendment that
is that includes all
these if if that is the desire of the
subcommittee that's the desire of the
subcommittee representative Bailey no
you're good okay I do want to hear from
I do want to hear from from one other
person in the in the uh that would like
to to come forward and speak and then I
do want to hear from oplc so great thank
you thank you ma'am come forward and uh
just make sure for the record you let us
know who you are the record my name is
Michelle Heaton I am the director of
Life and Health at the New Hampshire
insurance department um we looked at
this and I apologize because I think our
we drafted an amendment and I think in
the shuffle it got lost so I'm not sure
that actually made it to who it needs to
go to but um our concern is with um
sections 15 and 26 of the bill in
cleaning up there these sections are
referring to
420j U colon
8-c and I think in cleaning up some of
the statutory
references um it can be somewhat
misleading so what we're recommending
instead is for those two Provisions
amending it so that it would say uh
mental health practitioners licensed to
practice in the state of New Hampshire
and just remove all the citations to the
various um things because in cleaning up
the citations I think it's implying
something that was not intended at all
all right go and I hit me with that one
more time section in section 15 which is
Managed Care law yes okay so it would
amend
420j 8 and um it would amend sub
paragraphs A and B so that we would read
mental health practitioners licensed to
practice in the state of New Hampshire
so removing the reference of RSA
330a yes okay and then for the
psychologist the same thing psychologist
licensed to practice in the state of New
Hampshire and we just believe that's the
cleaner way of cleaning up the statutory
references we just want to make sure
that anyone who is licensed to practice
in the state is able to be credentialed
by insurance companies which I believe
was the attent all along and I think in
just cleaning up some of the statutory
references it can be a little bit
do you have that written down yes and I
can email that to you I just don't have
it printed out unforunately can you send
that to me yes so um I'm
just I'm going to need the opinion of of
the oplc director on this one just to
make sure that that that falls in line
with the general way that things are
worded um
without because I'd have to look up 330a
to
well 330a is the mental health
practitioners licensing RSA if I if I'm
not
mistaken but I guess what you're saying
is just saying under RSA through
330a doesn't state that they are
licensed in the state of New Hampshire
no I believe in cleaning it up there was
removal of that reference to temporary
license and by doing that I think
there's an implication that because they
have a temporary license that they're
somehow not able to be credentialed and
that's not at all the case as long as
you have a license we don't care what
kind of license it is if you're licensed
then that is the requirement to be
credentialed and as part of the
credentialing process for insurance the
insurance compan is just required to
ensure that they have a license and the
ability to practice legally in the state
of New Hampshire so that's why we're
just wanted to clean up those references
and we think it's cleaner knowing that
statutes can change so we don't have to
come back and do this in the future um
just if they're licensed to practice in
the state of New Hampshire that's all
that the requirement is
okay and where is the reference to
psychologist in this bill um I think sub
paragraph A is for mental health
practitioners and then sub paragraph B
psychologists oh sorry B is in section
32 of the bill so somehow it got split
up into different sections but it's the
C
you
26 oh oh I see so it's it's page n it's
eight so it would be psychologist
licensed under the state of New under
the state of New to practice in the
329b okay well yes because that way it
would fall under all of the oplc statuto
thank
you thank you no problem would you I'm
going to bring up our orange tagged
friend here to
forward thank you Mr chair members of
the committee John dejoy representing
the National Association of Social
Workers as well as the New Hampshire
Psychological Association
um my clients object to this
recommendation uh with due respect to
miss Heaton I would like I would like to
live in the world that she just put
forward um but I'd like to explain to
the
subcommittee where this language came
from originally in
2019 Senator Khan introduced Senate Bill
80 Senate Bill 80 was directly addressed
at the significant backlog in Behavioral
Health practitioners being able to
practice in the
state initially it it addressed the
boards and speeding up the boards but
through testimony there was testimony
that credentialing of these same
professionals was taking an extensive
period of time
I can't get any more specific than that
because I've read the notes and that's
that's what I have from it but from that
conversation came this
language from talking to my clients
there was a time period
where
credentialing wasn't a foregone
conclusion for for folks under the
mental health Practice Act or
psychologists the language was added to
make it clear that these folks are
licensed and are in fact eligible for
credentialing our concern is that by
removing that language we could go back
to a bygone era where it wouldn't be a
foregone conclusion that um
professionals under the mental health
Practice Act and
psychologists uh are eligible for
credentialing so that's the reason we
object to it uh we think it just it's
clearer by stating the um the rsas that
just add the R I don't know if this
would work but could we do something
like psychologist licensed
under licens to practice under the state
of New Hampshire parentheses RSA
DB or does the I just is that sort of a
a good compromise between the two that
would that would almost be like saying
baby kitten I know but you know I'm just
I'm just trying to figure out I don't
know how that's going to I don't know
how that's going to satisfy both
entities here um I
think I think it might be we need to
talk to the
director so let's find out let's find
out what what the director's feel is on
this as far as this um the foregone
conclusion of
credentialing
and the backlog that once
existed uh thank you so much I think the
credentialing that's being referred to
is um by insurance and not by the office
specifically so there there's kind of
two different steps right there's the
credentialing the license or
certification that occurs within the
oplc and then there's a separate
credentialing that occurs for the
billing uh based on insurance I'm just
going to look back and say so far am I
right okay so they're talking about two
separate things so I believe the
credentialing of the previous discussion
is related to insurance billing and not
to the oplc issuing a a license to
practice I I I think one of the
considerations is um if there is a
temporary license or some we hear new
license types all the time and the
thought would be we don't want to impact
the I think the the consideration for
the insurance department is if they
create a new path to a psychologist
license or a mental health license in a
different chapter um um the we're not
going to have a flag in our email that
says hey make sure we look at that
Managed Care statute to ensure that it's
that we put the reference in so I think
that's the consideration is just to say
that it it's broad enough to catch if
there are additional considerations or
if the you know we do a full rewrite and
the boorder of psychology moves to a
different RSA so even if no other policy
change exists I think it's it it's to
say let's make sure that we're that
there isn't an impact there um if people
are getting cred from the office but
can't get credential because that number
is not referenced in this statute I
think that's the consideration really
has no impact on the office's ability to
credential people but that would be my
understanding
okay it it almost sounds like we're
we're talking about uh you know captain
of the army captain of the Navy not the
same thing but the same word is are we
confused are we using the same word in
two different universes here and fusing
what the what they do is the insurance
department can you help me with that for
a
second so yes there has been a lot of
confusion in the past regarding
credentialing and Licensing and the
requirements around credential and
Licensing when we're talking about
credentialing for insurance companies
under Managed Care the way that works is
um to be a part of a um Health
Insurance's Network for like your HMO or
po plan you know how you use your
insurance you go to an in network
provider so when they're building that
Network the carrier establishes um
credentialing criteria and I think just
to clear up any confusion um
insurers and providers this is a
contractual relationship that the state
is not involved in at all so there is
nothing that requires a carrier to
credential with any credential or
contract with any provider um I think
historically some of the backlog has
been because there are different levels
of um Mental Health Providers you know
we you have your doctors you have your
PhD level you have your Master's level
um I don't because there's a lot of
confusion between the difference between
lure which is setting the floor for what
you have to do to be able to practice in
the state and what you need to have in
order to be credentialed by an insurance
company which is different and I think
historically there's been a lot of
confusion about what that means and
there's also a difference between
privileges for a hospital so if you're
practicing in a hospital and getting
privileges that's a whole another
credentialing process as well so I think
there's been confusion as providers
sometimes didn't understand the
difference between what is required and
at the end of the day a carrier does not
need to contract or credential anyone
it's really up to them and the parties
to negot negotiate that contract so what
we've been doing at the insurance
department is trying to break down some
of these barriers and confusion around
credentialing and we've come a long way
but what we're trying to fix in the
statute is not even necessary to have
that in the statute we would argue
because we already have a whole another
section about what's required for
credentialing and in statute we have
some very basic minimal things that
before you can credential someone you
have to make sure that they're licensed
and you have to have certain
Consumer Protections in the contract
between the provider and the health
carrier um but at the end of the day we
do nothing to force people to contract
so I think that that those two
Provisions somewhat are unnecessary and
I think in the past what we've been
doing and what oplc has been doing is
revamping and creating new lure levels
with the idea that if th that person is
now licensed and we have set as a state
minimum standards and a scope of
practice for them that could lead to um
ures credentialing them and allowing
them to be reimbursed for services
provided to ured patients however that
is kind of conflating some issues and I
don't know that that's necessarily how
it how it's panning out but when we're
talking about Master's level uh
clinicians for social work um psychology
clinical mental health practice those
providers are being credentialed and um
we as the insurance department would
take any complaints relating to the
credentialing process and we oversee
that process to make sure certain
statutory deadlines are met so that the
process does move smoothly so under the
credentialing standards um the if they
get to that point of Contracting where
the insur is going to credential them
and they submit a clean application for
these Mental Health Providers of all
different levels the carrier has 45 days
to complete that credentialing process
to help streamline this process and make
sure that you know where we have
workflow issues throughout the state
insurance is not the hold up for those
workflow issues that if they have
decided to enter into a contract with
them they have 45 days to credential
them and so that they can start building
and be part of that provider Network so
I think there's a lot of different
issues here and we're conflating a lot
of different things but the only thing
we're concerned about is we want to make
sure there are no more barriers than
need to be in this whole credentialing
process and that's why our proposed
amendment we think removes any confusion
about that and makes it clear that the
only requirement is that you have a
license to practice and that goes back
to oplc oplc sets the standards for what
licensed you know
I I've sat on the PTSD commission for
three terms and there's a lot of
discussion within that commission about
um the fact that billing
insurance is
is pretty much how it's so necessary
that um the barriers to be able to do
that make
things so restrictive and so problematic
so I I what I don't want to do is I
don't want to make this process more
difficult because a lot of these folks
folks have to bill to survive they have
to be able to do that so
I'm so I'm I guess I'm trying
to I'm trying to
understand if this if your
language in your eyes you got you the
insurance guys think you guys think that
this makes things quicker and
smoother I think it clears up any
the minimum standard is that you're
licensed carriers are routinely
licensing are routinely credentialing
these types of providers all the time
they are an active part of all Insurance
networks um and we have laws insurance
laws in place to make sure that process
is going um you know within certain
parameters so from our view this
provision is not even necessary but
since it is there and we're going to
clean it up we want to make sure it's
clear that there's no barriers to it and
I think when they're doing the statutory
cleanup they remove the reference to the
temporary license because that statute
is no longer the appropriate one and in
doing so it kind of implies that you can
only be licensed under one statute and
we don't think that's the case if it's
reciprocal license it's if a temporary
license from an insurance perspective we
don't care if they have a license to
legally practice in New Hampshire that's
the only thing we're worried about and
that's what we're trying to reflect in
our amendment is just that's what the
criteria is that there is you have a
license and you're legally able to
practice in New Hampshire that's it I
think um there's probably other ways of
doing that we could put every single
statutory reference in there but then
each time those statutes change or
modified we're going to have to make
sure we go back and update this that's
why the language I'm proposing is just
broad enough that if you're licensed to
legally practice in New Hampshire that's
it is not it is not the legislator's job
to tell an insurance company how
committee how to develop that
relationship
it's the office of professional
licensure does just exactly that
licensing so I'm trying to understand I
think I understand if I if I can have
the prior your your opposition if you
will come back up here and explain to me
why because
the if this makes things
easier from a licensing standpoint I
don't know why his client would be
opposed to
that so help me out help me understand
why I'll do my best but I have to be
able to I have to speak with cander this
language exists because there was an
error when uh many Behavioral Health
Providers were not being credential by
insurance companies or the credential
was La was taking six months to a
year that's why this language
exists yes Behavioral Health Providers
are being credential today this language
has existed since
2019 would it have would it have taken
due course and and these folks would
have been credential I I don't know
because the law is in place what I do
know is that things changed after the
and you view the current statute being
as inhibiting the ability of folks to to
do
what the current statutory regimen has
enabled Behavior Health Providers to be
credentialed in 45 days which as an
aside there's another bill in Commerce
now about credentialing mhm um most
there are two different classifications
in the statute um most professionals are
licensed in 30 days not 45
days behavioral health professionals are
listed as Specialists and so they're 45
days so there's been a long history of
behavioral health professionals having a
hard time getting credential by
that that's fairly clear in the hearing
notes from
sb80 and that's why you know maybe it's
just fear of the unknown of going back
to when things were different maybe Miss
Heaton could be absolutely right that
things would be fine without
this my clients feel uncomfortable
taking that
risk because you're right
insurance and reimbursement is the
businesses so
okay are we boiling this down to a
disagreement over a 15-day
period no I I think we're boiling this
down to whether behavioral health
professionals need to be specifically
cited in the chapter as they are now
we
believe
that behavioral health professionals
under the mental health Practice Act
330a and 329b PSY board of psychology
need to continue to be referenced
specifically to not impair their ability
credential
okay go for it okay so I'm just looking
at
420-j col 8 C which is titled
reimbursement for providers waiting for
health carrier credentialing
certification MH right and I think that
about and specifically says for purposes
of RSA 420 J colon 4 and this section a
health care provider having a valid
license shall
include all mental health practice
practitioners licensed under RSA
330a and then this Bill gets rid of the
rest of
it um and then in B it's psychologist
licensed under RSA 329b and it just gets
rid of um an psychologist licensed in
another jurisdiction blah blah blah blah
so it basically talks about these two
Health Care Professionals and Rel and
relates to
RSA that they specific
rsas and you're concerned that well
they're concerned that if we remove that
RSA and just say licensed under the
state of New
Hampshire they
to confirm or they'll have to prove that
they're
licensed I'm just wondering I mean I I
understand why the language is in here
and I but I don't understand let me let
me let me ask the question a different
way maybe you aren't the one to ask it I
don't understand why removing those RSA
references is creates a barrier because
we're we're defining that RSA as the
process by which to get a license and I
think why why the insurance company
wants to get rid of it is
because that reference to the license
different um and correct me if I'm wrong
because I'm looking at you both that
that Li that license
reference refers to different levels of
licensure within that
profession so rather than and
complicating it all with different
license levels they're saying anybody
who's licensed as a mental health
practitioner and anybody who's licensed
as a
psychologist so I can understand their
concern but I also could understand how
removing that reference removes the
barrier that's am I explaining it
correctly yes
so do you want me to say one more
time you have the
floor so psychologists let's just take
social um the uh the um the first
one which is the m mental health pract
practitioners because I think that's a
more it's an easy one to explain if you
look under 330a there's different levels
of mental health practitioners that are
listed there depending on what kind of
Mental Health um criteria you have what
and then if you just refer to the RSA
then the insurance company is stuck with
looking at all these different levels of
professions whereas if you refer to it
as a entity then it already captures all
those
people I'm just trying to think of oh
okay let's just say that you have a
basket of citrus fruit and the insurance
company is saying all the the Citrus
food is it doesn't matter if you're a
lemon you're Lime You're an orange
doesn't matter all those people
are fall under this managed care
criteria to be reimbursed as opposed to
referring to an RSA where they have they
have to figure out oh gosh there's
lemons and limes and oranges listed
underneath all these things and so what
they're saying is doesn't matter what
kind of a citrus suit you are because
you're you're going to be all covered
because you are licensed to practice
mental health in New
Hampshire and you're saying that your
professions are concerned about that
because they've struggled so to get
reimbursed as evidenced by House Bill
right
okay I would add that it really this is
a housekeeping bill yeah and from our
perspective this is not a housekeeping
measure thank you because one of the
things I thought of was just to take
this out of this bill and send it on its
merry way and look at this issue because
it's not only is it is this the
only um issue where we have a licensing
hurdle or are there other professions in
New Hampshire no this is
it not a licensing
hurdle insurance hurle it's a
reimbursement I'm so sorry I've been
spending a lot of time in Commerce
because I mean today there was a there
was another bill about retroactive
denials there was a bill last week about
credentialing it's that's where most of
this action happens is in Commerce
happen I mean
need
okay I would I would like to ask go PLC
because I would imagine you help
representative Maguire write this even
though I'm a co-sponsor you helped her
write this right yes ma'am so why did
you put that section in
there um you know the the Managed Care
section because that's not really a I
wouldn't I wouldn't have thought that
was a cleanup issue so I I believe it
was just because the uh the license at
another jurisdiction issued a temporary
license to practice under RSA 329b 20
Roman 3 it was to remove because that
statute has been repealed so that was
the cleanup was just to remove that I
will say if the committee it would not
affect the day-to-day operations if the
committee decided we don't want to move
forward with that it it would what it is
clean up in the way to say this doesn't
exist we don't want to reference it
somewhere else but it um I don't think
that that part is the point of
contention the strikeout
is is not the issue here it's
it's it's whether or
not removing a specific RSA reference to
turn it into a generic license to
practice in the state of New Hampshire
phrase affects John Q practice you know
practitioner here I think that's and it
I think that's what that really boils
down to I mean and
since and you this is tough here because
you handle licensing you don't handle
credentialing no I guess I will I would
the piece of it that we're saying is we
want more people to be credential to be
able to Bill but there's no obligation I
mean there's certainly social pressure
for them to continue to to be able to
build like for them to be credential by
insurance companies but there's nothing
that binds them even if they are
licensed by any specific chapter um yes
even if this didn't exist and there were
no require like there was no standard
they wouldn't have to right so I I guess
that's that's kind of the discussion
what what I was positing is if that
section
introduces less Clarity by striking out
the piece and the committee decided
we're just not going to touch those two
lines uh it would not affect operations
I don't think for either of our agencies
I think we could continue to operate
status quo if you'd like to just say
that's that's that's what I'm getting at
here because it the status quo the
problem with cleanup bills is and I'll
warn everybody in the room that uses
that phrase sometimes cleanup bills turn
into gigantic mud pies extremely aware
of that Dynamic yes sir yes so so I am
more inclined to say if things are okay
right now I'm not inclined to change
them right because cleanup bills
literally deal with oh this statute
doesn't exist anymore oh this reference
is out of date that sort of
thing this seems a little more
complicated than that
and
I normally we see the argument go in the
other direction so where the users want
things very vague and insurance
companies want things very specific so
I'm
I can't I I could say I think the the
concern my understanding that my concern
from the insurance department who is
really more holding insurance company's
accountable than representing insurance
companies I will just I get yes um but I
I think the the deletion of those pieces
actually would introduce um it there
could be a misinterpreted legislative
intent I think is what they were saying
so no change would be better than just
removing the repealed St there one other
problem here is that on a cleanup bill
when it comes to to this type of
language that is appropriate to this
committee when we start referencing the
operations of relationships with
insurance company that is Commerce right
so that is not I think we might be
getting out of our lane here a little
bit um taking a cleanup Bill and going
just a little bit beyond cleanup so
that's if we if we'd like to strike it
from the language and and just not touch
it well I mean we haven't we haven't put
it in so I mean as this sits right now
the the amendment that that
representative Gro is going to draft
doesn't does it's fringer cat here it
doesn't contain or not contain this yet
it's just what we're discussing as to
whether it will contain that or not and
it sounds like realistically that that's
really outside of Edna's purview if
that's going to start affecting
relationships and if that change needs
to come forward bring it forward next
year in in a separate bill and we'll put
it to the appropriate committee
and I don't know that that's this one I
do I do believe that that language is in
the text of House Bill 82 as introduced
so if the committee wishes in your
Amendment representative grota then you
could just strike it in your Amendment
language I don't see that in here as I
don't see the the changing of this to be
licensed practice in the state of New
Hampshire no no no she's
no this is the first time that they've
come and talk to us about this so I
haven't done anything with this in in
reference so the discussion would be
we leave it the way it is in here we we
repeal we just take the whole section
out or we change it to the way the
insurance
company I mean the insurance commission
wants it to so but you seem to have an
idea I can tell yeah I mean we wanted we
I and I just sent it to you so it'll be
in your email later um we are
introducing the amendment so there is no
confusion about this practically
speaking this is not going to to change
the way we enforce this at all because
we already would enforce it as these you
know ENT these types of providers are
able to be credentialed and the
requirement is that they're licensed
that has how what it has always been and
it was that was the case well before
2019 these providers have been an
integral part of insurance networks for
many years so I don't see that changing
so from the insurance department
perspective this is not going to change
the way we've interpreted laws or the
way we're enforcing them but I think by
doing a partial deletion of those it can
be misconstrued and we don't want that
to happen and that's what we're trying
to Stave off so we would say either just
don't touch 420j and we'll clean it up
at another time in one of our insurance
technical bills or if we're going to
clean it up clean it up with our
misinterpreted so if you're talking
about leaving 420j alone then you're
removing sections I'm going to take out
section 15 and 26 yes I'm going to take
out section on page
four lines one to
three and I'm going to take out
section
26 page nine lines 8 through
nine okay well actually I'm going to
take out the whole 26 I'm going to take
out yes the whole section 26 so yes in
doing so then the strike through
language is not going to be struck
through that correct okay the the
statute will stand as presently as it
does presently okay and you're okay with
that yeah okay then it sounds like we've
after punching each other in the head 20
times we've we've solved this
problem yep okay just so that I'm not I
don't make a
mistake I'm going to make sure that I
send the draft the amendment to you and
we will meet and go over it that sounds
great um okay available whenever you
need okay I just don't want to steer the
cor the committee incorrectly right so
okay so as far as action on 82 um we're
final Omnibus on that and before we I
think that would be prudent because it's
it's been a little confusing so um so
we'll we'll recess
82 and um and we'll reconvene 82 once we
have that figure it out we have solved
just for for those watching the the
millions around the world watching on
YouTube um we did solve at least the
um the issue with the dieti that part
and uh we also solve the background
check problem that occurs in this as
well so those those matters have been
have been agreed
upon so yeah well I'm just in reference
to 82 what I'm talking so that's just
yep that's okay so so that those parts
have been figured out we've we've seem
to have have struck a a balance here
with the with the other part and I think
at that point we'll we'll wait on Final
language and and it doesn't necessarily
even
require a full subcommittee meeting
since we've talked about the substance
it's just looking at the language to
make sure it does what it does
so if there's if there's no other
concerns then I'll close the hearing on
82 and we will uh will'll convene at the
calendar
e